SENATE UH, BUDGET SUBCOMITTEE
NUMBER ONE ON EDUCATION WILL
COME TO ORDER. UH, THIS IS OUR
THIRD HEARING, UH OF THE OF 2024
AS THE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE. UM
WE HAVE DONE ONE ON STUDENT AID
AND DONE ONE ON THE OVERALL
FINANCING. OF, UM PROPOSITION 98
AND Kò THROUGH 14 EDUCATION. AND
TODAY, UH, THIS WILL BE OUR
SECOND HEARING THEN ON HIGHER
EDUCATION ISSUES. THERE'S FIVE
DISCUSSION ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
AND THEY COVER THE MAJOR BUDGET
ITEMS FOR THE UNIVERSITY,
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. IT'S AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING AND WE
WILL NOT BE TAKING VOTES TODAY.
HOWEVER WHENEVER SENATOR MIN
ARRIVES AND WHOEVER IS SPEAKING
AT THE TIME STOPS, I WILL CALL
THE ROLL TO A FORMALLY ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. UH, ANYWAY. WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN, UH, WITH ISSUE
NUMBER ONE WITH UPDATES FROM U,
èC PRESIDENT MICHAEL DRAKE AND
èC S¼ U CHANCELLOR MILDRED
GARCIA. REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WILL ALSO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PANEL OF THE SENATE BUDGET. UH,
SUBCOMITTEE CHAIR SENATOR WEINER
. WE WELCOME TO THE HEARING. HE
WILL JOIN THE SUBCOMITTEE FROM
THE DÍAS, UH, ON THE QUESTION
PERIOD ON CAMPUS CLIMATE. UM
FOLLOWING THE PRESENTATIONS,
ISSUES TWO THROUGH FOUR WILL
CONSIDER STUDENT HOUSING AND
ENROLLMENT UPDATES AT èC AND
èC S¼ U ISSUE FIVE. WE CONSIDER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS.
THERE'S SOME INDIVIDUAL ONES FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WITH THAT OH, I WOULD
WELCOME OUR FIRST PANEL TO THE
TABLE HERE, AND, UH, WE'LL HEAR
TESTIMONY FROM THE PANELISTS AND
THEN MOVE TO QUESTIONS. IT IS
OUR PRACTICE. TO, UM TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER WE DO EVERY ISSUE.
BUT IF THERE IS UNIQUE
DISCUSSION, UH OUT OF THE
QUESTIONS OF SENATOR WEINER, I'M
GONNA TAKE A SHOW OF HANDS TO
SEE IF PEOPLE WISH TO TESTIFY AT
THAT POINT AND ALLOW LIMITED
TESTIMONY. IF THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO DO IT, SO YOU DON'T
HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL THE END OF
ALL FIVE ITEMS TO DO TESTIMONY.
WITH THAT, UM THE FIRST PANEL.
WE HAVE PRESIDENT MICHAEL DRAKE
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
A CHANCELLOR MILDRED GARCIA OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM. A CHRIS FERGUSON FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. UH
JENNIFER PURCELL FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND WE ALSO HAVE SEA VERIN AND
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND RYAN STORM FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM WHO ARE AVAILABLE, UH, MY
SCRIPT SAYS ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR DETAILS. BUT THEY'RE REALLY
AVAILABLE FOR DETAILS. AND SO,
UH, WE WELCOME ALL SIX OF YOU
HERE. WE'RE GONNA GO IN THE
ORDER THAT I MENTIONED IN
OPENING COMMENTS AND I WOULD
WELCOME FIRST PRESIDENT MICHAEL
DRAKE FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. GOOD MORNING. AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SENATOR
LAIRD. NICE TO SEE YOU. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE. UH UH, WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM TO TALK ABOUT
THE LATEST OPPORTUNITIES AND
CHALLENGES FOR PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION AND FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA IN PARTICULAR. LET
ME BEGIN BY EXPRESSING MY DEEP
APPRECIATION FOR THE
LONG-STANDING PARTNERSHIP THE
UNIVERSITY HAS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND WITH GOVERNOR
NEWSOM. OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS, THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN LASER
FOCUSED ON ENSURING THAT WE ARE
SERVING THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
AND ALL THAT WE DO FROM
EDUCATING GROWING NUMBERS OF
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES TO
ENHANCING THE PIPELINE OF
TEACHERS AND HEALTH CARE WORKERS
TO EXPANDING OUR HEALTH
ENTERPRISE SO THAT IT CAN
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE WORLD CLASS
HEALTH CARE. AND TO REACH OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. SUPPORT
WE'VE RECEIVED FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR HAS
BEEN KEY TO OUR SUCCESS IN THESE
AREAS. WE RECOGNIZE, OF COURSE,
THAT THIS IS NOT A TYPICAL
BUDGET YEAR, THE STATE IS FACING
A GROWING DEFICIT AND CONTINUED
FISCAL UNCERTAINTY. AND THAT
MEANS THAT ALL OF YOU AND THE
GOVERNOR ARE IN THE UNENVIABLE
POSITION. OF HAVING TO MAKE
TOUGH CHOICES ABOUT NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET. WE'RE TREMENDOUSLY
GRATEFUL THAT IN THIS JUST IN
HIS JANUARY BUDGET INTRODUCTION,
GOVERNOR NEWSOM DEFERRED RATHER
THAN ELIMINATE ALTOGETHER, THE
5% FUNDING INCREASE. THESE
PLEDGED IN THE MULTI YEAR
FUNDING COMPACT WITH THE
UNIVERSITY. WE STAND READY TO DO
TO WORK WITH ALL OF YOU, OUR
PARTNERS IN THE LEGISLATURE. TO
PRESERVE THAT FUNDING SO THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO EXPAND ACCESS,
IMPROVE OUR OFFERINGS AND SERVE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WELL,
AS AN EXAMPLE OF THE INCREASES
IN FUNDING THAT YOU HAVE
PROVIDED OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
HAVE TRANSLATED INTO VERY
POSITIVE ENROLLMENT NUMBERS.
FALL. 2020 THREE REPRESENTED THE
UNIVERSITY'S LARGEST
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT
POPULATION. INCLUDING A RECORD
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
WE ENROLLED THE SMALLEST NUMBER
OF NON RESIDENTS STUDENTS SINCE
FALL OF 2017 WITH A THREE YEAR
DECLINE, NOW STANDING AT 16.6%
THANKS TO STATE SUPPORT. FOR THE
SECOND YEAR IN A ROW. WE ALSO
REDUCED NON-RESIDENT ENROLLMENT
AND INCREASED CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT ENROLLMENT AT U èC,
BERKELEY, U èC, L A AND U èC
SAN DIEGO. UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT OF UNDERREPRESENTED
GROUPS ALSO INCREASED COMPARED
TO LAST YEAR. AS WE CONTINUE TO
ENROLL MORE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS THAN ANY UNIVERSITY OF
OUR CALIBER, UH, OF OUR CALIBER
IN THE NATION. THIS IS VERY
REFLECTIVE OF OUR STRONG
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM AND ONE THAT WE
ARE VERY PROUD OF. THERE'S A
REASON THERE'S REASON TO BE
HOPEFUL ABOUT FUTURE ENROLLMENT
AS WELL. JUST A FEW DAYS AGO,
THE UNIVERSITY PUBLISHED DATA
ABOUT UNDERGRADUATE APPLICATIONS
FOR FALL OF 2024, AND OVER ALL
THOSE APPLICATION NUMBERS
INCREASED BY 1.5% COMPARED TO
LAST YEAR. 1.5% IS ABOUT 4000
ADDITIONAL STUDENT APPLICATIONS
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR. LARGELY
DRIVEN BY A RISE IN APPLICATIONS
FROM CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS,
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANSFER
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS FROM
HISTORICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED
GROUPS AND HIGHER EDUCATION. SO
I WANNA THANK THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
MAKING THESE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
POSSIBLE. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
INCREASE OUR ENROLLMENT FOR THE
COMING ACADEMIC YEAR. BEYOND
ENROLMENT GROWTH. WE'RE MAKING
PROGRESS ON OTHER COMPACT
COMMITMENTS, I'LL SHARE A FEW
HIGHLIGHTS. FIRST THE COMPACT
CALLS ON US TO APPROVE THE
AFFORDABILITY OF THE UNIVERSITY
BY CONTINUING TO EXPAND DEBT
FREE PATHWAYS FOR UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS AND BY REDUCING NON
TUITION EXPENSES, SUCH AS
TEXTBOOKS, HOUSING, FOOD AND
TRANSPORTATION. I'M PROUD THAT
WE'VE BEEN FUNDING OUR OWN DEBT
FREE PROGRAM FOR TWO YEARS NOW,
WITH EXPANDED FINANCIAL AID AND
THE STATE'S MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM. AND IT'S
WORKING. ARE GRADUATING CLASS IN
2022 HAD THE LOWEST PROPORTION
OF STUDENTS WITH DEBT IN THE
PAST 10 YEARS, MORE THAN HALF OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS GRADUATE
ENTIRELY DEBT FREE. IN THE AREA
OF STUDENT AND THOSE WHO
GRADUATE WITH THAT ACTUALLY
GRADUATE WITH THAT THAT IS LOWER
THAN THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
SUBSTANTIALLY. IN THE AREA OF
STUDENT HOUSING. SPECIFICALLY
OUR CAMPUSES CONTINUE TO BUILD
MORE OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE WE
NEED FOR OUR STUDENTS. AS YOU
KNOW, OUR CAMPUS IS RESIDE IN
SOME OF THE STATE'S MOST
COMPETITIVE HOUSING MARKETS, SO
ADDING STUDENT HOUSING IS A
CRITICAL PRIORITY. SINCE THE
LAUNCH OF OUR STUDENT HOUSING
INITIATIVE IN 2015, THE
UNIVERSITY HAS ADDED MORE THAN
28,000 BEDS ACROSS THE SYSTEM.
AND RIGHT NOW WE ARE BUILDING OR
READY TO CONSTRUCT MORE THAN
15,000 NEW STUDENT BEDS. OF
THESE 6700 BEDS WILL BE READY BY
THE FALL OF 2025. SECOND THE
COMPACT CALLS FOR THE UNIVERSITY
TO FULLY PARTICIPATE IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CRADLE TO
CAREER DATA SYSTEM. UNIVERSITY
TOOK THE LEAD IN DRAFTING
INITIAL DATA SPECIFICATIONS TO
SUPPORT FAL TO CAREER AND OTHER
SEGMENTS. WE ALSO SERVE THE ON
THE CRADLE TO CAREER INFORMATION
SECURITY TASK FORCE TO HELP
BUILD OUT EFFECTIVE INFORMATION
SECURITY PRACTICES AND POLICIES,
ALONG WITH TESTING AND
VALIDATION VALIDATION PLAN. AS
OF LAST FALL, WE ARE ALSO
SHARING STUDENT DATA WITH THE
CRADLE TO CAREER SYSTEM. THIS
YEAR AT THE UNIVERSITY IS ALSO
REQUESTING A $3.5 MILLION IN
ONGOING FUNDS TO ESTABLISH AND
SUPPORT ENROLLMENT FOR TWO NEW
HEALTH SCIENCES PROGRAMS MODELED
AFTER OUR PRIME OR U èC
PROGRAMS AND MEDICAL EDUCATION
STARTED ABOUT 20 YEARS AGO,
WHICH HAVE DRAMATICALLY
INCREASED THE NUMBER OF
PHYSICIANS SERVING UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
SOMETHING WE'RE VERY PROUD OF
THESE NEW PROGRAMS WOULD EXPAND
AN INNOVATIVE TRAINING
CURRICULUM FOCUSED ON ADDRESSING
HEALTH CARE, WORKFORCE SHORTAGES
AND MEETING THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS UNDER SERVE
POPULATIONS MORE BROADLY. AND
SAY, WE'LL BE TALKING A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THOSE LATER ON, SO WE
APPRECIATE THAT SUPPORT AS WELL.
I WILL CLOSE BY REITERATING HOW
MUCH WE APPRECIATE THE STRONG
PARTNERSHIP WE HAVE WITH THE
STATE LEGISLATURE. WE KNOW THAT
MANAGING SO MANY BUDGET REQUESTS
IS CHALLENGING, AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR RECOGNITION OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION TO THE FUTURE OF OUR
STATE. I LOOK FORWARD TO I'M
HAPPY TO BE HERE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO QUESTIONS LATER ON
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
JUST BEFORE WE MOVE, UH TO
CHANCELLOR GARCIA, I BEEN ASKED
THAT WE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
LAIRD HERE, SENATOR LAIRD. HERE
SENATOR. MIN MIN HERE, SENATOR
WILK. WE HAVE A QUORUM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. UH THEN I'M GOING
TO WELCOME THE CHANCELLOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CENTER. UH, SYSTEM. MILDRED
GARCIA, CHAIR LED AND SENATORS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY. SINCE THIS
IS MY FIRST TIME APPEARING
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE, I'D LIKE
TO BEGIN WITH A FEW INTRODUCTORY
REMARKS. I BEGAN MY TENURE AS
CHANCELLOR ON OCTOBER 1ST OF
LAST YEAR. SERVING AS A CSU'S
11TH CHANCELLOR. THE FIRST
LATINA IN THIS ROLE IS ONE OF MY
GREATEST LIFE HONORS IN SO MANY
RESPECTS, THE CSU STORY MIRRORS
MIRRORS MIRRORS MY OWN. I SEE
MYSELF IN THE STUDENTS WE SERVE.
I AM A FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENT, THE DAUGHTER OF HUMBLE
AND PROUD PARENTS WHO MIGRATED
TO BROOKLYN FROM PUERTO RICO
WITH FIVE OF THEIR SEVEN
CHILDREN. I WAS ONE OF THOSE
OOPS, BABIES. I GREW UP IN A
POOR AND BEAUTIFULLY DIVERSE
NEIGHBORHOOD NEAR THE FACTORIES
WHERE MY PARENTS WORKED. BUT
WHILE MY NEIGHBORS WERE DIVERSE,
THEIR DREAMS WERE THE SAME TO
CREATE A BETTER LIFE FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS. THANKS TO MY
PARENTS, VISION, SELFLESS
SACRIFICE AND THEIR BELIEF IN
THE TRANSFORMATIVE POWER OF
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION. I HAVE
LIVED THAT DREAM. AND THAT'S THE
REASON I CHOSE TO RETURN TO THE
CSU. IT IS BECAUSE OF THE WORK
WE DO AND THE STUDENTS. WE SERVE
AMERICA'S NEW MAJORITY, THE
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS,
STUDENTS OF COLOR, LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND ADULTS LOOKING FOR
NEW AND BRIGHTER OPPORTUNITIES.
AS CHANCELLOR. I NOW HAVE THE
PROFOUND HONOR TO LEAD THE
NATION'S LARGEST AND MOST
DIVERSE, FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM. IT'S GREATEST DRIVER OF
SOCIAL MOBILITY AND AN ENGINE OF
ECONOMIC VITALITY FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA, WHILE MY TENURE
IS ONLY NEARING THE END OF ITS
FIFTH MONTH THAT SHORT TIME HAS
DEMONSTRATED TO ME THAT THE èC
S¼ U IS ON A STEEPLY UPWARD
TRAJECTORY AND BUILDING POSITIVE
MOMENTUM. THE CSU STANDS ALONE,
AMONG OTHER SYSTEMS IN ITS SIZE
AND SCOPE. WE ARE ONE SYSTEM,
BUT OUR 20 THREE UNIVERSITIES
ARE AS DIVERSE AS OUR GREAT
STATE AND ITS CITIZENS IN THEIR
REGIONS ARE UNIVERSITIES SERVE
AS ANCHOR INSTITUTIONS
LEVERAGING THEIR HUMAN,
INTELLECTUAL AND FISCAL
RESOURCES TO ENHANCE THE SOCIAL,
CULTURAL AND ECONOMIC PROSPERITY
OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT THEY
SERVE. MANY OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
PLACE BOUND OR MORE ACCURATELY
PLACED, COMMITTED AND RESIDE
NEAR THE CAMPUSES THEY ATTEND
AFTER GRADUATION. 80% OF OUR
STUDENTS CONTINUE TO LIVE AND
WORK WITHIN A 50 MILE RADIUS OF
THEIR ALMA MATER. THEY ARE THE
TEACHERS, THE ENGINEERS, THE
CAREGIVERS, THE BUSINESS
LEADERS, CIVIC LEADERS AND
LEGISLATORS. THE INVESTMENT. WE
MAKE U S¼ LEGISLATORS FUNDING
THE CSU AND WE THE UNIVERSITY
THROUGH ACADEMIC PROGRAM AND
HOLISTIC STUDENT SUPPORT IS A
DIRECT INVESTMENT BACK INTO NOT
ONLY OUR STUDENTS, BUT THE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THEY PROUDLY CALL HOME AND GO ON
TO SERVE. LIKE MICHAEL DRAKE AND
MY FRIEND. I KNOW THESE ARE
DIFFICULT TIMES FISCAL TIMES FOR
THE STATE. YOU ARE FACED WITH
MANY COMPETING NEEDS AN EQUAL
NUMBER OF DIFFICULT CHOICES, BUT
BUT ALLOW ME TO UNDERSCORE WHY
THE STATE'S ONGOING INVESTMENT
IN THE èC S¼ U IS SO VITALLY
IMPORTANT. FIRST THE FISCAL
REALITY IS THAT èC S¼ U S¼
HEAVILY DEPENDENT ON STATE
FUNDING, UNLIKE OTHER
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND
SYSTEMS, WE ESSENTIALLY RELY ON
ONLY TWO AND ONLY TWO REVENUE
SOURCES, THE STATE GENERAL FUND
AND STUDENT TUITION AND FEES. WE
ARE FACED. WE ARE FACING
INCREASED COSTS FROM RECENT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
, RISING HEALTH INSURANCE
PREMIUMS AND COST ASSOCIATED
WITH OUR STEADFAST COMMITMENT TO
STRENGTHEN OUR TITLE IX AND
OTHER ANTI DISCRIMINATION
PROGRAMS AND TO ACHIEVE FULL AND
TIMELY COMPLIANCE WITH NRA AND
CAL NUR COMBINE THESE ADDITIONAL
COST TOTAL MORE THAN $300
MILLION. WE PLAN FOR THESE
ADDITIONAL EXPENSES AND RELIANCE
ON SUSTAINED STATE INVESTMENT
WITHOUT THE FUNDING IDENTIFIED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL, THE ONLY SOURCE OF
ADDED REVENUE WE CAN COUNT ON
FOR OPERATING COSTS IS $98
MILLION FROM OUR NEW TUITION
PLAN. THE BALANCE OF OUR NEW
TUITION REVENUE. 49 MILLION IS
RIGHTFULLY COMMITTED TO
FINANCIAL AID SO THAT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE FULL COST
OF THEIR TUITION COVERED. THE
IMPORTANCE OF SUSTAINED STATE
FUNDING IS NOT JUST ABOUT
DOLLARS AND CENTS. IT IS ALSO
PREDICTABILITY AND OUR ABILITY
TO APPROPRIATELY PLAN TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF OUR DIVERSE
STUDENTS. CONSIDERING BOTH THE
GOVERNOR'S MULTIYEAR COMPACT AND
THE FIVE YEAR TUITION PLAN WE
ADOPTED LAST SEPTEMBER. OUR
REVENUE PROJECTS ENABLED US TO
REACH MULTIYEAR CONTRACTS WITH
OUR LABOR UNIONS. AS YOU KNOW,
THIS AGREEMENT WAS REACHED AFTER
A VERY DIFFICULT NEGOTIATIONS,
BUT WE BELIEVE THEY ARE
REASONABLE AND THAT THEY PROVIDE
FAIR AND COMPETITIVE
COMPENSATION TO OUR WORLD CLASS
FACULTY AND STAFF WHO ARE SO
FOUNDATIONAL TO THE SUCCESS OF
OUR STUDENTS. THESE CONTRACTS
ALSO INCLUDE INCREASED PARENTAL
LEAVE AND A RETURN TO SALARY
STEPS, BOTH OF WHICH ARE A
PRIORITY OF THE LEGISLATURE. I
AM COMMITTED TO THE LONG TERM
FINANCIAL SUSTAINABILITY OF THE
UNIVERSITY. WE MUST BRING OUR
COSTS IN LINE WITH REVENUES, THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND EACH OF
OUR UNIVERSITIES HAVE ALREADY
BEGUN THE CHALLENGING AND OFTEN
PAINFUL PROCESS OF FINDING WAYS
TO COVER OUR ADDITIONAL COSTS
USING RESERVES IF REQUIRED IN
APPROPRIATE BUT MORE OFTEN BY
MAKING THE HARD DECISIONS THAT
WILL TRANSLATE INTO ONGOING
SAVINGS. PLEASE HEAR ME WHEN I
SAY WE ARE STRETCHING. WE ARE
DOING OUR PART. IN ADDITION TO
DEPLOYING DIFFICULT COST
CONTAINMENT STRATEGIES AT BOTH
THE UNIVERSITY AND SYSTEM LEVEL,
WE ARE ALSO INTRODUCED KEY FISH
AND STREAK STRATEGIES, INCLUDING
AN ENROLLMENT TARGET AND BUDGET
REALLOCATION PLAN THAT WILL
BETTER ALIGN FUNDING RESOURCES
WITH THE REALITIES OF SHIFTING
DEMOGRAPHICS AND STUDENT DEMAND.
AND WE ARE IDENTIFYING
ADDITIONAL COLLABORATION
OPPORTUNITIES AMONG OUR
UNIVERSITIES TO FURTHER REDUCE
COSTS. BUT WITHOUT SUSTAINED
STATE FUNDING. THIS WORK BECOMES
EXCEEDINGLY DIFFICULT. OUR
PROGRESS IN MISSION. CRITICAL
AREAS WILL BE SLOWED TO THE
DETRIMENT OF OUR DIVERSE AND
DESERVING STUDENTS. WHEN
STUDENTS ENROLL AT THE èC S¼ U,
THEY EXPECT THEY WILL RECEIVE
THE QUALITY ACADEMIC PROGRAMMING
AND STUDENT SUPPORT. THEY NEED
TO GRADUATE IN A TIMELY MANNER.
THESE CANNOT BE TURNED ON ONE
YEAR AND OFF THE NEXT DUE TO
VOLATILITY IN OUR ABILITY TO PAY
FOR THEM. PREDICTABILITY IS AN
IMPORTANT IS AS IMPORTANT A
CURRENCY AS A MONEY ITSELF.
DESPITE THE FOREGOING I AM PROUD
TO REPORT THE èC S¼ U HAS
EMERGED FROM A PERIOD OF
CHALLENGE AND TRANSITION AND IS
NOW ON A STEEP UPWARD TRAJECTORY
. THE CSU'S FLAGSHIP STUDENT
SUCCESS EFFORT GRADUATION
INITIATIVE, 2025 HAS LED TO AN
ALL TIME HIGH IN GRADUATION
RATES AND FROM FOR STUDENTS FROM
ALL BACKGROUNDS. OUR FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE HAS NEARLY
DOUBLED SINCE 2015 RESULTING
FROM 19% TO 35% IN FACT, THE èC
S¼ U HAS PRODUCED A CUMULATIVE
TOTAL OF MORE THAN 100 AND
50,000 ADDITIONAL DEGREE HOLDERS
SINCE THIS INITIATIVE WAS
LAUNCHED. ALTHOUGH EQUITY GAPS
HAVE PROVEN STUBBORN, THE èC S¼
U IS ADDRESSING THEM HEAD ON BY
IMPLEMENTING AN EQUITY ACTION
PLAN ACROSS ALL 20 THREE
UNIVERSITIES. IMPROVED
GRADUATION RATES ALSO MEAN
IMPROVED ACCESS FOR FUTURE
STUDENTS. WE ARE ALSO CLOSING
THE GAP TOWARDS THE STATE
ENROLLMENT TARGET, CONTRARY TO
RECENT MEDIA REPORTS, ENROLLMENT
FOR THE CURRENT YEAR IS UP 2%
MORE THAN 7500 STUDENTS OF 2223.
THIS WAS ACHIEVED THROUGH
INTENTIONAL WORK TO RETAIN AND
SUPPORT CONTINUING STUDENTS.
ADDITIONALLY WE ENROLLED THE
LARGEST FRESHMAN CLASS IN THE
èC S¼ U S¼ HISTORY MORE THAN
64,000, CALIFORNIANS AND
UNDERGRADUATE APPLICATIONS FOR
2025 ARE UP OVER THE HØI YEAR,
SIGNALING CONTINUED MOMENTUM
UPWARD. THE CSU IS A MODEL FOR
SERVING AMERICA'S NEW MAJORITY
21 OF OUR 23 CAMPUSES ARE
HISPANIC SERVICE SERVING
INSTITUTIONS, AND THE MAJORITY
ARE ASIAN, AMERICAN AND NATIVE
AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
SERVING INSTITUTIONS. WE
RECENTLY COMPLETED A SYSTEM WIDE
INVENTORY OF EXISTING EFFORTS
ACROSS ALL 20 THREE UNIVERSITIES
TO SUPPORT BLACK STUDENT SUCCESS
. THE RESULTING REPORT ASSESSES
THE MANY PROGRAMS IN PLACE
HIGHLIGHTS CURRENT AREAS OF
STRENGTH THAT CAN SCALED ACROSS
THE SYSTEM AND SETS FORTH
UNIVERSITY ACTION ITEMS THAT
ALIGN WITH THE RECOMMENDATIONS
OF THE CSU'S BLACK STUDENT
SUCCESS REPORT ACTION ITEMS THAT
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED OVER THE
NEXT 18 MONTHS. WE ARE COMMITTED
TO AND MAKING GREAT STRIDES IN
TURNING WEAKNESSES INTO
STRENGTH, INCLUDING BOLSTERING
OUR UNIVERSITY'S TITLE NINE AND
OTHER ANTI DISCRIMINATION,
HARASSMENT AND RETALIATION
PROGRAMS GUIDED BY AUTHENTIC
CONSULTATION WITH NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES, WE ARE
PRIORITIZING THE TIMELY AND
RESPECTFUL REPATRIATION OF
NATIVE AMERICAN ANCESTORS AND
CULTURAL ITEMS HELD IN OUR
CAMPUS FAR TOO LONG. WE CONTINUE
TO COLLABORATE WITH COMMUNITY
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND ACROSS
HIGHER ED SEGMENTS TO IDENTIFY
AND SCALE HIGH IMPACT PRACTICES.
THESE EXAMPLES IN MANY MORE
UNDERSCORE AN UNDENIABLE
POSITIVE MOMENTUM FOR THE CSU. A
MOMENTUM THAT HAS ME OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT THE CSU'S FUTURE. HOWEVER
I MUST EMPHASIZE THE SUSTAINING
THIS CRITICAL MOMENTUM REQUIRES
THE NECESSARY ONGOING RESOURCES.
THE èC S¼ U ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN TWO KEY AREAS FIRST,
BECAUSE OF THE REASONS I
OUTLINED EARLIER, WE ASKED FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND IN CONTINUING
TO HONOR THE FUNDING SET FORTH
IN THE MULTIYEAR COMPACT, EITHER
AS ORIGINALLY STRUCTURED OR AS
MODIFIED AND GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL AND
SECOND WE ASK POOR FOR EDUCATION
FACILITIES BOND THAT INCLUDES
HIGHER EDUCATION SO THAT WE CAN
BRING OUR BUILDINGS, MORE THAN
HALF OF WHICH ARE OVER 50 YEARS
OLD TO MODERN ACADEMIC STANDARDS
AND TO ADDRESS SAFETY AND
ACCESSIBILITY ISSUES. I LEAVE
YOU WITH A COMMITMENT. I COMMIT
TO YOU THAT THE èC S¼ U WILL
CONTINUE TO DEMONSTRATE THAT
RESOURCES ENTRUSTED TO US ARE
NOT AN EXPENDITURE, BUT AN
INVESTMENT AN INVESTMENT WITH
DIVIDENDS MEASURED IN SOCIAL
MOBILITY AND MORE VITAL
COMMUNITIES AND EMPOWERING
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE, DIVERSE AND
EDUCATED WORKFORCE. OUR BUSINESS
COMMUNITY GREATEST COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGES IS ALL OF THAT ALL AT
A SCALE. ONLY THE èC S¼ U CAN
PROVIDE AN AFFORDABLE, HIGH
QUALITY HOUSE. I AGREE IS A
PRIVATE GOOD AND IT IS A PUBLIC
GOOD AND WORTHY AND UNNECESSARY
INVESTMENT IN BOTH STRONG AND
VERY CHALLENGING ECONOMIC TIMES.
SHE LEERED AND SENATORS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY AND FOR LISTENING
TO ME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. UH
UM, AN AUSPICIOUS MAIDEN
APPEARANCE. THANK YOU, AND WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. CHAIR UH, CHRIS
FERGUSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, AND I'LL
KEEP MY REMARKS RATHER BRIEF.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. UH,
PROPOSES TO, UH, DEFERRALS THE
DEFERRALS REPRESENT, UM, A
DEFERMENT OF THE PLANNED
INVESTMENTS OF 5% IN THE, UH èC
S¼ U AND U èC PURSUANT TO THE
COMPACTS THAT REFLECTS ROUGHLY,
UH 228 MILLION FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
ROUGHLY 240 MILLION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY. WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO THE OVERALL
GOALS OF THE COMPACTS. WE REMAIN
COMMITTED TO THE ENROLLMENT
TARGETS AND THE COMPACTS AND TO
THE EXTENT THE SEGMENTS MAY HAVE
BEEN UNDER COMMITTED TO GETTING
TO THOSE, UH, BACK TO THOSE
TARGETS, UM, OVER THE COURSE OF
THE, UH, COMPACT AS WELL. SO
WITH THAT I'LL CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
AND WE'LL MOVE TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PANELS. UH, JENNIFER
PELEG ANALYST'S OFFICE SO AS
DESCRIBED THE GOVERNOR'S MAIN
PROPOSALS FOR èC AND èC S¼ U
THIS YEAR ARE THE DEFERRALS. UM,
AS YOU'VE HEARD WHAT THE
DEFERRALS DO IS IT EFFECTIVELY
DELAYS THE THIRD YEAR COMPACT
PAYMENTS AND THEN COME 2526
PROVIDES A ONE TIME BACK PAYMENT
AS WELL AS DOUBLING UP YEAR
THREE AND YEAR, FOUR ONGOING
FUNDING IN 2526. SO WHILE U èC
N èC S¼ U WOULDN'T RECEIVE
FUND AUGMENTATION IN 2425,
THEY'D BE EXPECTED TO SPEND AT A
HIGHER LEVEL. THOUGH NEITHER
SEGMENT HAS FINALIZED THEIR
PLANS. BOTH HAVE INDICATED THAT
THEY WOULD LIKELY RESPOND BY
DRAWING DOWN THEIR UNCOMMITTED
RESERVES. AS YOU KNOW, WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THE DEFERRAL
PROPOSALS AND HOLDING FUNDING
AND SPENDING FLAT IN 2425 FOR
BOTH STIGMAS. COME 2526 IF THE
STATE BUDGET CONDITION HAS
IMPROVED IF THE DEFICITS HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSED, THE LEGISLATURE
AT THAT TIME COULD DECIDE WHAT
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATIONS TO
PROVIDE. WE HAVE SEVERAL
CONCERNS WITH THE DEFERRALS. ONE
CONCERN IS THAT JUST PAYING
BILLS LATE IS GENERALLY
CONSIDERED BAD FISCAL PRACTICE.
ANOTHER CONCERN IS THAT UNTIL
THE STATE PAYS THE BILL AND CSU
ARE SUPPORTING THIS HIGHER
FUNDING WITH THEIR OWN
RESOURCES. AS I INDICATED. BOTH
ARE LIKELY TO USE UNCOMMITTED
RESERVES AS OF THE CLOSE OF LAST
FISCAL YEAR. SO JUNE OF 23, YOU
SEE WAS REPORTING THAT IT HAD
TOTAL CORE RESERVES OF 1.4
BILLION, OF WHICH 238 MILLION
WERE UNCOMMITTED RESERVES. THOSE
UNCOMMITTED RESERVES EQUATE TO
NINE DAYS OF OPERATING EXPENSES
AT èC S¼ U. èC S¼ U REPORTS
OVER THAT SAME TIME PERIOD THAT
IT HAS 2.5 BILLION IN TOTAL CORE
RESERVES, OF WHICH 766 MILLION
ARE UNCOMMITTED IN èC S¼ U
TERMS THAT EQUATES TO 1.1 MONTH
OF OPERATING EXPENDITURES, SO
BOTH U èC AND èC S¼ U RIGHT
NOW HAVE OPERATING EXPENDITURES
THAT ARE BELOW A MINIMUM OF TWO
MONTHS, WHICH IS WHAT THE
GOVERNOR GOVERNMENT FINANCE
OFFICERS RECOMMENDS AS A MEN
MEMBERS ARE LEVEL. IN ADDITION,
IF THE SEGMENTS BORROW, THEN
THEY'RE GONNA BE ACCRUING
INTEREST COST RATHER THAN
ACTUALLY USING RESOURCES FOR
INSTRUCTION AND OTHER OPERATING
COSTS. DEFERRALS ALSO PUT BOTH
THE SEGMENTS AND THE STATE AT
RISK. SO COME 2425. THE STATE
WOULD HAVE THIS PRICE TAG OF 1.5
BILLION BETWEEN THE TWO SEGMENTS
BETWEEN THE BACK PAYMENTS AND
THE DOUBLING UP OF ONGOING
RESOURCES. SO PLACES THE STATE
AT RISK OF NOT BEING ABLE EITHER
TO PROVIDE THE PAYMENT AND
HAVING TO DELAY IT EVEN LONGER,
OR CUTTING OTHER STATE PROGRAMS
TO FIND ROOM FOR THAT 1.5
BILLION. THE SEGMENTS, THEN
COULD POTENTIALLY BE FACING CUTS
IN 2526. IF THE STATE CAN'T COME
UP WITH RESOURCES TO PROVIDE
THAT 1.5 BILLION UM AND THEY'LL
BE DOING SO HAVING JUST PROPPED
UP THEIR FUNDING IN 2425 AND
ENTERING WITH FEWER RESERVES
BECAUSE THEY WILL HAVE USED
RESERVES IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
EVEN WITHOUT A GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION IN 2425. BOTH
STIGMAS WILL HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL REVENUE TO COVER SOME
SPENDING PRIORITIES, SO THEY'VE
MENTIONED THAT BOTH SEGMENTS ARE
RAISING TUITION FOR U èC. THIS
WILL GENERATE 100 AND 17 MILLION
IN ADDITIONAL TUITION DOLLARS
YOU SEE, WILL GENERATE ABOUT 99
MILLION IN ADDITIONAL TUITION
DOLLARS, YOU SEE, HAS ALSO
IDENTIFIED SOME ALTERNATIVE FUND
SOURCES THAT THEY'RE USING, LIKE
INVESTMENT EARNINGS. THOSE TOTAL
100 AND 5 MILLION SO WITH THOSE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES, BOTH
SEGMENTS CAN DO AGAINST SOME
SPENDING INCREASES, BUT JUST NOT
EVERYTHING THAT THAT THEY'RE
DESIRING TO DO. YOU NCSU ARE IN
A MORE ADVANTAGEOUS FISCAL
POSITION THAN SOME OF THE OTHER
STATE AGENCIES YOU'LL HEAR FROM
THAT RELY SOLELY ON GENERAL FUND
. THEY DO HAVE SOME NON STATE
RESOURCES TO TURN TO BEYOND THE
DEFERRAL. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DOESN'T HAVE MANY BUDGET
SOLUTIONS THAT INVOLVE OR èC S¼
U. UM, TO TRY TO HELP THE
LEGISLATURE BALANCE THE BUDGET.
WE WORKED WITH THE SEGMENTS OVER
THE LAST FEW MONTHS TO TRY TO
IDENTIFY IF THERE WERE OTHER
BUDGET SOLUTION OPPORTUNITIES.
WE FOCUS PRIMARILY ON FUNDS THAT
HADN'T BEEN ENCUMBERED OR SPENT,
UH, FROM RECENT INITIATIVES.
OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS, THE
STATE PROVIDED WITH ONE POINT
THREE BILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR ABOUT 50 INITIATIVES.
ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF THOSE
INITIATIVES HAVE SOME REMAINING
FUNDING IN TOTAL, ABOUT THREE
125 MILLION AS OF JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR. AT CSU, THE STATE
PROVIDED ONE POINT 1,000,000,001
TIME GENERAL FUND OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS FOR 50 INITIATIVES.
VERY LITTLE OF THAT MONEY
REMAINS AVAILABLE, BUT SOME
STILL DOES. SO 26 MILLION FROM
PROGRAMMATIC èC, S¼ U
INITIATIVES 100 AND 45 MILLION
FROM CAPITAL PROJECTS THAT WERE
CASH FUNDED. SO WE DO RECOMMEND
REVERTING. THESE ONE TIME FUNDS
AND TOTAL AGAIN IS THREE 125
MILLION FOR, UH, 100 AND 71
MILLION FOR èC S¼ U REVERTING
THE ONE TIME FUNDS WOULD LIKELY
BE LESS DISRUPTIVE THAN CUTTING
ONGOING PROGRAMS. IT ALSO ALLOWS
THE STATE TO RETAIN MORE OF ITS
RESERVES FOR NEXT YEAR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
PRESENTATIONS, AND IN A LITTLE
BIT, WE WILL GET TO THE
QUESTIONS ON THE SUBSTANCE OF
THE BUDGET. FOR NOW, I AM GOING
TO RECOGNIZE THE CHAIR OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE. SENATOR WEINER
FOR QUESTIONS. UH, THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. UH, MR CHAIRMAN,
I APPRECIATE THE COURTESY. UM,
I'M HERE NOT IN MY CAPACITY TO
CHAIR A BUDGET. BUT AS A SENATOR
WHO REPRESENTS, UH, SEVERAL
CAMPUSES THAT FRANKLY, THE BEST
YOU SEE, AND THE BEST YOU YOU,
UH èC S¼ U CAMPUSES IN SAN
FRANCISCO. UM WILL BE PUTTING.
WE'LL BE PUTTING THAT TO SAN
FRANCISCO AND THEY ARE THE BEST
CAMPUSES. YEAH, WE'LL BE PUTTING
THAT TO VOTE AND YOU ARE OUT
VOTED UM SO, UH, FIRST OF ALL,
UM, I, I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
FOR PRESENTATION TODAY AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK. I AM A HUGE
FAN OF BOTH THE èC S¼ U AND U
èC SYSTEMS. I THINK THESE TWO
SYSTEMS ARE, UM THEY'RE THE
CROWN JEWELS OF NOT JUST THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM, BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE.
UH, BUT, FRANKLY, UH, NATIONALLY
AND INTERNATIONALLY. I MEAN,
JUST, UM THEY ARE, UH, WE
PIONEERED, UH, PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION AS A PATHWAY TO THE
MIDDLE CLASS, AND I'M JUST SO
GRATEFUL FOR BOTH SYSTEMS. UH,
I'M ALSO A BIG FAN OF BOTH OF
YOU PERSONALLY, UM I THINK
YOU'RE DOING INCREDIBLE. WORK
I'M JUST VERY GRATEFUL FOR
EVERYTHING THAT, UH, THAT YOU
DO, UM, SO, UH, ONE OF THE THING
THE GREATEST STRENGTHS OF BOTH
SYSTEMS IS THAT THIS IS A PLACE
WHERE STUDENTS OF DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS CAN BE TOGETHER, UH,
ON CAMPUS IN CLASSROOMS AND
ACTIVITIES AND AGREE. DISAGREE
HAVE DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES,
OVERLAPPING EXPERIENCES AND
STILL BE PART OF A CAMPUS. UH,
COMMUNITY, UM, AND SAY THINGS
THAT MAKE OTHER PEOPLE
UNCOMFORTABLE AT TIMES, UH AND
JUST HAVE THAT KIND OF, UH, FREE
SPEECH AND COLLABORATION. UH,
AND IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
UM AS I'VE TALKED TO BOTH OF YOU
ABOUT, AND AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM
VERY MANY PEOPLE, I ASSUME, UM I
AND OTHERS HAVE A LOT OF
CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING.
NOT ALL OF THE CAMPUSES, BUT ON
SOME OF THE CAMPUSES NOW, UH AND
WHAT THAT MEANS. UM UH FOR, UH,
NOT ONLY JEWISH STUDENTS, BUT
DEFINITELY FOR JEWISH, UH,
STUDENTS IN TERMS OF, UH,
WHETHER THEY FEEL SAFE ON
CAMPUS, AND MANY DO NOT UH,
WHETHER THEY FEEL LIKE THEY CAN
EXPRESS WHO THEY ARE, AND THERE
ARE STUDENTS WHO DO NOT FEEL
COMFORTABLE WEARING A STAR OF
DAVID OR A KIPPAH, UH, ON CAMPUS
, UH, WHETHER THEY CAN GATHER
SAFELY WITHOUT BEING HARASSED.
INTIMIDATED UM, ASSAULTED,
EVACUATED WITH SECURITY. UM
WHETHER, UH, THEY CAN JUST BE
WHO THEY ARE, WHETHER THEY CAN
INVITE SPEAKERS TO CAMPUS
WITHOUT THOSE SPEAKERS BEING
HARASSED AND INTIMIDATED AND
THREATENED. UM, I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT, UM WHEN? WHEN I MEET
WITH STUDENTS WHO SAY I? I DON'T
FEEL SAFE, UH, WEARING A KEY PO
OR A STAR OF DAVID ON CAMPUS
THAT THAT ABSOLUTELY BREAKS MY
HEART. UM IT WOULD ALSO BREAKS
MY HEART. IF A IF A MUSLIM
STUDENT TOLD ME I DON'T FEEL
SAFE WEARING A HIJAB ON CAMPUS
OR WHEN A TRANS STUDENT TELLS ME
I DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE. I
DON'T FEEL SAFE EXPRESSING MY
GENDER IDENTITY ON CAMPUS. IT IT
IS ABSOLUTELY HEARTBREAKING, BUT
I HAVE INCREASINGLY BEEN HEARING
FROM JEWISH STUDENTS. THAT THEY
DO NOT FEEL SAFE, UH, ON ON
CAMPUS. UM AND, UH, THAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE. AND I KNOW THAT
YOU AGREE THAT THAT IS
UNACCEPTABLE. WE CANNOT ALLOW,
UM, TOXIC ENVIRONMENTS ON CAMPUS
TO STEW. UH AND I AND I'M I'M
GRATEFUL THAT THAT THAT THAT THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT AND
CHANCELLOR HAVE BEEN PROACTIVE
ON THIS, UM THIS DID NOT START
ON OCTOBER 7TH IT EXISTED BEFORE
BY OCTOBER, 7TH. AND THE
RESULTING WAR IN GAZA HAVE
POURED LIGHTER FLUID. UH, ON
THIS, UM, THE ANTI-SEMITISM THAT
WE'RE SEEING ON OUR CAMPUSES AND
NOT ONLY ON CAMPUS. BUT ON OUR
CAMPUSES, UM IT'S SOMETHING I
NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD SEE IN OUR
LIFETIME. AND I AND MANY JEWS
WOULD TELL YOU THE SAME. UM
PEOPLE CANNOT BELIEVE IT'S
HAPPENING AGAIN. I WANT TO BE RE
VERY, VERY CLEAR. I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT PROTESTS AGAINST
THE WAR. I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
THE BEHAVIOR OF THE ISRAELI
GOVERNMENT OR THE NETANYAHU
ADMINISTRATION. I RESPECT
PEOPLE'S FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS
TO PROTEST AGAINST THE WAR. UM
IT IS, I THINK WARRANTED TO
PROTEST AGAINST THE LEVEL OF
DEATH AND DESTRUCTION THAT IS
HAPPENING IN GAZA, JUST AS IT IS
WARRANTED TO PROTEST AGAINST THE
DEATH AND DESTRUCTION. THAT
HAPPENED ON OCTOBER 7TH, UH AND
AGAINST THE HOSTAGES THAT REMAIN
IN GAZA TODAY. THIS IS A
HUMANITARIAN CATASTROPHE ON SO
MANY LEVELS FOR BOTH. ISRAELIS
AND PALESTINIANS. UM I'VE BEEN
VERY VOCAL ABOUT THAT. AND I
REPEAT THAT TODAY. THAT'S NOT
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT. UH, WHEN I
CALL OUT ANTI SEMITISM ON OUR
ANTI-SEMITISM ON OUR CAMPUSES
I'M TALKING ABOUT WHEN PROTESTS
CROSS A LINE WHEN PEOPLE ARE
TARGETED BECAUSE THEY ARE JEWISH
OR ASSOCIATED WITH A JEWISH
ORGANIZATION. UM AND WHEN
HARASSMENT, INTIMIDATION AND
EVEN VIOLENCE OCCURS, AND I WANT
TO BE CLEAR WE HAVE SEEN
VIOLENCE. WE KNOW THAT RECENTLY
AT U èC BERKELEY, UH TO JEWISH
STUDENTS WERE FORCED TO SEEK
MEDICAL ATTENTION AFTER AN EVENT
THAT FEATURED AN ISRAELI SPEAKER
WAS ABSOLUTELY VIOLENTLY
TARGETED BY PROTESTERS. ONE OF
THE JEWISH STUDENTS WAS CHOKED
BY A PROTESTER. UH, THE OTHER
ONE. I BELIEVE HAS THEIR HAND OR
WRIST INJURED. UH, THE
PROTESTERS BROKE INTO THE
THEATER. BREAKING THE GLASS
STUDENTS WERE JEWISH STUDENTS
WERE SPAT AT, UM WE CALLED AND
DIRTY JEWS. UH AND CAMPUS
SECURITY WAS OVERWHELMED AND
ULTIMATELY, UH, THESE JEWISH
STUDENTS AT UC BERKELEY HAD TO
BE EVACUATED VIA A TUNNEL. I
JUST WANNA DO THEM FOR A MOMENT.
UM JEWISH STUDENTS HAD TO BE
EVACUATED. VIA A TUNNEL AT U èC
BERKELEY IN 2024. AT UC DAVIS.
UM SHORTLY AFTER OCTOBER, 7TH,
UM, A AN ASSISTANT PROFESSOR,
UH, TWEETED ABOUT, UM, BASICALLY
KILLING. UH, MURDERING, UH,
ZIONIST JOURNALISTS. QUOTE
UNQUOTE, UH AND, UM, TALKED
ABOUT KNOWING THEIR ADDRESSES
AND WHERE THEIR KIDS GO TO
SCHOOL. UM AT UCSF. UM A DOCTOR
BY THE NAME OF RUPA MARIA, UM,
HAS BEEN POSTING VILE, ANTI
JEWISH CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
ABOUT QUOTE UNQUOTE ZIONIST
DOCTORS READ JEWISH DOCTORS, UM,
SHOULDN'T BE TREATING PATIENTS
OF COLOR. SHE ALSO, UH UM UH, BE
EFFECTIVELY? UM, UH, JUSTIFIED
OCTOBER. 7TH UM UH, IN ANOTHER
TWEET. UH, TALKED ABOUT, UH,
CEDRIC, FOLLOWING QUOTE MAY THE
MAY JEWISH PEOPLE DO THEIR
HEALING SO THEY CAN STOP.
PRESSING SO JEWS AS OPPRESSORS.
UH AND THEN, UH, A NUMBER OF
OTHER TWEETS LIKE THAT, AND THIS
IS A FACULTY MEMBER AT UCSF. WHO
ALSO TREATS PATIENTS ON BEHALF
OF UCSF, SAYING THOSE THINGS
ABOUT JEWS WHO COULD BE HER
RESIDENCE WHO COULD BE HER
PATIENTS. AND THAT'S WHAT WE
ARE. SEEING AT èC S¼ U SAN
BERNARDINO. UH, UH, PROFESSOR
POSTED AN IMAGE OF NETANYAHU
COVERED IN BLOOD. EATING
CHILDREN. UH, WITH THE WORD
KOSHER EMBLAZONED ABOVE THE
IMAGE OF HIM EATING CHILDREN.
AGAIN I'M NÓ FAN OF NETANYAHU,
BUT TO LINK THIS TO JUDAISM IN
THAT WAY, UM, WAS HORRIFYING. UM
UH, THE ETHNIC STUDIES FACULTY
COUNCIL PUT OUT A STATEMENT. UM
BARELY A WEEK AFTER OCTOBER. 7TH
UH, THAT, UM, ESSENTIALLY
JUSTIFIED. OCTOBER 7TH AS A
LEGITIMATE FORM OF FREEDOM
STRUGGLE. THE MASS MURDER OF
MASS RAPE OF JEWS AND TAKING OF
HOSTAGES. UM AT CAL POLY SAN
LUIS OBISPO ON OCTOBER 8TH. UH,
WITH HAMA WELL, HAMAS TERRORISTS
WERE STILL IN ISRAEL. UM IN
THESE IN ISRAELI COMMUNITIES,
UH, WE SAW TWO JEW JEWISH
STUDENTS HAD DEATH TO ISRAEL
SCREAMED AT THEM. UH, WE'VE ALSO
SEEN, UH, BECAUSE ANTI-SEMITISM
CONSTANTLY MORPHS, UH, THE USE
OF THE WORD ZIONIST AND ZIONISM,
UH, AS A SUBSTITUTE FOR JEW, UH,
ZIONIST MEANS SOMEONE WHO
BELIEVES IN ISRAEL'S EXISTENCE
AS A JEWISH HOMELAND. THAT'S
WHAT IT MEANS. IT DESCRIBES 90%
OF JEWS. AND SO WHEN PEOPLE USE
THE WORD ZIONIST, YOU HAVE TO
ASK. WHAT DOES THAT MEAN? UM WE
KNOW THAT BEFORE OCTOBER 7TH,
UH, THERE WERE A GROUP OF
ORGANIZATIONS OF AT BERKELEY LAW
THAT BANNED QUOTE UNQUOTE
ZIONIST SPEAKERS, UH, FROM
SPEAKING TO THEIR GROUPS. UH, WE
KNOW THAT, UH UM, WE'VE SEEN, UH
, MORE RECENTLY, UM AT U èC
SANTA BARBARA, UH, A STUDENT
DORM THAT HAD A MESSA EFFECT TO
IT. UM WHICH, OF COURSE, IS A
JEWISH CULTURAL AND RELIGIOUS
OBJECT. I HAVE A TO BOTH MY HOME
AND TO MY OFFICE DOOR. UM AND
THE MESSAGE ZIONISTS NOT WELCOME
WITH AN ARROW POINTING TO THE
MEZO. SOMETIMES PEOPLE TELL ON
THEMSELVES. UH, THIS CAME
SHORTLY AFTER THE SANTA BARBARA
CULTURAL CENTER WAS PLASTERED
WITH POSTERS SAYING THAT A QUOTE
UNQUOTE ZIONISTS WERE NOT
WELCOME. UH AND EVEN
SPECIFICALLY TARGETING A JEWISH
STUDENT, UM, NAMING HER AND
SAYING YOU CAN RUN, BUT YOU
CAN'T HIDE. I DO. BERKELEY A
PROMINENT ENVIRONMENTALIST, A
MEMBER OF THE OAKLAND CITY
COUNCIL, UH, WHO ACTUALLY
SUPPORTED A CEASE FIRE
RESOLUTION WAS DISINVITED FROM
SPEAKING TO A CLASS BECAUSE HE
WAS A QUOTE UNQUOTE ZIONIST
BECAUSE HE BELIEVES THAT ISRAEL
SHOULD EXIST. UM UH, THIS
DYNAMIC IS NOT UNIQUE TO, UH,
GUESTS OF UNIVERSITIES. UH,
JEWISH PROFESSORS HAVE ALSO
BECOME FREQUENT TARGETS. AT U
èC LA. A LETTER WAS SUBMITTED
DECRYING FACULTY AND STAFF WHO
PENNED A LETTER IN OPPOSITION TO
THE OCTOBER 7TH ATTACK. THEY
WERE, UM, ATTACKED FOR
CRITICIZING OCTOBER 7TH AT SAN
JOSE STATE. UM A GUEST PROFESSOR
FROM èC S¼ U LONG BEACH WAS
HEAVILY PROTESTED, PROTESTED FOR
GIVING. TALK ABOUT THE IDEA OF A
TWO STATE SOLUTION. SO HE
ADVOCATING FOR AN INDEPENDENT
PALESTINE, BUT HE WAS LABELED
ZIONIST. UM AND THEREFORE, UH,
WAS HEAVILY PROTESTED. UM THIS
LONG BEACH PROFESSOR IS NOW JUST
AS OF A FEW DAYS AGO BEING
HARASSED WITH FLYERS, LABELING
HIM AS A GENOCIDE DENIER,
COLONIZER, ZIONIST AND WHITE
SUPREMACIST. UH, AGAIN DEMON
DEMONIZATION OF JEWS ON CAMPUS.
UH SO, UH, WE ALSO, UM WENDY'S
INCIDENTS HAPPEN. THE CAMPUSES
ISSUE STATEMENTS. UH WE KNOW
THAT SOME OF THESE STATEMENTS
HAVE FALLEN SHORT. THOSE RECENT
U èC BERKELEY AND U èC SANTA
BARBARA INCIDENTS THAT I
DESCRIBED THE CAMPUS STATEMENTS
THAT CAME OUT IMMEDIATELY
AFTERWARDS. DID NOT USE THE WORD
JEW. UH, IT WAS BASICALLY AN ALL
LIVES MATTER STATEMENT WITHOUT
REFERENCING THAT IT WAS ACTUALLY
JEWS WHO WERE BEING TARGETED.
BOTH CAMPUSES DID REVIVE THEIR
STATEMENTS, AND I'M VERY
APPRECIATIVE. UM OF THAT, UM WE
ALSO, UM I ALSO JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE THE
RECENT, UM, INCIDENT, UH AT U
èC S¼ U LONG BEACH. UH, THE,
UM, UH, PRESIDENT PUT OUT
EXCELLENT STATEMENT IMMEDIATELY,
UH, CONDEMNING IT FOR WHAT? IT
WAS ANTI SEM. AND I'M VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT. UM I'M GONNA
STOP THERE BECAUSE THERE YOU
KNOW, III. I DO NOT WANNA, UH, I
CAN I COULD GO ON FOR HOURS
ABOUT LISTING INCIDENTS. I'M NOT
OBVIOUSLY NOT GOING TO DO THAT.
THAT WAS JUST THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG. UH, THAT I LISTED. UM
AND SO, UM AGAIN, I WANNA THANK
YOU FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING BECAUSE I KNOW THAT YOU
BOTH OF YOU ARE ENGAGED AND I'M
SUPER APPRECIATIVE OF THAT. UM I
JUST WANNA ASK, UM, IF YOU COULD
TALK ABOUT WHAT YOU SEE IN èC
S¼ U ARE DOING TO ENSURE A SAFE
CAMPUS. UM, CLIMATE, UM MAKE
SURE THAT SOME OF THESE
INCIDENTS DON'T HAPPEN AGAIN,
UH, AND TO PROTECT FREE SPEECH.
FREE SPEECH FOR PROTESTERS. UM
BUT MAKING SURE THAT FREE SPEECH
IS NOT CROSS A LINE AND END UP
PREVENTING OTHERS FROM HAVING
SPEECH. UH ON CAMPUS. SO IF YOU
COULD JUST TALK ABOUT STEPS THAT
ARE BEING, UH, TAKEN THANK YOU,
SENATOR WEINER. LET ME BEGIN BY
SAYING FIRST AND FOREMOST. HATE
BIGOTRY, ANTI SEMITISM AND ALL
OF THESE HORRIFIC THINGS HAVE NÓ
PLACE. THE èC S¼ U. I THINK YOU
KNOW THAT ABOUT ME. FROM THE
VERY START AND I STARTED IN
OCTOBER. 1ST THIS HAPPENED ON
OCTOBER 7TH. AND FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING, I HAVE INSTRUCTED THE
PRESIDENTS TO PRIORITIZE THAT
OUR CAGES ARE WELCOMING FOR
STUDENTS OF JEWISH FAITH AND ALL
STUDENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE WELCOMING ENVIRONMENTS.
WE'VE PROVIDED RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT TO HELP THESE PRESIDENTS
AND THEIR TEAMS. WE ALSO HAVE
REGULAR MEETINGS, NOT NOT ONLY
WITH THE PRESIDENT WITH THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF, UH, DIRECTORS OR
DIRECTORS OF A DIVERSITY,
INCLUSION STUDENT AFFAIRS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE MONITORING
AND ENSURING AND GETTING OUT THE
WORD THAT WE ARE THERE FOR ALL
STUDENTS, ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
ARE BEING TARGETED AT THIS POINT
, THE JEWISH STUDENTS, SO WE'RE
DOING THAT AS WELL. WE ALSO HAD
OUR, UH, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I'M REALLY PROUD OF IS THAT WE
HAD FOUR PRESIDENTS GIVE
EXAMPLES ON HOW THEY ARE
MANAGING THIS IN FRONT OF ALL 23
UNIVERSITY PRESIDENTS, LEARNING
FROM ME ABOUT EACH OTHER ABOUT
INTERFAITH COUNCILS, WORKING
WITH HILLEL TEACHINGS, ET
CETERA, BRINGING IN OUTSIDE
EXPERT TO SPEAK TO STUDENTS AS
AN EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT TO
HAVE EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT, WHICH IS, HOW DO WE LIVE
AND WORK TO GET A LEARNING FROM
EACH OTHER AND UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS HATRED HAS NÓ PLACE?
THIS BIGOTRY HAS NÓ PLACE AND SO
AND LAST MONTH WE SENT, UH WE
ARE IN PERSON IN DEPTH MEETING
WITH ALL OUR PRESIDENTS
THOROUGHLY REVIEWING FEDERAL NON
DISCRIMINATION PRACTICES, MAKING
SURE THAT PRESIDENTS HAVE THIS
TOOL KIT THAT IS BEING DELIVERED
TO ALL VICE PRESIDENTS AND ALL
DIRECTORS. THAT HAVE A POINT TO
TALK TO THE STUDENTS. SO THIS
COOL TOOL KIT WILL HELP. OF
COURSE WE HAVE OUR CAMPUS POLICE
MONITORING. WE'RE MUCH MORE
PRESENT. WE ARE ENSURING THAT
OUR PEOPLE ARE OUT THERE OUTSIDE
WATCHING WHAT'S GOING ON ON OUR
CAMPUSES, AND WE'RE HAVING
COUNSELING AND MENTAL HEALTH FOR
ANYBODY THAT NEEDS IT. AND OUR
DOORS ARE ALWAYS OPEN FOR
STUDENTS WHO FEEL UNSAFE. I'M
JUST HOPING THAT THEY WILL TELL
US SO WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS IT. I HOPE THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION. NÓ II. I
PRESIDENT. DR. YES WELL, THANK
YOU. I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS,
SENATOR. WE KNOW WE'VE HAD A
CHANCE TO SPEAK ABOUT THESE
ISSUES. AND UH UM I ECHO YOUR
COMMENTS FROM BEGINNING TO END.
AND ALSO THOSE OF MY, UH,
COLLEAGUE, J GARCIA, THE OUR
CAMPUSES NEED TO BE SAFE PLACES
FOR PEOPLE TO LIVE AND TO WORK.
YOU MENTIONED STUDENTS WHO FEEL
HARASSED AND THREATENED,
PARTICULARLY JEWISH STUDENTS IN
AT THESE LAST FIVE MONTHS. THIS
ALSO IS JEWISH STAFF AND JEWISH
FACULTY AS WELL WHO, UH,
SOMETIMES FEEL UNSAFE ON CAMPUS,
PARTICULARLY IN IN AND THE
PRESENCE OF, UH, DEMONSTRATIONS,
WHICH CAN BE OUTRAGEOUS AND HAVE
CROSSED THE LINE TO ANTI
SEMITISM ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS
ON MULTIPLE CAMPUSES IN OUR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
OTHER PLACES THAT WE'VE SEEN
AROUND AROUND THE COUNTRY, WE DO
SEVERAL THINGS FIRST, UM AGAIN,
AS IS THE DENTIST LAST YEAR, WE
BRING OUR CHANCELLORS TOGETHER
ON A REGULAR BASIS OUR OUR
REGULAR MEETINGS AND WE'VE HAD
ACTUALLY SPECIAL MEETINGS ON
THESE PARTICULAR TOPICS. UH,
OVER THE LAST, UH, SEVERAL
MONTHS. I HAVE ISSUED STATEMENTS
THAT YOU IN FACT, REFERENCED,
UH, YOU YOU MENTIONED, UH UH,
REBOUND STATEMENTS FROM, UM
FACULTY, CRITICIZING THE
POSITION THAT THE UNIVERSITY
HAVE TAKEN THOSE THOSE ARE MY
POSITIONS THAT THEY WERE
CRITICIZING, AND WE'VE STATED
THAT ANTI SEMITISM HAS NÓ PLACE
ON OUR CAMPUSES AND WILL BE
WE'LL DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PREVENT IT AND TO ROOT IT OUT
AND TO CALL IT OUT WHEN WE SEE
IT TO CALL IT OUT, AS SUCH,
ACTUALLY, REGIONS ADOPTED A
POLICY OF, UH, SEVERAL YEARS
AGO, THE REGION POLICY 44 03,
WHICH SAYS THAT ANTI SEMITISM
AND OTHER FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION AND NÓ PLACE IN
THE UNIVERSITY AND THE REGIONS
CALLED ON UNIVERSITY LEADERS, UH
TO CHALLENGE ANTI-SEMITISM AND
OTHER FORMS OF DISCRIMINATION
WHENEVER AND WHEREVER THEY
OCCUR, AND THAT WAS DONE
SPECIFICALLY TO CALL OUT ANTI
SEMITISM PER S¼ E AS UM, UH, AN
AREA OF FOCUS AND WE TAKE THAT
QUITE SERIOUSLY, AND WE DO OUR
BEST TO ACT ON IT IN THESE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS. WE'VE UH FROM MY
OFFICE. WE'VE DEVELOPED A $7
MILLION FUND. UH, THE CAMPUSES
APPLY FOR PRO FOR THIS MONEY TO
USE FOR SUPPORT FOR
COMMUNICATIONS FOR SUPPORT OF
STUDENTS FOR OTHER THINGS THAT
WILL ADDRESS ANTI SEMITISM IN
OTHER FORMS OF DISCRIMINATION,
BUT SPECIFICALLY, ANTI-SEMITISM
CALLED OUT ON OUR CAMPUS AS WE,
UH, DIVIDED THIS INTO TWO
TRANCHES. THE FIRST TRANCHE, UM,
WENT OUT A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO.
UH, WE HAD 55 PROPOSALS FROM THE
CAMPUSES ON THINGS THAT THEY
THEY WANT TO DO, AND THESE ARE
HAPPENING ON ALL THE CAMPUSES.
WHERE PLEASED ABOUT THAT. THE
SECOND UH UH. SEA BREEZE OF
REQUESTS HAVE ARRIVED AT THE
OFFICE THAT ARE BEING REVIEWED
NOW, AND THESE ARE MEANT TO
SUPPORT DIALOGUE AND I SUPPORT
BUILDING A SENSE OF COMMUNITY
WHEN WE HAVE SO MUCH, UM, THE
COMMUNITY IS SO FRACTURED. I
WILL SAY ABOUT UC BERKELEY THAT
YOU MENTIONED THE, UM ENTIRELY
UNACCEPTABLE EVENT OF THREE
WEEKS AGO. AND UH, YOU WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THE SPECIFIC NATURE
OF THAT EVENT. CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS ARE UNDERWAY AND
THAT THAT'S APPROPRIATE. I AS
WITH YOU WOULD PLEASE. THAT THE,
UH, STATEMENTS. UH, THAT CAME
OUT LATER IN THE WEEK WERE MORE
FOCUSED ON EXACTLY WHAT THE, UH,
INCIDENT WAS. I'LL SAY THAT
WE'VE HAD, UM UH, BOTH A PROTEST
AND, UH ANOTHER, UH, UH, SPEAKER
FROM THE POSITION ON THAT THE
OTHER SPEAKER, UH UH, SPEAKING
IN FAVOR OF THE, UH, S¼ OF THE
ISRAELI GOVERNMENT IN IN DOING
EVERYTHING THAT THEY IT COULD TO
PROTECT ISRAEL BUT
CONTROVERSIALLY THE SAME AS THE
SPEAKER, UM, WHO WAS RESCHEDULED
THAT SECOND SPEECH, UM, WAS ABLE
TO TAKE PLACE THERE WAS BETTER
PLANNING, I THINK IN ADVANCE OF
THAT. AND SO THE UNIVERSITY'S
COMMITMENT TO FREE SPEECH AND
PROTECTING SPEAKERS AND
PROTECTING AUDIENCES THAT WISH
TO SPEAK, UM IS MANIFEST AND
THAT'S THE NORMAL POLICY. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THESE
THINGS. YOU KNOW, WE HAVE, UM,
AN INTERESTING CIRCUMSTANCE IN
OUR CAMPUSES. WE CELEBRATE SO
MUCH DIVERSITY AND INCLUSIVENESS
, BRINGING PEOPLE FROM ALL PARTS
OF THE MAP TO, UH, COME AND WORK
TOGETHER AND TO LEARN TOGETHER
BUT ALSO ON OUR CAMPUSES TO LIVE
TOGETHER. WE HAVE 100,000
STUDENTS THAT LIVE ON OUR
CAMPUSES. WE THEN BY HAVING THAT
DIVERSITY THAT THAT LEADS TO THE
RICH TAPESTRY OF IDEAS AND
POINTS OF VIEW, BUT EVERYONE
AGREES AND WE HAVE FRICTION
BETWEEN GROUPS FROM TIME TO TIME
OR BETWEEN INDIVIDUALS FROM TIME
TO TIME, AND WE HAVE AS A DAILY
COMMITMENT TO DO ALL WE CAN TO
PROTECT AND SUPPORT THE SAFETY
OF OUR INDIVIDUALS AND ALSO THE
FEELING OF BEING AT HOME AND
BEING WELCOMED IN YOUR HOME FOR
EVERY STUDENT FOR EVERY FACULTY
FOR EVERY STAFF MEMBER, AND
WE'LL CONTINUE TO BE COMMITTED
TO THAT. THANK YOU. JUST ONE
MORE BRIEF QUESTION. THEN I'LL
BE DONE AND MR CHAIR. I'M VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE TIME. UM SO
WE HAVE SEEN. UM UH BOTH
DEPARTMENTS. UM INDIVIDUAL
PROFESSORS AND ALSO WITHIN
CLASSROOMS AND TEACHING. UH UH.
NOT JUST BIASED BUT HISTORICALLY
INACCURATE. UM STATEMENTS.
OFFICIAL WEBSITES. UM AND ALSO,
UH IN CURRICULA IN CLASSROOMS.
UH, AND THIS IS ALSO TRUE.
FRANKLY, I  N SOME Kò THROUGH 12
SETTINGS. TEACHING SO IT'S A
HISTORICAL INFORMATION ABOUT
ISRAEL ABOUT, UM, THE JEWISH
PEOPLE'S CONNECTION. UH TO
ISRAEL. UH AND REALLY, UM,
CURRICULA DESIGNED FRANKLY, TO
DEMONIZE JEWS AND TO DEMONIZE
ANY RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN JEWS
AND ISRAEL. WE KNOW THAT ISRAEL
IS HOME TO 7 MILLION JEWS, HALF
OF ONE HALF OF ALL JEWS ON THE
PLANET LIVE IN ISRAEL. JEWS HAVE
HAD A CONNECTION TO ISRAEL FOR
THOUSANDS OF YEARS. PALESTINIANS
ALSO HAVE DEEP CONNECTION TO THE
LAND. UH AND I CONDEMN PEOPLE
WHO TRY TO ERASE THAT
CONNECTION. AND I I'M JUST
CURIOUS HOW AND IT'S THIS IS I
KNOW IT'S COMPLICATED BECAUSE OF
A ACADEMIC FREEDOM. BUT ACADEMIC
FREEDOM HAS ITS LIMITS. WHEN UM
UH, FALSEHOODS ARE BEING, UH,
TAUGHT, UH AND SO I'M JUST
CURIOUS IF YOU HAVE ANY COMMENT
ON THAT, UH, GENERAL ISSUE YEAH,
I'LL SAY THAT, UH. AS WE LOOK AT
WHAT INDIVIDUAL FACULTY MEMBERS
TEACH ON INDIVIDUAL, UH UH,
CIRCUMSTANCES WE FIND THAT THERE
ARE TIMES WHEN FACULTY MEMBERS
HAVE POSITIONS THAT ARE
OUTRAGEOUS OR UNSUPPORTABLE.
BROADLY THAT IT'S A RARE EVENT.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF LECTURES THAT
HAPPEN MORE THAN THAT. HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS IN A YEAR WHEN, UM
AND BROADLY THE FACULTY ITSELF.
SEES THE PRIVILEGES OF ACADEMIC
FREEDOM BEING BALANCED WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF ACADEMIC
FREEDOM AND ACADEMIC ACCURACY
AND THE FACULTIES THEMSELVES.
THEN ARE THE OVER THE YEARS.
THAT'S THE ECOSYSTEM IN WHICH
THESE THINGS ARE BALANCED OUT.
WE CAN'T WE DON'T PRE SCREEN WE
CAN'T. UH, CORRECT. WE CAN'T
GUIDE EVERYONE'S POSITION WHEN
THINGS COME WHEN WE HEAR OF
THINGS THAT ARE INAPPROPRIATE OR
INACCURATE. WE DO OUR BEST AS A
SYSTEM TO, UH UH UH, BALANCE
THOSE THINGS WITH, UH, ACTUAL
TRUTH AND YOU KNOW, THERE'S A
LINE THAT CLARK KERR SAID. UM UH
YEARS AGO THAT I THINK OF A LOT,
HE SAID THAT OUR JOB IS NOT TO
MAKE SPEECH SAFE FOR STUDENTS.
OUR JOB IS TO MAKE STUDENTS SAFE
FOR SPEECH AND WE TRY TO EDUCATE
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO HEAR THINGS
EVEN WHEN THOSE THINGS ARE ARE
ARE COUNTERFACTUAL AND TO BE
ABLE TO PROCESS THOSE AND
RESPOND APPROPRIATELY TO THEM.
AND UH AND WE JUST TRY TO WHEN
WE HEAR THINGS THAT ARE
INACCURATE OR OR NOT TRUTH WE
TRY TO UH, COUNTERACT THAT WITH
MORE TRUTH AND JUST CONTINUE TO
PUSH FORWARD IN THAT WAY. THANK
YOU. YEAH I'D LIKE TO ADD TO
THAT. I THINK NOT. IN ADDITION
TO THAT OUR DIVERSITY, EQUITY
INCLUSION AND OUR STUDENTS
AFFAIRS AND THE PROVOST OFFICE
DOES A LOT OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT ON DIVERSITY, EQUITY
AND INCLUSION THAT WOULD INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE ANTI SEMITISM, ETC.
THAT WE'RE HOPING THAT FACULTY
WILL ATTEND AND LEARN FROM AND
ONCE A SMALL GROUP STARTS TO GO.
YOU START TO HEAR ACROSS
CAMPUSES AND I USED TO DO THIS
AT FULLERTON THAT THEY ARE THEY
ARE. THIS IS A GOOD THING TO GO
TO. AND MORE AND MORE FACULTY
WILL GO AND ALSO, YOU KNOW, TO
CONTINUE TO SAY THAT WE DO HAVE
A RESPONSIBILITY AS ACADEMICS TO
HAVE DIFFICULT DISCUSSIONS, BUT
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS
ACCURATE, AND SO WE MAKE SURE WE
SAY THAT THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT. SENATOR MINT. YOU
ASKED TO BE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND UH, IT
IS VERY TROUBLING TO SEE THE
RISE IN HATE ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES
AROUND THE STATE AND AROUND THE
COUNTRY, AND IN PARTICULAR THE
RISE OF ANTI SEMITISM,
PARTICULARLY FOLLOWING THE
HORRIFIC ATTACKS OF OCTOBER 7TH.
UH, BUT I UNDERSTAND THIS IS A
TOUGH DEBATE AS WELL. UM
PRESIDENT DRAKE AND I WERE BACK
AT U èC. IRVINE TOGETHER WHEN
IRWIN CHEMERINSKY WAS THE DEAN
OF THE LAW SCHOOL THERE. AND UH,
I KNOW THAT IRWIN HAS TALKED
QUITE A LOT AND WRITTEN QUITE A
LOT ABOUT, UH, COLLEGE SPEECH,
FREEDOM OF SPEECH. AND, YOU
KNOW, CERTAINLY, AS SOMEONE WHO
IS PART OF THESE COMMUNITIES, I,
I BELIEVE STRONGLY IN ACADEMIC
FREEDOM AND FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
UH AT THE SAME TIME, I THINK
IT'S VERY CLEAR AND II. I THINK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
ARTICULATED THIS VERY POIGNANTLY
THAT ANTI SEMITISM SHOULD HAVE
NÓ PLACE ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
RACISM CALLS FOR GENOCIDE HAVE
NÓ PLACE IN OUR UNIVERSITY
COMMUNITY AT THE SAME TIME, I
ALSO WANNA BE CLEAR ISLAMOPHOBIA
AND HATE OF ALL KINDS,
PARTICULARLY WHEN THESE TAKE THE
FORM OF ACTIVITIES LIKE
HARASSMENT THAT THAT JEOPARDIZE
THE FEELING OF SAFETY AND
SECURITY HAVE NÓ PLACE AND, UH,
I. I KNOW THAT SOMETIMES FINDING
THAT BALANCE IS DIFFICULT
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A CORE
MISSION OF ANY HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTION. THIS BELIEF THAT
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION. AND SO TRYING TO
ARTICULATE GUIDELINES AND RULES
AND MARKERS FOR, UH WHEN THIS
BLURS THE LINE WHEN IT CROSSES
OVER THE LINE INTO SOMETHING
THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE, I KNOW CAN
BE CHALLENGING. UH AND SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION TO YOU BOTH.
AND THAT WAS A LONG STATEMENT.
BUT, UM YOU KNOW, I RIGHT NOW
I'M PREPARED TO SUPPORT S¼ B
1287 THE LEGISLATION THAT'S
BEING PROPOSED BY MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS
, UH, TO KIND OF FORCE THE HAND
HERE AND DICTATE THAT THE èC S¼
U S¼  N U SHELL, UH, CREATE
CERTAIN GUIDELINES, AND I THINK
BY THE WAY, THEY THEY'VE STRUCK
THE RIGHT BALANCE. I'VE I'VE HAD
THE CHANCE TO READ A DRAFT OF
WHAT THEY'VE PROPOSED ON SOME OF
THESE COMPETING PRINCIPLES, BUT
I, I GUESS MY QUESTION TO YOU
IS, IS WOULD THAT WOULD
LEGISLATION BE HELPFUL? UH, DO
YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'RE ABLE TO DO
THIS ON YOUR OWN WITHOUT
LEGISLATION? UH BECAUSE I THINK
MY COLLEAGUES ARE CONCERNED WHEN
THEY SEE YOU KNOW, AND I'M
CONCERNED WHEN WE SEE THE RISE
IN HATE ON THESE CAMPUSES, SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION TO YOU IS, UH,
IS THIS HELPFUL AND HOW SO? I'M
SORRY. LET ME BEGIN BY SAYING
THAT WE'VE ALREADY STARTED DOING
A TOOL KIT ON THIS FOR WHAT'S
ACCEPTABLE AND WHAT'S NOT. WE
HAD THIS PRESENTATION WITH ALL
THE PRESIDENTS MAYBE A MONTH AGO
RECENTLY, WE'RE WE'RE HAVING OUR
PEOPLE OF DIVERSITY, EQUITY
INCLUSION AS WELL AS OUR
ATTORNEYS GIVE THIS COOL TOOL
KIT TO OUR CAMPUSES TO ENSURE
THAT THIS DOES NOT HAPPEN AGAIN.
WE STAND STRONG ON ANTI, UH,
ISLA ISLAMOPHOBIA. AND UH, YOU
KNOW, EVERY EVERY SEXISM, RACISM
EVERYTHING THAT WE ARE. ANY
STRONG, ESPECIALLY NOW,
ESPECIALLY NOW. OUR CAMPUSES
NEED TO BE AS UH, SENATOR WEINER
SAID. THE EDUCATIONAL LABORATORY
WHERE STUDENTS LIVE WORK AND
DEBATE TOGETHER TOUGH DECISIONS,
AND IT'S UP TO US TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN MANAGE THAT. AND
THAT'S WHY WE THINK THE TOOL KIT
IS WONDERFUL, AND WE'RE HOPING
THAT EVERYBODY PUTS IT INTO
PLACE AND THAT WE WILL CONTINUE.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE
DIFFICULT DIALOGUES WHERE WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE MANAGE IT
AND THAT WE PROTECT ALL OUR
STUDENTS, INCLUDING OUR JEWISH
STUDENTS AND OUR ISLAMIC
STUDENTS AS WELL AND ALL OUR
STUDENTS, QUITE FRANKLY. WELL,
WHAT P. OH, I'M SORRY, BUT BUT
NÓ THAT THAT'S TAKE MORE TIME. I
WOULD JUST ECHO WHAT CHANCE,
GARCIA SAID. WE WORK ON THESE
THINGS ON A DAILY BASIS WE HAVE.
ACTUALLY THREE OF OUR CAMPUSES
ARE WORKING WITH HILLEL
INTERNATIONAL ON A PROGRAM THAT
HAD A NATIONAL HAS TO, UH, TRAIN
LEADERS. UH, FOURTH CAMPUS HAS
SIGNED UP TO BEGIN NEXT MONTH.
AND AT THE OTHER, UM, UH, FIVE
CAMPUSES. ANOTHER FIVE
UNDERGRADUATE, UH, CAMPUSES
ACTUALLY ARE ARE SPEAKING ABOUT
HAVING A SPECIAL PROGRAM
DEVELOPED JUST FOR THEM TO HELP.
CONTINUALLY RE, UH, TRAIN AND
REFOCUS AND RESENSITIZED. OUR
JUST WHAT IS HAPPENING? I'M
ACTUALLY MEETING TOMORROW ON
THIS, UM, WITH HILLEL AND
MEETING ON MONDAY AGAIN WITH, UM
, THE FORMER MEMBER OF THIS, UH
UH, BODY, UH, TO TALK ABOUT WAYS
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO PUSH
THESE THINGS TO THE FRONT OF OUR
MINDS. YOU SPOKE A CERTAIN MEN
ABOUT ACTIVITIES THAT WERE
TAKING PLACE AT U èC. I 15
YEARS AGO, AND WE WERE ACTIVELY
INVOLVED 15 YEARS AGO WITH THOSE
ISSUES. WE IT LED TO THE
FORMATION OF THE NATIONAL FREE
SPEECH CENTER, WHICH I BELIEVE
I'M THE SOMETHING OF THE
PRESIDENT. OR SOMETHING, BUT BUT
, UH UH DEAN CHEMERINSKY AND
CHANCELLOR GILMAN ARE THE CO
CHAIRS OF AND SO IT'S AN ONGOING
ACTIVE THING FOR US ON A DAILY
BASIS, AND IT'S UH, AT THE CORE
OF OUR MISSION. AND WE ARE. I
THINK OUR OUR PAL IS REALLY THE
PEDAL IS STILL THE METAL ON
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO HAVE
TO FOCUS ON THESE AREAS AND THIS
AND AS SEVERAL OF YOU HAVE SAID,
WE ARE SPEAKING TODAY, PRIMARILY
ABOUT ANTI-SEMITISM AND THE RISE
OF ANTI SEMITISM OVER THESE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS FOCUSED ON THE
RISE THAT'S HAPPENED AFTER
OCTOBER. 7TH WE HAVE, UM, UH,
DISCRIMINATION AND
MARGINALIZATION OF STUDENTS FROM
A VARIETY OF BACKGROUNDS ALL THE
TIME AND WE SO WE TRY TO KEEP
OURSELVES ELEVATED EVERY DAY ON
ON THESE TOPICS. YES CHANCELLOR.
ONE LAST THING I'D LIKE TO SAY
WHEN I MET WITH, UH SENATOR
WEINER AND, UM, ASSEMBLYMAN
GABRIEL DID WE OFFER THAT WE
WOULD LOVE TO WORK TOGETHER? I
THINK THIS IS SOMETHING THAT YOU
KNOW NOT ONLY WORKING WITH
EXPERTS, BUT ANYTHING YOU CAN
OFFER TO US THAT WE SEE WE CAN
IMPROVE ON WE'RE WILLING AND
ABLE. AND IF I CAN? JUST ONE
QUICK THING, MR CHAIR. I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT I MEAN, NOW.
WE'RE GOING THROUGH A VERY, VERY
DIFFICULT TIME IN IN THIS
COUNTRY IN TERMS OF THE RELA
RELATIONS BETWEEN THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY AND THE MUSLIM AND
ARAB AND PALESTINIAN COMMUNITIES
, IT'S TIME OF WAR. IT'S JUST A
VERY TENSE TIME AND THE AND
HEALING IS GONNA BE CHALLENGING
AND IT BUT IT'S SO CRITICAL, UM
BUT I WENT WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW?
WHEN I'M SEEING WITH WITH WITH
WITH JEWS AND SOME OF THE
ATTACKS WE SEE IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S NOT THE SAME, BUT IT IT
DRAWS ME BACK TO 23 YEARS AGO
AFTER AFTER SEPTEMBER 11TH WHAT?
UM MUSLIMS AND ARABS WENT
THROUGH AND STILL GO THROUGH. IN
THIS COUNTRY IN TERMS OF JUST
SUSPICION. UM, UH, SORT OF
TAGGING PEOPLE WITH YEAH,
BECAUSE OH, YOU'RE I  N THE SA
YOU YOU'RE LINKED SOMEHOW TO
THAT AND DEMONIZING PEOPLE AND
WE SAW RISES IN HARASSMENT,
INTIMIDATION, VIOLENCE AGAINST
MUSLIM AND ARAB PEOPLE IN THIS
IN THIS COUNTRY. UM AND SO IT'S
JUST, UM IT'S JUST SO IMPORTANT
THAT IN IN A KIND OF REALLY HARD
TIME, UM BUT THAT OVER TIME, WE
JUST ALL RECOGNIZE THAT THAT THE
THIS HATRED IT JUST TAKES A LOT
OF DIFFERENT FORMS, UM AND
TARGETS DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
AND WE HAVE TO FIND WAYS TO HAVE
COMMON GROUND. SO AND JUST TO
MAYBE MAKE A CLOSING COMMENT, UM
I WOULD BE LYING IF I DIDN'T SAY
I WAS SLIGHTLY APPREHENSIVE
ABOUT THIS DISCUSSION BEFOREHAND
, AND I THINK IT'S BEEN VERY,
VERY THOUGHTFUL AND I THINK IT'S
BEEN VERY, VERY HELPFUL. UH, I,
I SUBSCRIBE TO YOUR COMMENTS AND
I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT IT AND I
THINK THE RESPONSES WERE GOOD,
AND I THINK MAYBE IT'S A
HINDSIGHT. BUT THE COLLEGE
PRESIDENTS ON THE EAST COAST
COULD HAVE REALLY LEARNED FROM
HOW YOU TALKED ABOUT THIS TODAY
AND HOW YOU HAVE ACTED IN A WAY.
HAS BEEN VERY GOOD, AND I THINK,
UH, SENATOR WEINER AND SENATOR
MIN HAVE TALKED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT AS PRESIDENT IS THIS IS AND
IS UNJUST AS SOME OF THE THINGS
ARE THAT IS GOING IT IS NOT IN
ISOLATION FROM OTHER THINGS THAT
ARE GOING ON AND I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST CALL OUT THAT PRESIDENT
DRAKE HAS BEEN THE OBJECT OF
SOME THINGS. UH, I TO HIS
PROPERTY AND POTENTIALLY HIS
PERSON IN A WAY THAT THAT THAT
NEEDS TO BE CALLED OUT AS WELL,
AND THAT NEEDS TO BE THAT WHERE
THERE'S A LINE THAT SOMEBODY
THAT IS A LEADER SHOULD NOT BE.
TO THOSE ACTS OF RACISM AND
WORRY ABOUT HIS OWN PERSONAL
SECURITY OR THE SECURITY OF THE
PLACE THAT HE LIVES THAT WE
SUPPORT. AND SO, UM WHAT? JUST
A, UH, ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THIS IS
AN ONGOING DISCUSSION. AND AN
ONGOING DISCUSSION THAT BECAUSE
THE EVENTS WILL BE ONGOING IN
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT WILL TRIGGER
DIFFERENT PIECES OF THIS AND WE
WILL HAVE TO ADJUST AN
INTERESTING WAY LATER IN THE
AGENDA ON POINT, WE'LL BE
TALKING ABOUT THE DIVERSITY OF
ENROLLMENT. A AND WE'LL BE
TALKING ABOUT THE, UH, NATIVE
AMERICAN, UH, REPATRIATION OF
GRAVES AND OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
OUR WAYS TO TRY TO DEAL WITH
INJUSTICES AND ISSUES OF
DIVERSITY THAT THAT IN MANY
PLACE AS YOU ARE THE FRONT LINES
FOR SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS
EXCHANGE. I APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S, UH, PARTICIPATION.
AND AS I ANNOUNCED AT THE
BEGINNING, WE USUALLY HAVE A
COMMENTS RESERVED TO THE END.
BUT IF THERE'S ANYBODY HERE
ABOUT THIS ITEM THAT WISHES TO
ADDRESS US, COULD I SEE YOUR
HAND RIGHT NOW? ONE. TWO. AM I
MISSING ANYBODY? THEN I WILL
ALLOW EACH OF YOU ON THIS
SUBJECT TO SPEAK FOR UP TO ONE
MINUTE AT THE PODIUM. SO PLEASE
COME FORWARD AND ADDRESS US.
YOU'RE WELCOME. THANK YOU.
COMMITTEE THANK YOU, UH, SENATOR
WEINER FOR OPENING UP THIS
CONVERSATION. UM AND FOR, UH,
THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC. MY NAME IS
RABBI ADAM NAFT AND KELMAN. I AM
THE ROSSLYN AND ARTHUR GILBERT
FOUNDATION, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF BERKELEY, HILLA, THE JEWISH
STUDENT CENTER THAT HAS BEEN ON
THE UC BERKELEY CAMPUS SINCE
1927 AND HAS BEEN PART OF THE
AND IS PART OF THE HILLEL
INTERNATIONAL MOVEMENT THAT
SERVES OVER 180,000 JEWISH
STUDENTS ACROSS CAMPUSES IN
NORTH AMERICA AND THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD. IN THE LAST 15 YEARS. IS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. I HAVE
SEEN THE EXPANSION OF JEWISH
LIFE FOR STUDENTS TO ENGAGE
THEIR WHOLE JEWISH IDENTITY
THROUGH MANY AVENUES, INCLUDING
HILLEL, MULTIPLE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES, SOCIAL ACADEMIC
CENTERS, JEWISH COMMUNAL LIVING.
AND, IN FACT, A FEW YEARS AGO, A
CO FOUNDER OF THE A, THE ANTI
SEMITISM EDUCATION INITIATIVE AT
UC BERKELEY EVEN WITH ALL OF
THESE OPPORTUNITIES, JEWISH
STUDENTS ARE NOT ABLE TO FULLY
ENGAGE OR EXPRESS THEMSELVES
BECAUSE THEY ARE EXPERIENCING
INCREASED EXCLUSION AND
HARASSMENT. WELL. THE UNIVERSITY
ADMINISTRATION HAS WORKED TO
SUPPORT JEWISH STUDENTS. THEY
MUST DO MORE AFTER THE VIOLENT
PROTEST ON FEBRUARY 26TH AS ROSE
REFERENCED EARLIER. JEWISH
STUDENTS DESERVE AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT WILL HOLD
THOSE INVOLVED FULLY ACCOUNTABLE
AND ENFORCE UNIVERSITY POLICIES.
AND EVEN AT THIS MOMENT, THERE
ARE UN UNIVERSITY POLICIES THAT
ARE BEING VIOLATED AND THEY ARE
NOT BEING ENFORCED. THE TIRELESS
WORK OF BUILDING A VIBRANT
JEWISH COMMUNITY AT UC BERKELEY
AND ACROSS ALL OF THE U èC
SYSTEM AND THE CAL STATE SYSTEM
WHO MY SON HOPEFULLY WILL BE
GOING TO NEXT YEAR. WILL BE FOR
NAUGHT IF JEWISH STUDENTS CANNOT
FULLY EXPRESS THEMSELVES SAFELY
AS JEWS AS A PART OF A JEWISH
COMMUNITY WITHOUT FEAR OF THREAT
ON THEIR IDENTITY. BUT NOT ONLY
SHOULD THEY BE TOLERATED AND
SAFE AND ACCEPTED, BUT THEY
SHOULD BE CELEBRATED FOR WHO
THEY ARE. MEMBERS OF A DIVERSE
COMMUNITY THAT ADD SOMETHING TO
HIGHER ED. OUR JEWISH STUDENTS
DESERVE YOUR STRONG LEADERSHIP,
NOT JUST WORDS, BUT STRONG
ACTIONS TO ENSURE THAT THEY CAN
FULLY EXPRESS THEIR JEWISH
IDENTITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND WE HAVE ONE
OTHER, UH, SPEAKER HERE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR WAIR.
GOOD MORNING, EVERYONE. MY NAME
IS NANCY APPELL AND I'M WITH THE
ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE. UM I'VE
HAD TO REVISE MY PREPARED
REMARKS AS THIS HAS GONE ON
BECAUSE SENATOR WEINER UM SO
POIGNANTLY, AS YOU SAID, UH,
WALKED US THROUGH, FRANKLY,
WHAT'S JUST BEEN A PARADE OF
HORRIBLES ON CAMPUS. UM
ANTI-SEMITISM HAS SPIKED
ALARMINGLY, UH, THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND ON ITS COLLEGE
CAMPUSES, UM, WE'VE TRACKED OVER
100 ANTI-SEMITIC INCIDENTS. IN
CALIFORNIA CAMPUSES SINCE
OCTOBER 7TH AND THAT'S JUST WHAT
WE KNOW ABOUT, UM, WHAT'S
REPORTED TO US? UM AND THESE
INCLUDE ASSAULT, VANDALISM,
HARASSMENT AND RALLIES THAT USE
ANTI-SEMITIC RHETORIC. THE ONLY,
UH, EXTRA I WILL ADD TO, UM WHAT
SENATOR, UH WEINER TALKED ABOUT
WAS THAT THE EVENT AT SAN JOSE
STATE UNIVERSITY ALSO WAS SHUT
DOWN. SO THE HECKLERS VETO WENT
OUT. AND UM, I'M NOT SAYING IT'S
CAUSATION, BUT, UH VERY SHORTLY
AFTER THAT, UM THAT EVENT, THE
JEWISH STUDIES PROFESSOR WHO HAD
SPONSORED THE PROGRAM, UM,
SUFFERED A HEART ATTACK. AND
WON'T BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TEACHING THIS YEAR THIS FOR THIS
TERM. SO I ASK IS THAT WE IS FOR
ADMINISTRATORS TO MAKE PLAIN
THAT THERE WILL BE REAL
CONSEQUENCES FOR ANTI SEMITIC
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT.
FULL STOP. THIS MEANS
ENFORCEMENT OF ALL NON
DISCRIMINATION AND ANTI
HARASSMENT POLICIES, PLUS
MEETING OUT DISCIPLINARY
MEASURES WHERE WARRANTED. UM
WE'RE ASKING FOR BOTH WORD AND
DEED FOR, UH, FOR THEM TO STAND
UP FOR THEIR JEWISH MEMBERS OF
THEIR JEWISH COMMUNITIES AND ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITIES ON
CAMPUS AS CAMPUS LEADERS. THEN
HERE TODAY MAKE REQUESTS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. WE ASK THE OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO DEMAND THAT
THEY ENSURE A SAFE AND WELCOMING
ENVIRONMENT FOR JEWISH STUDENTS,
BUT ALSO FOR ALL, UH, ALL
MEMBERS, ALL STUDENTS AND
FACULTY AND STAFF ON THEIR
CAMPUSES, UM, AND SO THAT THEY
CAN BE SAFE IN THEIR IDENTITIES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS, AND WE
APPRECIATE AH! AH THE COMMENTS
AND THE DISCUSSION AND THE
PARTICIPATION AND WE KNOW THIS
WILL BE AN ONGOING DISCUSSION.
SO THANK YOU, EVERYBODY FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THAT TODAY. UM,
WE ARE GONNA RETURN. UH UH. TO
THE SUBJECT OF THE BUDGETS OF
THE èC S¼ U AND THE U èC
SYSTEM, AND, UH, LET ME ASK
FIRST, BECAUSE I KNOW YEAH. I
THINK YOU'RE STILL GOOD. BUT TO
SENATOR MIN HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
YOU WISH TO? YEAH, I. I HAD TWO
QUICK QUESTIONS. AND IF I HAVE
TIME, MAYBE A COMMENT AFTER THAT
, UM AND I GUESS REALLY JUST
WANNA GO BACK TO THE 50,000 FT
LEVEL, IF WE FOLLOW THE L A Ó
S¼ RECOMMENDATION HERE AND I
GUESS, LET ACTUALLY LET ME
PREFACE THIS BY SAYING, I. I
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP, BOTH
OF YOU, UM AND, UH, I BELIEVE
STRONGLY IN THE MISSION OF BOTH
YOUR INSTITUTIONS. AND I THINK
YOU'VE HEARD ME SAY THIS BEFORE.
UH BUT I, I OFTEN QUOTE THE
GREEKS WHO ONCE WERE REPORTED TO
SAY THAT A CIVILIZATION IS GREAT
WHEN ITS ELDERS PLANT TREES
WHOSE SHADE THEY KNOW THEY'LL
NEVER SIT UNDER AND TO ME, THE
HIGHEST FORM THE MOST PRODUCTIVE
FORM OF INVESTMENT WE CAN MAKE
IN THE FUTURE IS EDUCATION. UH
AND WE'RE PLANTING TREES IN OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE TO PRODUCE. UM, UH
PEOPLE WHO CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
SOCIETY, AND I KNOW BOTH OF YOUR
INSTITUTIONS HAVE SUCH A GREAT
ROLE TO PLAY IN CALIFORNIA. UH,
I PARTICULARLY WANNA JUST SHOUT
OUT THE èC S¼ U S¼ BECAUSE I
THINK YOU'RE OFTEN OVERLOOKED
BUT YOU PRODUCE SUCH A MASSIVE
OVER SHARE OF OUR WORKFORCE. UH,
BUT WE'RE IN CHALLENGING TIMES
RIGHT NOW AND I PERSONALLY HAVE
HEARD FROM I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT IF THESE ARE STRUCTURAL
DEFICITS WE'RE FACING OR
CYCLICAL DEFICITS. TO WHAT
EXTENT WE'RE SEEING EVIDENCE
EITHER, BUT I'VE HEARD FROM BOTH
SIDES COMPELLING REASONS TO
THINK THAT THIS DOWNTURN MIGHT
BE MORE THAN A COUPLE OF YEARS.
I'VE HEARD PEOPLE WHO ARE MORE
OPTIMISTIC WHO THINK WE'RE GOING
TO GET OUT OF THIS IN A YEAR OR
TWO. BUT I THINK WE YOU KNOW A
AS WE HAVE TO DO WITH BUDGETS.
UH, ASSUME THE WORST AND HOPE
FOR THE BEST. AND UH, YOU KNOW,
IN IN THAT CONTEXT, I'M NOT SURE
THAT THE L A Ó S¼
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE IMPRUDENT.
AH. BUT I DO KINDA WANNA DRILL
DOWN AND ASK, YOU KNOW, I IF WE
WERE TO FOLLOW THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS, UH, WHAT WOULD
THAT MEAN? IN TERMS OF STUDENT?
UH, EXPERIENCE FACULTY WORKFORCE
? UM YOU KNOW THINGS LIKE THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG
THAT I KNOW THE èC S¼ U S¼ ARE
FACING AND HOW WOULD YOU TRY TO
ADAPT? UM AND I KNOW EACH OF YOU
HAVE DIFFERENT, YOU KNOW, YOU
KNOW DIFFERENT, VERY DIFFERENT
BUSINESS MODELS, BUT I JUST
KINDA WANTED TO TOUCH BASE ON ON
THAT, LIKE, I THINK VERY LARGE
AND IMPORTANT QUESTION OF, UH,
WHAT DOES IT MEAN? IF WE'RE
WE'RE ADOPTING EITHER WHAT THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES OR WHAT THE E.
A Ó PROPOSES THAT PARTICULARLY
IF THIS DOWNTURN LASTS MORE THAN
A COUPLE OF YEARS. YEAH, GREAT.
UH, SO IT'S CLEAR A P HÌ Dð OR
AN M Dð DOESN'T HELP WITH, UH
UH, YOUR ABILITY WITH YEAH, WITH
THE DEFECTIVE UH, YEAH. THE
MICROPHONE THAT YOU'RE
PRESENTING WITH, OK, NÓ NÓ OK,
UM UH, THE, UM SO A COUPLE OF
THINGS SO FIRST I APPRECIATE
YOUR YOUR YOUR COMMENTS, SENATOR
AND I, ALSO WITH CHANCELLOR
GARCIA SAID WE ARE, UM UH, A
LONG TERM INVESTMENT. WE DON'T
GO IN YEARLY CYCLES. WE GO IN
LONGER CYCLES AND THAT OUR
STUDENTS COME FOR FOUR YEARS.
OUR FACULTY ARE WITH US FOR
CAREERS. OUR RESEARCH PROJECTS.
THREE 510 YEARS AND SO WE CAN'T
JUST TURN THEM ON AND TURN THEM
OFF. SO WE HAVE TO BE. WE HAVE
TO HAVE A LONGER UH, TIME
HORIZON FOR THE THINGS THAT WE
PLAN. WHAT WE ARE DEALING WITH
ARE TWO OR TWO OR THREE THINGS
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH, UH, ON
A DAILY BASIS ONE. WE'RE DEALING
WITH THIS VERY MINUTE. IF YOU GO
TO OUR ANY OF OUR HOSPITALS, IF
YOU ONE OF YOU WERE TO GO AS A
SPECIAL PERSON IN ONE OF OUR
HOSPITALS AND NEED CARE, UM UH,
YOU'D BE LIKELY IF YOU GOT TO AN
EMERGENCY ROOM. UM, UH, TAKE
HOURS TO BE SEEN OR IF YOU, UM,
HAD CONDITION HAD TO BE TREATED
RIGHT AWAY OFF HOURS BEFORE YOU
COULD GET TO A BED. UH, UH,
EVERY DAY HERE AT AT U, èC
DAVIS BUT IN SAN FRANCISCO AND L
A AT IRVINE, ET CETERA. FOR
THESE LAST SEVERAL YEARS WE HAVE
. WE'RE BOARDING PA PATIENTS IN
OUR ER S¼ BECAUSE THERE'S NOT
ROOM IN THE HOSPITALS TO ACCEPT
THEM MORE THAN THAT. WE TURNED
DOWN ABOUT 20,000 PATIENT
REFERRALS. UH, TRANSFERS A YEAR.
THAT'S UH UH, TRANSFERS FROM
OTHER HOSPITALS, PATIENTS IN OUR
REGIONS. THAT THOSE HOSPITALS
CANNOT HANDLE APPROPRIATELY AND
SEEK OUR CARE FOR THE PARTICULAR
PROBLEMS THEY HAVE ABOUT 20,000
PER YEAR ACROSS OUR SYSTEM, UH,
WHERE WE COULD PROVIDE THE CARE
IF THERE WERE ONLY SPACE TO DO
THAT, BUT WE DON'T HAVE ROOM AND
SO WE'RE TRYING TO GROW OUR
HEALTH CARE ENTERPRISE TO
PROVIDE MORE CARE TO CALIFORNIA
TO NEED IT AS WE SPEAK, AND, UH
AND THAT GROWTH REQUIRES MONEY.
THE RATE AT WHICH WE'RE ABLE TO
GROW WILL DEPEND ON OUR FUNDING.
SO UH UH, NÓ FUNDING OR LESS.
FUNDING MEANS LESS GROWTH MEANS
LONGER WAITS, ETC. AND A QUICK
CALL JUST FOR YOU. I KNOW PART
OF THE CONTACT THAT WAS
IMPORTANT TO A LOT OF US WAS THE
INCREASE IN IN STATE SLOTS. UH,
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE DOING IF WE ARE TO
SAY ADOPT THE L OS
RECOMMENDATION. THE INCREASE IN
INSULATES THOUGHTS CAME BECAUSE
OF AN OF THE DISCUSSIONS WE HAD
HERE WITH YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES ABOUT WAYS THAT WE
COULD FINANCE THE INCREASE IN IN
THOSE SLOTS. AND SO WE HAVE DONE
THAT WE HAVE A DECREASED NUMBER
OF NON RESIDENTS AND
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS AND THE
INCREASED NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS, UH, OVER THESE LAST
YEARS. THOUSANDS MORE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS AND WE HAVE A PLAN TO
GROW THAT THROUGH 20,000
STUDENTS OVER THIS DECADE WERE
ON TARGET FOR THAT. IF FUNDING
IS TO STOP, THEN THAT GROWTH IS
THE KIND OF THING THAT WE CAN'T
CONTINUE TO DO EXACTLY THAT.
THAT'S UM AGAIN, I WOULD SAY
THAT COMES FROM SPECIFIC
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD HERE
ABOUT WHAT WE COULD DO IF WE HAD
THE RIGHT SUPPORT, AND WE'VE WE
BELIEVE IN THAT COMPACT. WE'VE
COME. WE'VE MOVED FORWARD WITH
THAT, AND IT'S WORKED QUITE
WELL. BUT IF IT'S NOT FUNDED,
THEN WE DON'T HAVE THE FACULTY.
WE DON'T HAVE THE FACILITIES TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE THOSE SLOTS
AVAILABLE. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION, SENATOR. MIN. LET ME
BEGIN BY SAYING WE HAVE TRIED TO
LOOK AT THIS AND IT'S NOT A
PRETTY PICTURE. AS OF MARCH,
2024. WE ESTIMATE WE WOULD HAVE
LIKE A $345 MILLION OPERATING
DEFICIT IN 2425 OF THE COMPACT
IS NOT FUNDED FOR SCALE. THAT IS
EQUIVALENT TO 19,600 COURSES
AFFECTING 451 SEATS. WE WOULD
AFFECT 17% OF OUR STAFF,
WORKFORCE AND 8% OF THE FACULTY
WORKFORCE. THAT AMOUNT IS THE
ENTIRE OPERATING BUDGET OF èC
S¼ U, SAN BERNARDINO. AH TO BE
WE ARE LOOKING AT COST REDUCTION
STRATEGIES THAT HAVE TO COME
WITH REALLY TOUGH DECISIONS.
CONSOLIDATED PROGRAMS, DEFER
CAPITAL MAINTENANCE PROJECTS,
REDUCE HIRING AND ELIMINATE
PROGRAMS POSITIONS INCREASE.
SIDE REDUCE COURSES TO REFLECT
STUDENT DEMAND. REDUCE PART TIME
FACULTY LECTURERS REDUCE THE
SERVICES LEVELS PROVIDED BY
STAFF REDUCED TRAVEL,
RESTRUCTURED APARTMENTS RESTRICT
NON-ESSENTIAL PURCHASES. MOST
EVERYTHING IN OUR OPERATING
BUDGET IN 2425 WOULD NOT BE
FUNDED BECAUSE WE ONLY HAVE ONLY
TUITION TO WORK WITH THE
POSSIBLE OUTCOME COULD INCLUDE
NOT GROW ENROLLMENT AT OUR MOST
IN DEMAND CAMPUSES AND YOU HEARD
ME SPEAK EARLIER THAT OUR
ENROLLMENT IS GOING UP AND WE
DON'T WANT OUR CALIFORNIANS NOT
TO HAVE THE ACCESS TO OUR
WONDERFUL UNIVERSITIES AND WE
WERE. WE WERE REALLY STRAND OUR
CAMPUSES WITH MANY UNFUNDED COST
INCREASES, WE WOULD HAVE TO
EXPAND TITLE IX AND CAL NAKA
WORK AT THE EXPENSE OF
WRAPAROUND STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES AND ACADEMIC OFFERINGS.
AND WE WOULD HAVE TO STRAND OUR
CAMPUSES WITH NEARLY ALL
COMPENSATION COST INCREASES. SO
THINK THAT GIVES YOU A PICTURE.
THANK YOU. UH, I HAVE TO LEAVE
IN A MOMENT. BUT I JUST HAVE ONE
QUICK, UNRELATED, FOLLOW UP
COMMENT. I JUST WANTED TO RAISE
TO PRESIDENT DRAKE. AND YOU AND
I HAD A VERY, VERY BRIEF
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS, BUT, UH
UH, YOU AND I TALKED A FEW YEARS
AGO ABOUT THE DECISION FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO END
STANDARDIZED TESTING. AND IF I'M
REMEMBERING AT THAT POINT IN
TIME CORRECTLY, I THINK YOU
ASSURED ME WE HAD A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PROXIES AND METRICS
THAT COULD BE USED TO PREDICT
STUDENT OUTCOMES AND PERFORMANCE
THAT COULD END UP BEING SUPERIOR
TO STANDARDIZED TESTS. I WILL
JUST NOTE THAT SINCE THAT TIME,
UM M I Tð YALE BROWN HAVE
RESUMED THE USE OF STANDARDIZED
TESTING. UH THE UNIVERSITY OF
TEXAS AUSTIN JUST DID RESUMED IT
AND ELIMINATED THAT OPTIONAL AND
NÓ TEST REQUIREMENT, UM, PRONG,
AND THEY RELEASED A LOT OF DATA
THAT I ACTUALLY FOUND VERY, VERY
INTERESTING, UH, FINDING THAT ON
AVERAGE THE STUDENTS THAT DID
NOT SUBMIT TEST SCORES PERFORM
0.86 ON THEIR GPA ALMOST A FULL
LETTER GRADE WORSE THAN THEIR
COUNTERPARTS WHO, UH, WENT UNDER
THE UNDER THE STANDARD
STANDARDIZED TEST REGIME. UH YOU
KNOW, I WAS ON THE ADMISSIONS
COMMITTEE FOR A YEAR AT U èC,
IRVINE LAW SCHOOL, AND I I'M
AWARE OF SOME OF THE DATA THAT
WE HAVE AGGREGATED THAT THAT
REALLY STRONGLY SUGGESTS THAT
STANDARDIZED TESTS, UH, ARE A
STRONG PREDICTOR OF STUDENT
OUTCOMES AND PERFORMANCE. UH, I
UNDERSTAND. I THINK THE
REASONING BEHIND TRYING TO MOVE
TO A DIFFERENT UM, PROXY I, I
YOU KNOW, AND I APPLAUD THE
GOALS HERE, I. I THINK EQUITY IS
REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT IN
HIGHER EDUCATION, PARTICULARLY
GIVEN THE LONG HISTORY OF
DISCRIMINATION. OF UM FAILED
OUTCOMES AMONG MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. UH AND I. I APPLAUD
THE EFFORT TO TRY TO, YOU KNOW,
LIFT PEOPLE UP. UH, AT THE SAME
TIME, YOU KNOW IF WE'RE ENDING
UP WITH AN OUTCOME WHERE, UH,
YOU HAVE STUDENTS UNDER
PERFORMING WHERE IT POTENTIALLY
IMPACTS GRADUATION RATES AFTER
THEY'RE ADMITTED II. I DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT. UH AND
FINALLY, I GUESS I JUST
MENTIONED AS AN ASIAN AMERICAN
AS VICE CHAIR OF THE A P A
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. I I'VE
RECEIVED A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT
FROM ASIAN PARENTS AND STUDENTS.
UH, WHO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
BACKDOOR MECHANISM OF
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST API
STUDENTS? UH, THAT AND I CAN
JUST TELL YOU THAT THAT
SENTIMENT IS VERY WIDESPREAD.
AND I THINK I WOULD BE REMISS IF
I DIDN'T MENTION THAT
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE DECISION
BY A NUMBER OF PROMINENT
INSTITUTIONS TO REVERSE ON THAT.
SO I, I GUESS I'D JUST BE
CURIOUS I. I DON'T HAVE TIME FOR
A RESPONSE. UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE I HAVE ANOTHER
COMMITMENT AND SO I DON'T WANNA
LEAVE IT CLIFF HANGER, BUT I I'D
LOVE TO CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE
AND I'D LOVE TO SEE AT SOME
POINT IF U èC HAS COLLECTED
DATA ON PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES AS
WELL, UM, AND BECAUSE I THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT DISCUSSION
TO HAVE, BUT THANK YOU. I HAVE
AS YOU'RE LEAVING 15 SECONDS TO
SAY WE'VE LOOKED AT THIS. AND
SINCE OUR CONVERSATION I LOOKED
AT OUR THE PRELIMINARY RESULTS
OF OUR CLASSES 2019 CLASS
COMPARED TO 2020 THREE. WE FIND
THE, UM PERSISTENCE RATE OF
STUDENTS THE SAME TO THE DECIMAL
POINT, SO IT'S NOT GONE DOWN AT
ALL. IN FACT, IN FACT, INCREASES
IN THE PERCENTAGES OF, UH,
AFRICAN AMERICAN, UH, LATINO OF
ASIAN STUDENTS IN OUR SCHOOLS
SINCE 2019 10,000 MORE OFFERS TO
ASIAN STUDENTS IN 2020 THREE
THAN WAS THE CASE. IN 2019. SO
WE'VE BEEN GROWING. UM AND SO
WE'LL TALK MORE ABOUT THIS, BUT
WE HAVE DATA TO SHOW THAT SHOWS
THAT THINGS ARE ACTUALLY NOT
WORKING SO BADLY, OK? THANK YOU.
OK NOW, UM GOING TO SOME GLOBAL
QUESTIONS AS WELL. LET ME I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THE DEFERRALS IN
IN DIFFERENT WAYS. AND LET ME
ASK THE QUESTION WHERE I KNOW
WHAT THE ANSWER IS GONNA BE, BUT
I'M GONNA ASK IT ANYWAY. UH UH
UH, I'M GONNA ASK THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. HOW DO YOU HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE THAT WE COULD GIVE A
10% RAISE TO U èC AND èC S¼ U
IN THE NEXT BUDGET YEAR BY
DEFERRING THESE 5% THIS YEAR
YEAH, CERTAINLY. WE LOOK AT THE
TOTALITY OF THE BUDGETS. UH,
FROM ONE YEAR TO THE NEXT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS SOME
RISK. UM YOU KNOW OUR MULTIYEAR.
UH PROJECTION DOES SHOW AN OUT
YEAR DEFICIT. UM, THAT SAID IT
REMAINS A PRIORITY OF THE
ADMINISTRATION TO SUPPORT UH,
THE INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IN THE STATE. UM
SPECIFICALLY, YOU KNOW, OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM OR
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM OR UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM. UM, SO OUR
OUR DEGREE OF CONFIDENCE IS THAT
WE REMAIN STRONG SUPPORTERS OF
OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEMS. UM
AND, UH, WHILE WE DON'T KNOW,
UH, WE WOULD CERTAINLY SAY, UH,
THAT, UH, WE WOULD DO EVERYTHING
IN OUR POWER TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S UH FUNDED I APPRECIATE
THAT AND I ALWAYS HAVE TO
ANNOUNCE MY SNARKY COMMENTS AND
SNARLY. I WOULD SAY WE'RE STRONG
SUPPORTERS OF EVERYTHING WE'RE
CUTTING THIS YEAR. UH UH. AND SO
I HAVE GREAT CONCERNS ABOUT OUR
ABILITY. TO GIVE A 10% B DO YOU
SEE IN èC S¼ U NEXT YEAR IF
THERE IS A RESIDUAL DEFICIT OF
ANY KIND, AND PARTICULARLY, THE
CHANCELLOR WAS VERY ARTICULATE
ABOUT GOING THROUGH. BUT IF THIS
YEAR WHAT I DON'T TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND IS DO EACH OF YOU DIP
INTO RESERVES TO MAKE THE 5%
EXPENDITURE, BETTING THAT THE 5%
WILL COME NEXT YEAR, AND IT WILL
EVEN ITSELF OUT. IS THAT HOW YOU
ARE HANDLING THE DEFERRAL? START
WITH THE CHANCELLOR. AND THEN
IT'S YES, IT'S ONE TIME MONEY.
IT'S NOT RECURRING FUNDS. WE
WOULD TAKE IT OVER OUR $766
MILLION AND USE IT TO REALLY GET
US THROUGH THIS YEAR AND HOPE
FOR THE NEXT YEAR. WE DO A
COMBINATION OF THINGS, ACTUALLY,
THAT SOME OF THAT SOME, UH,
BORROWING, SOME SHIFTING AND
THEN ALSO SOME, UH, PULLING BACK
ON THE RATE AT WHICH WE'RE
EXPANDING PROGRAMS. UH, UM
HOPING. AND UM, UH, BELIEVING
THAT THE GOVERNOR AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WILL COME TO
FRUITION, BUT UNDERSTANDING THAT
THAT'S NOT 100% GUARANTEED. WE
DON'T WANT TO BE SURPRISED NEXT
YEAR. SO WE'RE THINKING EVEN NOW
ABOUT, UM, PULLING BACK ON
EXPANSIONS THAT WE WERE
EXPECTING. AND WHAT IT REALLY
MEANS IS IF IN FACT WE HAVE A
RESIDUAL DEFICIT AND COULD ONLY
DO SAY 5% NEXT YEAR, AND THAT'S
OPTIMISTIC. I MEAN, IF IT'S
REALLY RESIDUAL, THE WHOLE THING
COULD BE CHALLENGED. THEN YOU'RE
OUT RESERVES AND YOU MIGHT BE
SLIGHTLY OK WHERE YOU'VE
CONTRACTED OR NOT EXPANDED SPENT
. BUT THEN YOU'RE OUT WHATEVER
IT IS THAT YOU SPENT AND WE'D BE
OUT RESERVES. WE KEEP, UH, OUR
RESERVES BROADLY. I MEAN, WE
HAVE RESERVES IN OUR HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS THAT ARE THERE FOR SO
THOSE ARE KIND OF, UH AND WE'RE
CONSTRUCTING HOSPITALS AT THIS
AT THIS TIME, SO YOU KNOW THOSE
ARE THERE BUT THE GENERAL CAMPUS
RESERVES ARE THE RESERVES IN MY
OFFICE ARE ACTUALLY MINIMAL. SO
THEY YOU MENTIONED NINE DAYS
RESERVE SO WE CAN SPEND INTO
RESERVES, BUT THEY GET US TO THE
MIDDLE OF NEXT WEEK. SO THAT'S
THERE'S JUST NOT MUCH THERE AND
THEN BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ON THE OUT OF STATE
STUDENT BACKFILL IS THAT PART OF
THE 5% OR IS THAT ON TOP OF IT,
AND IS IT A DEFERRAL? THAT IS IT
AN ACTUAL CUT. THAT THAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING THAT WOULD BE ON TOP
OF THE 5% DEFERRAL. WE ARE
PROPOSING TO ALSO DEFER THAT
AMOUNT FROM ONE FISCAL YEAR TO
THE NEXT. UM AND THAT ALSO WOULD
BE REPAID AND BECOME PART OF
THEIR ONGOING BASE. UH, IN 2526,
AS WELL AS THE ADDITIONAL AMOUNT
OF FUNDING FOR THE NEXT 902
STUDENTS WOULD ALSO BE PART OF
THAT BASE. UM THE NEXT YEAR AS
WELL. SO YOU'D HAVE THAT SAME
SORT OF, UM, DOUBLE PAYMENT
SCENARIO OCCURRING, YOU'D HAVE A
ONE TIME PAYMENT AND DOUBLING OF
THE PAYMENT FOR THAT PARTICULAR
ENDEAVOR AS WELL. UM ONE OF THE
THINGS ABOUT PUBLIC LIFE IS THAT
THERE ARE MANY TIMES WHEN PEOPLE
HAVE THE RIGHT TO SAY I TOLD YOU
SO. AND THEN YOU'RE VERY
GRATEFUL WHEN THEY DON'T
ACTUALLY DO IT IN AND IT WAS
MISS VERTIN AND THAT TESTIFIED
IN FRONT OF THIS COMMITTEE,
SAYING THERE WILL BE A DOWNTIME
AND THERE WILL BE A TIME THAT
THE OUT OF STATE TUITION
BACKFILL IS CHALLENGED IF WE
AGREED TO THAT SHE WAS SKEPTICAL
AT THE TIME OF THE OVERALL THING
, AND WE MOVED ON THAT, BUT HERE
WE ARE, AND SO I THINK THAT WE
HAVE A STRONG CONCERN THAT THAT
BE MADE TOTALLY GOOD. AND HAPPEN
, AND THEN I HAVE A DIFFERENT,
UH, UNIQUE QUESTION FOR EACH. UH
UH, SEGMENT AND FOR èC S¼ U FOR
THE CHANCELLOR. THE CONTRACT
THAT YOU AGREED TO WITH THE
FACULTY AS I READ IT. SAYS THAT
THAT YOUR, UH HAVE TO MAKE GOOD
THE 5% INCREASE THIS YEAR, THE
5% INCREASE NEXT YEAR IF BASE
FUNDING IS NOT CUT. IS THAT THE
RIGHT WAY IT IS FORMULATED. SO
THAT IF UH UH, LET'S JUST SAY
RIGHT NOW. IN THIS YEAR, THE 5%
FROM THE COMPACT IS MIGHT BE
DEFERRED. AND THEN YOU ARE
MAKING GOOD. THE 5% ON THE, UH,
THE SALARY EVEN THOUGH THE
COMPACT WHICH MIGHT HELP YOU PAY
FOR IT IS BEING DEFERRED.
CORRECT AND THEN IF YOU WERE IN
THE WORST OF SCENARIOS OUT FIVE
OR 10% BECAUSE THE DEFERRAL
ISN'T MADE GOOD. YOU HAVE A FIVE
PER CENT NEXT YEAR AS WELL. AND
YOU ARE ALSO EATING FAT WITHIN
YOUR BUDGET. SO IT MAKES AN
URGENCY TO MAKING SURE THAT THE
DEFERRAL TRULY IS A DEFERRAL TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT THAT HAPPENS
YES, AND WE ARE PRAYING AND
HOPING THAT THAT WILL HAPPEN AND
THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS
CONTINUED SUPPORT. YES, BUT AS I
REMINDED PRESIDENT BLAKE,
THERE'S OTHER PEOPLE BESIDES THE
GOVERNOR INVOLVED IN THIS
PROCESS, I UNDERSTAND AND THEN
WITH, UH PRESIDENT DRAKE, UM WE
HAVE HAD LIVELY DISCUSSIONS THE
LAST TWO THREE YEARS ABOUT THE
CONTRACTING OUT ISSUE WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA, AND
YOU ISSUED A REPORT LAST. I
THINK IT'S AUGUST ON THE STATUS
OF WHAT CONTRACTING OUT IS, UH,
HOW WOULD YOU CHARACTERIZE THAT
AT THIS POINT FOR THE COMMITTEE
ON JUST HOW YOU'RE DOING ON THAT
ISSUE WHERE IT'S GOING? WHETHER
YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'RE ON TOP OF
IT? YEAH BUT SO FIRST WE'RE A
VERY LARGE ENTERPRISE. AS YOU
KNOW, WITH ALL OUR CAMPUSES.
THE, UM ETCETERA, THEN ARE THE
DIVISION OF AGRICULTURAL AND
NATURAL RESOURCE ALL ACROSS THE
STATE, AND, UM, OUR GOAL IS TO
HAVE AS MANY OF OUR WORKERS, UH
IN SOURCE. UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYEES AS POSSIBLE
. THERE ARE ANY NUMBER OF TIMES,
THOUGH, WHEN WE DON'T HAVE
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE AVAILABLE OR
PARTICULARLY TUNED FOR THE TYPE
OF SERVICE THAT WE NEED, AND SO
WE, IT'S NECESSARY FOR US TO
HAVE CONTRACTS WITH OTHER
ENTITIES. FROM TIME TO TIME. THE
TINY ONE JUST FOR THE COMMITTEE.
UH, WHEN I WAS AT U èC, IRVINE,
WE HAD OLIVE TREES. UM UH, AT
THE RESIDENCE THAT HAD TO BE
PRUNED ONCE A YEAR OVER ABOUT A
TWO WEEK PERIOD. IT DIDN'T MAKE
SENSE FOR US TO HAVE A FULL TIME
EMPLOYEE WHO KNEW THIS
SPECIALTY. THAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT WE CONTRACTED OUT FOR, UH,
BECAUSE IT WAS A, UH THERE WAS
ONE. IT WAS A ONE TIME ISSUE. WE
ALSO HAVE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE WE
CAN'T FIND THROUGH OUR NORMAL UH
I EM EMPLOYEE BASE. WE CAN'T
FIND EMPLOYEES TO COVER THE WORK
THAT WE NEED. WE SEE THIS IN TWO
WAYS. NOW UM, UH, THAT THAT COME
UP ONE NURSES. WE HAVE TO USE A
REGISTRY NURSES A LOT. UH, WHEN
WE HAD MENTIONED HOW
OVERBURDENED OUR HOSPITALS ARE,
WE SPEND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
MORE THAN MARKET RATES TO BRING
REGISTRY NURSES IN TO DO
SERVICES BECAUSE WE CAN'T KEEP A
WORKFORCE. UM UM UH UH, HIRED TO
BE ABLE TO, UH TEND TO ALL OF
OUR SERVICES. WE MUCH PREFER TO
DO THAT. MUCH LESS EXPENSIVE FOR
US, MUCH MORE EFFECTIVE, BUT
IT'S UH BUT THE WORKFORCE IS NOT
THERE. AND WE'VE HAD THIS HAPPEN
WITH FOOD SERVICE WORKERS AND
OTHER THINGS, UH, DURING THE
PANDEMIC IN PARTICULAR, WE HAD
TO SHUT DOWN SOME OF OUR, UM,
UH, FOOD SERVICE. UM, UH,
ENTERPRISES BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
HAVE ENOUGH APPLICANTS FOR THE
JOBS WE NEEDED TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE PEOPLE. SO THOSE, UH UH
UH, OCCASIONS OCCUR BUT
OVERWHELMINGLY, BUT OUR FIRST
CHOICE ALWAYS AND OVERWHELMINGLY
, WE USE WE FOLLOW THE
GUIDELINES OF OUR REGIONS AND
STATE LAW, THE REGIONS.
RESTRICTIONS ARE IN MANY CASES
MORE, UM UH, IMPACTFUL EVEN AND
SO WE DO OUR BEST TO KEEP UP
WITH THOSE. UH UH UH, THE, UM UH
, AUDITING OF AND REPORTING OF
OUR CONTRACTING OUT AND I THINK
THAT IT'S UH, WORKING QUITE WELL
. HAS SOME, UH I KNOW INDIVIDUAL
DATA IF YOU NEED THAT, BUT WE
FIND THAT WERE OVERWHELMINGLY,
UH, ABLE TO WORK WITH IN SOURCE
LABOR ALL THE TIME. THAT'S GREAT
. IT'S NOT 100% AND, UH, WE KEEP
CAREFUL RECORDS WHEN IT'S NOT. I
WON'T WORK WITH HER OVER TIME. I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE HEARING DIDN'T GO BY WITHOUT
US, ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THAT'S AN
ISSUE AND THAT WE'RE CONCERNED
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THERE'S
PROGRESS. AND I CAN ALSO TELL
YOU THAT GOVERNOR BROWN GETS
FORMER STAFF MEMBERS TO DO FREE
LABOR ON OLIVE TREES. YOU MIGHT
CONSULT WITH HIM. UH UH, I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE WOULD, UH, NÓ. WE
BELIEVE IN PLAYING PEOPLE FAIRLY
FOR THEIR THEIR LABOR AS WE
APPRECIATE THEM, AND WE YES, BUT
HE WOULD HAVE NOT PAID HIS
CABINET SECRETARIES. IF HE COULD
HAVE GOTTEN AWAY WITH IT. I CAN
TESTIFY TO THAT. AND YOU ALSO
HAVE, UM OH, IT'S IN OUR, UH UH,
PACKET A LIST OF LABOR
AGREEMENTS THAT THE NEGOTIATIONS
ARE COMING UP ON. AND SO WHAT WE
DO HERE WILL REFLECT ON YOUR
ABILITY TO DEAL WITH THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS, CORRECT. YES, WE?
YEAH, WE'RE WE HAVE SEVERAL THAT
ARE COMING UP. UH, THIS YEAR AND
NEXT YEAR AND WE HAVE, UM, ABOUT
ABOUT 15. I THINK SYSTEM WIDE
AND 22 CAMPUS WIDE. SO THERE
IT'S SOMETHING THEY'RE ALWAYS
ONES THAT ARE COMING. THERE'S
SEVERAL THAT WE'VE JUST, UM UH,
BEEN THROUGH, SO WE DO OUR VERY
BEST TO BE GOOD PARTNERS. IN
THOSE DISCUSSIONS. WE APPRECIATE
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING. UH,
APPARATUS THAT, UH, WE HAVE IN
PLACE. WE BELIEVE THAT OUR
WORKERS HAVE A CHA, UH, THE
RIGHT TO ORGANIZE AND WE DO OUR
VERY BEST TO BE GOOD PARTNERS
AND THIS WE WANT TO BE THE BEST
PLACE TO WORK. IN THE STATE,
RIGHT? AND THEN ONE LAST
QUESTION FOR BOTH OF YOU. WE? WE
HAVE A, UM I LET YOU OFF THE
HOOK. WE HAVE AN ANTI ACRONYM
POLICY HERE AND YOU MANAGED TO
SAY NAGRA, UH AND LET IT GO BY
WW, WHICH IS THE NATIVE AMERICAN
GRAVES PROTECTION AND
REPATRIATION ACT. I WANTED TO
ASK YOU BOTH ABOUT IT. AND
BEFORE YOU GOT HERE, A
CHANCELLOR, THERE WAS AN AUDIT
AND THERE WAS A RE RATHER LIVELY
HEARING ON IT IN THE, UH, JOINT
LEGISLATIVE, A COMMITTEE. UH AND
I. I THINK ONE OF YOUR
REFERENCES WAS IS YOU REALLY
WANNA DO THIS? BUT YOU YOU
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TROUBLE WITH
IF YOU DON'T HAVE MONEY TO PAY
FOR IT. COULD YOU COMMENT ON
YOUR PROGRESS AND YOU COMMENT ON
WHAT IT WILL TAKE TO FULLY
IMPLEMENT WHAT'S NEEDED UNDER
THE ACT, SO LET ME BEGIN BY
SAYING THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME
AND TO THE SYSTEM. I ALWAYS
THINK ABOUT THIS IS WHAT WOULD
YOU FEEL LIKE IF YOU HAD YOUR
OWN ANCESTORS ITEMS UTILIZED THE
WAY THEY'RE BEING UTILIZED ON
OUR CAMPUS. SO FOR ME, THIS IS
VERY, VERY IMPORTANT AS WELL AS
OUR BOARD AND EACH ONE OF OUR
PRESIDENTS. WE HAVE BEGUN
CONSULTING COLLABORATING WITH
OUR CHARITABLE PARTNERS TO
REPATRIATE ALL ANCESTORS AND
CULTURAL ITEMS. WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A POSITIVE AND
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION ON TWO
OCCASIONS, EXECUTIVE SECRETARY
RAYMOND HITCHCOCK ADDRESSED OUR
BOARD OF TRUSTEES AND OUR
PRESIDENTS ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
REPATRIATION AND CONSULTATION.
OUR CAMPUSES CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD. FOR EXAMPLE, CHICO
STATE REPATRIATED 532 ANCESTORS
AND MORE THAN 87,935 CULTURAL
ITEMS TO A CONSORTIUM OF SICK
LOCAL TRIBES. SACRAMENTO STATE
REPATRIATED 112 ANCESTORS AND 20
THREE 20 THREE 1002 120 CULTURAL
ITEMS TO LOCAL TRIBES. WE HAVE A
HUMBOLDT REPATRIATED LAND THAT
THEY WILL BE WORKING TOGETHER TO
SOME TEACHING AND LEARNING. WE
ALSO ARE MAKING HOPEFULLY THEY
CAN USE EXTRA MONEY THEY'VE
GOTTEN FOR BEING A COW POLY. WE
ALSO WE ALSO HAVE, UM, MADE SURE
THAT WE'RE COMPLETING REVIEWS OF
OUR UNIVERSITY COLLECTIONS,
CREATING A SYSTEM WIDE MACRO
POLICY HIRING A FULL TIME
NETWORK COORDINATOR AT EACH
UNIVERSITY, CREATING SYSTEM WIDE
AND CAMPUS COMMITTEES, WHO HAVE
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBAL
REPRESENTATION AND PROHIBITING
THE USE OF ITEMS IN TEACHING AND
RESEARCH. THIS CONTINUES, WE
HAVE ONE PRESIDENT, FOR EXAMPLE,
ACTUALLY WORKING WITH ALL
COLLEGE PRESIDENTS TO ENSURE
THAT IT'S WORKING. IT IS ALSO
DISCUSSED AT EVERY THAT I HAD
WITH THE PRESIDENT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE ON TARGET, AND IN
ADDITION TO THE ALL PRESIDENTS
HAVE THAT AS ONE OF THEIR GOALS
AS THEY MEET WITH ME AT THE END
OF THE YEAR, TELL ME HOW THEY
ARE PROGRESSING AND ABIDING BY
THE AUDIT AND ABIDING WHAT? WHAT
IS MORAL? THANK YOU. WE
APPRECIATE IT. AND WE WANNA, UH,
JUST KEEP TRACK OF WHAT'S GOING
ON THERE. PRESIDENT DRAKE. UH
UH, THANK YOU. SIMILAR WE HAVE.
WE'RE COMMITTED TO THE
REPATRIATION OF NATIVE AMERICAN
HUMAN REMAINS AND CULTURAL ITEMS
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE FEDERAL
NATIVE AMERICAN GRAVES
PROTECTION AND REPATRIATION ACT,
AND IT'S ACCOMPANYING
REGULATIONS AND CAL NERA AS AS
WELL. WE'VE DEVELOPED AN ISSUED
NEW U èC POLICY ON NATIVE
AMERICAN CULTURAL AFFILIATION
AND REPATRIATION, WHICH TOOK
PLACE IN 2022. IT FOLLOWS MANY
ITERATIONS AND REVISIONS TO THE
REVISIONS TO THE CALD BACK. FROM
NUMEROUS STAKEHOLDERS, INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES. I MEET WITH AN ADVISORY
BOARD EVERY QUARTER. UH AND WE
HAVE A ROBUST DISCUSSION. THIS
NÓ NÓ BY NÓ MEANS REPRESENTS THE
END OF THE UNIVERSITY'S EFFORTS.
THESE ARE ON ONGOING EFFORTS
OVER MANY, MANY YEARS. WE UH,
THIS, UH, LAST YEAR HAVE HIRED A
, UH, SYSTEM WIDE COORDINATOR
FOR THE REPATRIATION EFFORTS.
UM, AND SHE'S BEEN WORKING WITH
EACH OF OUR U èC CAMPUSES FOR
THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS TO
SUPPORT AN EXPEDITE THEIR
REPATRIATION EFFORTS. ACTIVITIES
AND WE PROVIDED SYSTEM. I UH,
FUNDING TO ASSIST THE CAMPUSES
IN THE FUNDING THAT THEY ALREADY
ARE PROVIDING FOR THIS ONGOING
EFFORT, AND I'LL MENTION ONE
OTHER THING THAT WE'VE DONE. UH,
THIS LAST. UM, UH, TWO YEARS AGO
NOW, UH AND NOT A STRICTLY UNDER
CAL, UH, NAG OR, UH, NAG, BUT
BROADLY IN IN FOCUSING ON NATIVE
AMERICAN, UH UH, FELLOW CITIZENS
, WE'VE DONE TWO THINGS ONE.
WE'VE DEVELOPED THE NATIVE
AMERICAN OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM.
WHICH SAYS THAT FOR, UH,
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS OF NATIVE OF
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED AMERICAN
TRIBES. WE COVER THE TUITION FOR
THEIR ATTENDANCE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT ALL
OF OUR CAMPUSES. THAT'S A NEW
PROGRAM AND ACTUALLY, SINCE THAT
PROGRAM WAS ANNOUNCED, WE
NOTICED THAT NEXT YEAR WE HAVE
ABOUT A 40% INCREASE IN NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDENTS AT ONE OF OUR
CAMPUSES THAT HAD EARLY, UH,
EARLY DATA, SO WE THINK THAT
THAT'S UM A GOOD THING. UH, SO
WE'RE WE'RE PLEASED ABOUT THAT,
AND WE MENTIONED THE PRIME
PROGRAMS EARLIER PROGRAMS IN
MEDICAL EDUCATION THAT FOCUS ON
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. AND
LAST YEAR WE, UH, STARTED A
PRIME PROGRAM FOCUSING
SPECIFICALLY ON HEALTH ISSUES OF
THE NATIVE AMERICAN POPULATION
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, SO WE ARE
DEDICATED TO DOING OUR BEST
UNDER CAL, NEB AND DOING MORE TO
HELP SUPPORT OUR FELLOW
CITIZENS. OK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
, AND WE AS WELL WITH YOU WILL
WANT TO KEEP TRACK OF IT AND
MAKE SURE BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE
FINALLY GETTING ON A TRACK TO
DEAL WITH THIS, BUT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE IT'S DONE AND
EXPEDITIOUSLY. SO UM, THAT
COMPLETES MY QUESTIONS, AND WE
HAVE OTHER THINGS YOU'VE
MENTIONED THAT WE'LL GET TO IN
THE OTHER ITEMS LIKE THE MEDICAL
SCHOOL FUNDING AND, UH,
ENROLLMENT AND DIVERSITY AND
OTHER THINGS AND SO, BUT WE
STARTED VERY LATE, AND THIS HAS
BEEN MUCH LONGER AS AN ITEM THAN
WE HAD ANTICIPATED. SO I KNOW
YOU'RE BOTH VERY BUSY PEOPLE,
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT YOU STUCK IT OUT AND
PARTICIPATED WITH US TODAY.
SENATORS AND SENATORS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIR FOR
REALLY GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALL YOUR SUPPORT THAT I KNOW
YOU LOVE BOTH èC S¼ U AND THE U
èC AND LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
CONTINUANCE. I THROW IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND WELL THEN
I HERE BUT I WILL THROW THEM
INTO HOW IS THAT? AS A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE GRADUATE, I GET IT. I
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH. AND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. UH, WE
WILL MOVE TO, UH, ISSUE NUMBER
TWO. WHICH IS HIGHER EDUCATION,
STUDENT HOUSING. AND UH, I
BELIEVE WE'LL HAVE, UH ALEX AND
IA VELASQUEZ FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. JENNIFER PELLA. I
HAVE WILL REMAIN HERE AS THEY
HAVE. VERIN WILL REMAIN HERE AND
WE HAVE PAUL GANON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM. AND I THINK WE'LL GO. UH
UH, IN THE ORDER OF FINANCE,
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA, CALIFORNIA STATE,
UH, UNIVERSITY SYSTEM SO WELCOME
AND LET'S START WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. MR CHAIR.
GOOD MORNING, MR CHAIR, ALEX.
AND I HAVE, ALAS, WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT HOUSING
REVOLVING LOAN FUND. THE 2020
THREE BUDGET ACT APPROVED A
MULTIYEAR INVESTMENT OF ONE
POINT 7,000,000,001 TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR OVER SIX YEARS, WHICH
IS COMPRISED OF 200 MILLION IN
THE CURRENT YEAR. 2020 THREE 24
AND THEN THREE 100,000,001 TIME
GENERAL FUND EACH YEAR FROM 2024
25 TO 2028 29. GIVEN THE BUDGET
REVENUE OUTLOOK, THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES SUSPENDING
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM. THIS
INCLUDES PULLING BACK THE PLAN
ONE POINT 5,000,000,001 TIME
GENERAL FUND INVESTMENTS FROM
2024 25 TO 2028 29 AND REVERTING
194 MILLION OF THE 200,000,001
TIME GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATED
IN THE CURRENT YEAR, 2020 THREE
24 THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS,
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. GREAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. WE'LL GO TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST JENNIFER AGAIN LED
ANALYSTS OFFICE. SO YOU HAVE
SEVERAL CAPITAL ITEMS BEFORE YOU
WITHIN THIS ISSUE REGARDING THE
REVOLVING LOAN FUND PROGRAM THAT
YOU JUST HEARD ABOUT. WE THINK
IT'S A REASONABLE BUDGET
SOLUTION. IT'S BY FAR THE
LARGEST HIGHER ED SOLUTION
BEFORE YOU AT 1.7 BILLION. IT'S
ONE OF THOSE SOLUTIONS THAT
WON'T HAVE A DIRECT IMMEDIATE
IMPACT ON STUDENTS FACULTY
STAFF, SO WE THINK IT'S
REASONABLE TO THAT ARE GIVEN THE
STATE'S BUDGET CONDITION.
TURNING TO THE PROJECTS OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS, THE STATE HAS
APPROVED EIGHT U èC HOUSING
PROJECTS AND THREE ACADEMIC
PROJECTS. OF THE EIGHT HOUSING
PROJECTS. SIX ARE UNDER
CONSTRUCTION. UM AND OR U èC
HAS ALREADY BORROWED FOR THE
PROJECT. THE REMAINING TWO
PROJECTS ARE THE SANTA CRUZ
INTER SEGMENTAL HOUSING PROJECT
AND THE MERS THAT INNER
SEGMENTAL HOUSING PROJECT. OF
THE THREE ACADEMIC PROJECTS. TWO
WERE IN THE CONSTRUCTION PHASE,
AND OR YOU èC S¼ R Dð BORROWED
FOR THE PROJECTS. THE ONE
REMAINING PROJECT IS THE U
CAMPUS EXPANSION PROJECT. SO WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE PAUSE.
THE THREE PROJECTS THE TWO INNER
SEGMENTAL HOUSING PROJECTS AND
THE MERCED EXPANSION PROJECT.
THEY REMAIN IN EARLY PLANNING
PHASES. U èC S¼ NOT SOLD THE
BONDS IN TOTAL. IT'S THREE 106
MILLION IN PROJECT COST 22
MILLION IN DEBT SERVICE. ALL
THREE PROJECTS ARE NEW
CONSTRUCTION, MEANING THERE'S
NOT ONLY THE NEAR TERM COST OF
BUILDING IT, BUT ALSO THE LONGER
TERM COST OF HAVING A NEW
FACILITY IN THEIR PORTFOLIO TO
MAINTAIN OVER TIME. THE OBJECT
AND AGAIN OF PAUSING THE
PROJECTS IS JUST DUE TO THE
STATE'S BUDGET SITUATION. ALL
THREE PROJECTS COULD BE
REVISITED WHEN THE BUDGET
SITUATION IMPROVES. TURNING TO
THE CSU PROJECTS. OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS, THE STATE HAS
APPROVED 12 STUDENT HOUSING
PROJECTS AT U AT èC, S¼ U AND
NINE ACADEMIC AND OTHER PROJECTS
OF THE 12 HOUSING PROJECTS FOR
OUR IN CONSTRUCTION. THE
REMAINING AID ARE IN PRELIMINARY
PLANS OR WORKING DRAWINGS AND
DESIGN èC S¼ U S¼ HAS SOLD A
UNIVERSITY BONDS FOR NINE OF
THOSE 12 PROJECTS. FOR THE OTHER
ACADEMIC OTHER PROJECTS, ONLY
ONE IS IN THE CONSTRUCTION PHASE
. èC S¼ U HAS SOLD BONDS FOR
ALL OF THOSE PARTICULAR
PROJECTS. WHEREAS THE UNIVERSITY
TYPICALLY SELLS BONDS, UM ONCE
PROJECTS ARE NEARING COMPLETION.
UM THEY DID SELL BONDS SORT OF
EARLY THIS TIME AROUND, SO THEY
NORMALLY DO TAX EXEMPT BONDS AND
THIS TIME AROUND, THEY DID
TAXABLE BONDS, WHICH GIVE THEM
EFFECTIVELY LONGER TO COMPLETE
THE PROJECTS. THOSE TAXABLE
BONDS COME AT HIGHER INTEREST
RATES. SIMILAR TO YOU. SEE WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE PAUSE
THE THREE STUDENT HOUSING
PROJECTS FOR WHICH BONDS HAVE
NOT YET BEEN SOLD THAT TOTALS
100 AND 49 MILLION IN PROJECT
COSTS AND ESTIMATED 12 MILLION
IN DEBT SERVICE, AS YOU'LL HEAR
MORE ABOUT THIS WOULD BE
PROBLEMATIC FOR THE SAN JOSE
HOUSING PROJECT. THE STATE
APPROVED IT AS A NEW
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT THAT'S NOW
UNDER A AN ALREADY EXECUTED
LEASING ARRANGEMENT, WHICH WOULD
MAKE CAUSING THAT PRO PROJECT
PROBLEMATIC. UM WE ALSO
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER JUST OVERSIGHT OF èC
S¼ U PROJECTS AND IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED, WE COULD TALK MORE
ABOUT THAT. LASTLY FOR BOTH U
èC  N èC S¼ U. WE RECOMMEND
THE STATE CONSIDER ALIGNING DEBT
SERVICE FUNDING WITH ACTUAL DEBT
SERVICE COSTS. SO THE THING THE
STATE TYPICALLY DOES IS WAIT
UNTIL PROJECTS ARE READY. UM AT
THE COMPLETE, UH, NEARING THE
COMPLETION STAGE TO SELL BONDS
AND START PAYING THE DEBT
SERVICE ON THOSE BONDS. IT DID
SOMETHING DIFFERENT LAST YEAR,
WHERE IT PROVIDED THE MONEY UP
FRONT. AND BEFORE EITHER SIGMUND
HAD ISSUED THE BONDS BEFORE
EITHER SIG HAD INCURRED. SERVICE
THIS IS A PRETTY INNOCUOUS
BUDGET SOLUTION. IT JUST ALIGNED
STATE FUNDING WITH ACTUAL DEBT
SERVICE COSTS IN 2324. WE THINK
THERE'S ABOUT 50 MILLION IN U
èC FUNDS THAT WERE NOT NEEDED
FOR INITIAL DEBT SERVICE COSTS
AND ABOUT 75 MILLION IN èC S¼ U
FUNDING THAT WASN'T NEEDED FOR
DEBT SERVICE COSTS. NOW THIS
THESE AMOUNTS WILL SHRINK OVER
TIME, AS ADDITIONAL BONDS ARE
SOLD AND DEBT SERVICES INCURRED,
SO IT'S JUST A SMALL SHORT TERM
SOLUTION TO GIVE THE STATE SOME
ADDITIONAL YEAR TERM BUDGET
SOLUTION AS THE UNIVERSITIES
ISSUE THEIR BONDS OVER THE NEXT
FEW YEARS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE'LL MOVE TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. CHAIR LAIRD. FOR THE
RECORD, I'M SAY OVER 10 FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAS
GREATLY EXPANDED THE STUDENT
HOUSING AVAILABILITY OVER THE
LAST EIGHT YEARS IN 2016, THE
UNIVERSITY BEGAN THE STUDENT
HOUSING INITIATIVE, WHICH AIMED
TO SUPPORT CURRENT AND FUTURE
STUDENTS BY EXPANDING CAMPUS
HOUSING OPTIONS EVEN FURTHER
THROUGH IDENTIFYING AVAILABLE
LAND WHERE HOUSING COULD BE
LOCATED AND EXPLORING A VARIETY
OF FINANCING OPTIONS. THESE
EFFORTS HAVE RESULTED IN THE
COMPLETION OF OVER 28,600 NEW
STUDENT HOUSING BEDS SINCE 2016
I WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR FOR THE
INVESTMENT IN THE HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM, WITH THE HELP OF THE
FUNDING RECEIVED, THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA WILL BE OPENING
4736 NEW BEDS THIS COMING FALL,
AND WE WILL COMPLETE ANOTHER
11,000 BEDS BY FALL OF 28. THESE
PROJECTS ARE CURRENTLY GOING
WELL, AND ONLY THE UC BERKELEY
PEOPLE'S PARK PROJECT HAS AN
UNKNOWN TIMELINE FOR OPENING FOR
THE STUDENTS. THE UNIVERSITY IS
SUPPOSED TO START ABOUT 1971,
RIGHT. KEEP GOING. SORRY HOPE
HOPEFULLY SOONER. UM, WE WILL.
WE WILL BE CONTINUING THAT
PROJECT. UM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IS COMMITTED TO THE
COMPACT, WHICH SEEKS TO INCREASE
STUDENT ACCESS, SUCCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY, AND WE SEE
HOUSING AVAILABILITY AS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF AN AFFORDABLE
EDUCATION. THE COMPACT WORKING
GROUP ON HOUSING HAS BEEN
MEETING TWICE A QUARTER TO
DISCUSS STUDENT NEEDS, AND THIS
WORKING GROUP CONSISTS OF BOTH
CAMPUS STAFF AND STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVES. UNIVERSITY
WORKED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATIONAL FACILITIES AUTHORITY
TO PROVIDE FEEDBACK ON THE
REVOLVING LOAN FUND FUND
PROGRAM. CRITERIA AND ON JANUARY
5TH OF 2024. WE SUBMITTED FORMAL
COMMENTS ON THE PROPOSED
REVOLVING LOAN FUND REGULATIONS.
AND WHILE THE APPLICATION
PROCESS FOR THE LOAN PROGRAM WAS
NOT OPENED, WE DO KNOW THAT AT
LEAST TWO U èC CAMPUSES WERE
READY GETTING READY TO SUBMIT
APPLICATIONS. IN ADDITION, WE
HAD OTHER CAMPUSES WITH PROJECTS
THAT, UH, INTENDED TO APPLY FOR
THE HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM THAT DID
NOT GET INTO THAT FIRST ROUND OF
FUNDING THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
APPLIED FOR THE REVOLVING LOAN
FUND. UM AND IF I COULD ADDRESS
ONE OF THE LAO'S COMMENTS ON
PULLING BACK OUR BOND FUNDS VERY
QUICKLY. I WAS GONNA ADDRESS
THAT AT THE END, BUT, UM, I
WANTED TO SAY REGARDING
WITHDRAWING, UM, THE BOND
PAYMENT FUNDS. UM THE UNIVERSITY
IS NOT ABLE TO, UH, ISSUE BONDS.
IF WE CANNOT PROVE THE ABILITY
TO REPAY THOSE BONDS, SO WE
WOULD REQUEST THE ABILITY TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE. IF
YOU'RE GOING TO GO THAT ROUTE,
IF WE COULD HAVE SOME LANGUAGE
THAT REVERTS ONE'S A LITTLE
LATER. WE DO INTEND TO SELL
BONDS THIS COMING YEAR AND WE
WOULD NEED THAT, UH, ABILITY TO
DEMONSTRATE REPAYMENT ABILITY,
BUT THERE WILL BE SOME, UH,
SAVINGS BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
SELLING THOSE BONDS FOR YOU
KNOW, 6 TO 8 MONTHS, UM AND WE
CAN DISCUSS A METHOD. THEN IF
YOU WANT. SOME OF THOSE FUNDS
RETURNED. GREAT. THANK YOU. AND
THEN èC S¼ U.
YOU HAD IT THERE A MOMENT CAUSE
I COULD HEAR YOUR THING. JUST
START TALKING. AND IF NOT YOU
PRESS IT AGAIN. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR. LAIRD UH, MY
NAME IS PAUL GANO. I'M ASSISTANT
VICE CHANCELLOR FOR CAPITAL
PLANNING AND DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY. I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY
. JUST I'LL GIVE YOU A REALLY
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF OUR HOUSING
PORTFOLIO. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT 61,000 BEDS ACROSS THE
SYSTEM, WHICH SUPPORTS ABOUT 14%
OF OUR STUDENT POPULATION. IN
ADDITION TO THE BEDS THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR PORTFOLIO NOW WE
HAVE ABOUT 10,000 THAT ARE
PLANNED JUST A LITTLE UNDER
10,000 THAT ARE PLANNED IN OUR
FIVE YEAR CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROGRAM. ON TOP OF THAT WE HAVE
ABOUT 5200 BEDS THAT ARE BEING,
UH EITHER IN DESIGN OR
CONSTRUCTION RIGHT NOW AS PART
OF THE HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM. AND UM,
ABOUT 1500 OF THOSE WILL COME
ONLINE IN FALL OF 24 IN IN TIME
FOR THE NEXT SEMESTER. UM ABOUT
3200 OF THOSE ARE WILL BE AT
AFFORDABLE RATES UNDER THE
PROGRAM. AND WE APPRECIATE THE
FUNDING THAT WE'VE GOTTEN FOR
THAT HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM AND WE
KNOW THAT THOSE BEDS WILL REALLY
IMPACT OUR STUDENTS. UM
POSITIVELY ALSO WOULD ECHO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
COMMENTS ON, UM PULLING BACK
FUNDING FOR OUR OUR BOND PROGRAM
. IF THAT DOES HAPPEN, THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE WERE ACTIVELY
WORKING ON THOSE THEY'RE IN. UM,
SCHEMATICS. WORKING DRAWINGS.
AND IF THAT PROGRAM GOES FORWARD
OF SORT OF PULLING BACK SOME OF
THOSE FUNDS. WE'D REALLY LIKE TO
WORK CLOSELY ON HOW THAT GETS
MANAGED. THANKS. I THINK THAT UM
THERE'S ALMOST NÓ PURPOSE IN
ASKING QUESTIONS BECAUSE
EVERYBODY WAS CRYSTAL CLEAR
ABOUT WHAT THE FACTS ARE AND
WHAT THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS ARE.
SO I'M GOING TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS AND LAST WEEK I THINK
IT WAS LAST WEEK WHEN WE HEARD
THE STATE LIBRARY. THERE WAS A
DIVIDING LINE ABOUT WHETHER
GRANTS HAD BEEN AWARDED AND
PEOPLE WERE ACTING ON THE BASIS
OF THE GRANT AWARD IN TERMS OF
CONSTRUCTION OR OTHER THINGS,
AND IT WAS OUR HOPE THAT THAT
DIVIDING LINE WOULD BE
RECOGNIZED IN THE BUDGET THAT
THAT IF I IF THERE ARE AWARDS
MADE, AND PEOPLE ARE MOVING ON
IT, AND I THINK THAT'S THE
DIFFICULTY WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST RECOMMENDATION ABOUT
PAUSING BECAUSE IT'S PAUSING
WHEN SOME PEOPLE ARE INTO THIS
IN DIFFERENT WAYS. THE SANTA
CRUZ ONE IS OBVIOUSLY VERY PAID
FOR AND WILL NOT. I WILL NOT
WANT IT PAUSED. BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT WHAT THE FACTS ARE, I.
THERE WAS A QUESTION ABOUT
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP AND
WE WHACK THAT BACK. THERE WAS A
QUESTION ABOUT BECAUSE IT WAS
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHETHER IT
VIOLATED THE UNIVERSITY
CONTRACTING OUT AND WE WHACK
THAT BACK, AND THERE WAS A THE
QUESTION IN THE BUDGET LAST YEAR
OF THE OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL ON FINANCING AND U èC
STEP FORWARD WITH THE BONDS TO
MOVE THAT PAST IT, AND NOW
THERE'S ONE REMAINING EIR. ISSUE
THAT THAT IS THERE, BUT IT'S
SORT OF AS EVERYBODY HAS WORKED
TIME TAKEN TIME TO WORK THROUGH
THEIR PROCESS. WE WOULD BE
REWARDING THOSE DELAYS BY, UH,
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE DOING THIS
èC IR. THEY'RE EXPENDING MONEY
AND MOVING AHEAD IN. MEANWHILE
THE SANTA CRUZ CAMPUS HAS SAID
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO ADMIT NÓ
STUDENTS UNLESS THEY HAVE
HOUSING AND THEY'RE CLOSING DOWN
THE PARKING AND THE TEMPORARY
CAMPING. THAT'S BEEN THERE FOR A
LONG TIME. AND IF THERE'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT COMES BEHIND IT,
THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
MEET THEIR OWN COMMITMENT ABOUT
NOT ADMITTING THE STUDENT UNTIL
THERE'S HOUSING THERE FOR IT, SO
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THESE HAVE
BEEN AWARDED, IN MY VIEW, THERE
ARE A SMALL NUMBER RELATIVELY
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR THEM
TO GO AHEAD AND EITHER WAY. I
THINK AS A COMMITTEE, I WOULD
HOPE WE WOULD WORK ON THE BOND
LANGUAGE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
OUR BEST TO MAXIMIZE THAT AND BE
FLEXIBLE AND HAVE THAT READY
FOR, HOWEVER, OF THE BUDGET
MOVES AHEAD AND THEN ON THE
REVOLVING LOAN FUND. THERE'S
SORT OF A EUPHEMISM BECAUSE IT'S
LIKE PUT A PAUSE ON THE
REVOLVING LOAN FUND. BUT IF I
REMEMBER THE NUMBER RIGHT
THERE'S 269 MILLION OF
UNEXPENDED. UH MONEY THAT WOULD
HAVE GONE FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
HOUSING THAT BY PAUSING, THE
BOND FUND IS PAUSING THAT
FUNDING AND I CAN SEE THAT ONE.
THERE'S NÓ COMMITMENT TO THE AS
MUCH AS I DON'T LIKE IT. THAT
MAKES MORE SENSE. UH UH UH,
MOVING AHEAD AND JUST TO REMIND
EVERYBODY WHILE WE'RE HAVING
THIS DISCUSSION ABOUT MONEY AND
GRANTS. IF WE HAVE A REVOLVING
LOAN FUND, THEN IT IS PAYING
BACK AND WE'RE CREATING A
PERMANENT SOURCE FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION HOUSING, SO IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO START THAT
WHENEVER WE CAN SO THAT WE ARE
CREATING THE PERMANENT FUNDING
SOURCE FOR HIGHER EDUCATION,
HOUSING, AND I RESPECT WHERE WE
ARE THIS YEAR, AND I'M THE ONE
THAT GAVE THE SPEECH THE FIRST
HEARING THAT EVERYBODY HAS TO BE
UNCOMFORTABLE ABOUT SOME OF THE
CUTS WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
BECAUSE OF THE HAIRCUTS. BUT
JUST, UH, IF WE DO PAUSE THAT I
WANT EVERYBODY TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT'S ALSO CAUSING 269
MILLION, OR WHATEVER THE NUMBER
IS FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE HOUSING
, AND IT'S MEETING. WE'LL JUST
TAKE AN EXTRA YEAR OR TWO YEARS
TO GET TO HAVING A REVOLVING
SOURCE FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
HOUSING BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
STARTED IT AND INVESTED IN IT.
AND SO, WITH THAT, UH, I WOULD
JUST MAKE THOSE COMMENTS THAT WE
WILL TAKE INTO ACCOUNT IS AS WE
HAVE FURTHER. COMMENTS ON THE
BUDGET AND I DON'T KNOW. NOBODY
LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE REACHING
TOWARD THEIR MIC. WELL ACTUALLY,
SOMEBODY DOES. UH MAYBE IT'S THE
PERSON WHOSE RECOMMENDATION I
TOOK ON RECOGNIZING THAT ALL THE
DECISIONS BEFORE YOU WHEN IT
COMES TO BALANCING A BUDGET ARE
GONNA BE DIFFICULT THIS YEAR.
POTENTIALLY UM I JUST DID WANNA
CLARIFY THAT WHETHER IT'S THE
STATE LIBRARY OR CROSSED HIGHER
EDUCATION. WE APPLIED THE SAME
STANDARDS, WHICH WAS TO LOOK AT
MONEY THAT HAD NOT YET BEEN
AWARDED. ENCUMBERED OR SPENT. WE
WORKED WITH THE DEPARTMENT SO
THAT WE WERE ALL SHARING AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THAT
MEANT. SO WHEN WE DO OFFER UP A
BUDGET SOLUTION FOR YOU, IT IS
MEETING THAT CRITERIA. NOW I
APPRECIATE IN THE CAPITAL
PROJECTS. IT'S A LITTLE BIT THAN
ALL THE PROGRAMMATIC INITIATIVES
. UM FOR MANY STATE AGENCIES,
THE STATE WILL FUND BY PHASE SO
IT WILL FUND THE PRELIMINARY
PLANS GET A BETTER SENSE OF COST
FUND DESIGN AND THEN FUN
CONSTRUCTION. AND IT HASN'T DONE
THAT WITH U èC AND èC S¼ U.
IT'S FUNDED ALL PHASES UPFRONT,
SO I COULD SEE HOW THERE MIGHT
BE AN INTERPRETATION ISSUE
THERE. BUT IF IT TURNS OUT TO
RESPOND TO THAT IF IT TURNS OUT
THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE DOING
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IN FINISHING
THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT,
WHICH NEEDS TO BE PAID FOR, AND
THE OTHER PLANNING, WHICH THEY
ARE DOING THAT THE BULK OF THE
EXPENDITURE IS IN THE OUT BUDGET
YEAR, THEN PHASING TO ME MAKES
SOME SENSE BECAUSE WE'RE SAYING
BUT IF YOU SEE HAS TO BOND ON
THE WHOLE THING, THEN WE HAVE TO
TALK TO THEM ABOUT HOW THAT
WORKS AND WHETHER IT'S DONE IN
THE RIGHT WAY. AND THE MINUTE
YOU BOND, YOU INCUR EXPENDITURES
, AND SO I WOULD. THE GOAL IS TO
KEEP IT MOVING FORWARD, AND IF
IT TURNS OUT THAT BECAUSE IT
CROSSES BUDGET YEARS, AND MAYBE
SOME EXPENDITURES ARE IN THE OUT
BUDGET HERE THAT ALLOWS FOR SOME
KIND OF SOLUTION, I'M SURE WE'RE
OPEN TO THAT. GREAT. WELL, THEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY, UH, OF
BEING HERE FOR THIS, AND, UM
WE'LL MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE, WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. UH
ENROLLMENT, AND WE HAVE DEVIN
MITCHELL FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. LISA KING FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
NATHAN EVANS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE. UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. AND
WHEN WILL, UH WHEN EVERYBODY'S
SEATED IN RED INK. WE WILL GO IN
THAT ORDER OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM SO
WELCOME, ACTUALLY, IN YOUR CASE,
BECAUSE YOU WERE HERE FOR THE
LIBRARY OR SOMETHING LAST WEEK,
WELCOME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THERE IT WAS ON YOU JUST TALK
AND SOMEHOW WE'LL GET THERE.
SORRY ABOUT THAT, UM HE DOES HE
NEED TO PRESS IT AGAIN. OK,
THANKS. GOOD MORNING, SENATOR UM
SENATOR LAIRD, DEVIN MITCHELL
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
UM THE ADMINISTRATION EXPECTS
THE èC S¼ U TO CONTINUE MAKING
PROGRESS TOWARDS THE SYSTEM'S
GOAL OF 1% ANNUAL ENROLLMENT
GROWTH DURING EACH YEAR OF THE
MULTI YEAR COMPACT AGREEMENT.
THE COMBAT ALSO SPECIFIES THIS
ENROLLMENT INCREASE MUST
MAINTAIN AT A MINIMUM A SHARE OF
NEW UNDERGRADUATE TRANSFER
STUDENT ENROLLMENTS THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH EXISTING
ADMISSIONS PRACTICES FOR NEW
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENTS.
ENROLLMENT GROWTH, AMONG OTHER
SHARED PRIORITIES IS SUPPORTED
BY ANNUAL UH 5% GENERAL FUND
BASE INCREASES WITH THE CAVEAT
THAT AS YOU HEARD, UM, DUE TO
THE BUDGET SHORTFALL THIS YEAR,
THE 2024 25 BASE INCREASE HAS
BEEN DEFERRED TO 2025 26. UM
WITH THAT, I'LL YIELD TO THE
OTHER PANELISTS AND CAN ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE. GOOD AFTERNOON
TRAILER. IT'S LISA KING WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. IF
YOU TURN TO PAGE 16 OF YOUR
AGENDA, YOU'LL SEE A CHART THAT
SUMMARIZES SOME KEY FIGURES
RELATING TO èC S¼ U ENROLLMENT.
AND THE TOP SECTION OF THIS
CHART. IT SHOWS èC S¼ U S¼
ENROLLMENT TARGET OVER TIME.
THIS IS A NUMBER THAT èC S¼ U
HAS TRACKED FOR MANY YEARS, AND
IT REFLECTS THE STUDENTS FOR
WHICH IT'S RECEIVED STATE
FUNDING TO ADD. THE CURRENT
YEAR. 2020 THREE 24 THE TARGET
IS ABOUT 387,000 RESIDENT
STUDENTS. BELOW THAT THE NEXT
SECTION OF THE CHART SHOWS èC
S¼ U S¼ ESTIMATES OF ACTUAL
ENROLLMENTS FOR THE SAME PERIOD.
IN 2020 THREE 24 èC S¼ U WAS
ESTIMATING AS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THAT IT WAS ENROLLING
ABOUT 368,000 STUDENTS RESIDENT
STUDENTS THIS YEAR. THAT'S BELOW
THE TARGET LEVEL BY ABOUT 19,000
STUDENTS OR 4.9. NOW LOOKING AT
THE SAME CHART. YOU CAN ALSO SEE
THAT ESTIMATED ENROLLMENT THIS
YEAR IS UP FROM LAST YEAR BY
SEVERAL 1000. AS YOU ALSO HEARD
THIS MORNING. MUCH OF THAT
GROWTH, HOWEVER, IS ATTRIBUTABLE
TO A CERTAIN CHANGE IN HOW
SUMMER ENROLLMENTS ARE COUNTED.
HISTORICALLY MANY CSU CAMPUSES
HAVE OFFERED SUMMER COURSES ON A
SELF SUPPORTED BASIS. MEANING
THAT THE INSTRUCTIONAL COSTS ARE
ENTIRELY COVERED BY COURSE FEES.
DON'T RECEIVE STATE GENERAL FUND
AND THE STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
THESE COURSES DON'T COUNT
TOWARDS STATE ENROLLMENT
TARGETS. LAST SUMMER, SOME
CAMPUSES SHIFTED CERTAIN SELF
SUPPORTED COURSES TO THE STATE
SUPPORTED SIDE. MEANING THAT THE
STUDENTS INVOLVED IN THEM NEARLY
COUNT TOWARD THE STATE
ENROLLMENT TARGET. WE THINK THIS
APPROACH TO INCREASING ENROLMENT
IS LIKELY NOT IN LINE WITH
LEGISLATIVE INTENT. BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T ADD NEW STUDENTS. IT
REALLY IS MORE FOCUSED ON
RECLASSIFYING THE CORPSES
THEY'RE ENROLLED IN. AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS NOTED
THE GOVERNOR'S COMPACT SETS
FORTH IN EXPECTATION OF
INCREASING èC S¼ U S¼ TARGET BY
1% IN 2024 25. GIVEN THAT èC S¼
U IS ABOUT 19,000 STUDENTS BELOW
ITS CURRENT TARGET. WE DON'T
THINK THIS IS WARRANTED. WE
RECOMMEND INSTEAD HOLDING èC S¼
C'S TARGET FLAT FOR 2024 25. IN
THE COMING MONTHS IF THE STATE
BUDGET CONDITION CONTINUES TO
DETERIORATE, AND THE STATE IS IN
NEED OF ADDITIONAL BUDGET
SOLUTION. ONE OPTION LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER IS LOWERING èC
S¼ U S¼ TARGET AND REMOVING THE
ASSOCIATED FUNDING. BETTER ALIGN
WITH ITS ACTUAL ENROLLMENT
LEVEL. THANK YOU. I'D BE HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND THEN WE'LL MOVE
TO THE èC S¼ U SYSTEM. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS NATHAN
EVANS AND I SERVE AS DEPUTY VICE
CHANCELLOR AND CHIEF ACADEMIC
AFFAIRS OFFICER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CHAIR. LAIRD, THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY. UM, AS YOU HEARD IN
CHANCELLOR GARCIA'S COMMENTS,
THE CSU IS INCREMENTALLY,
CLOSING THE GAP TOWARDS THE
STATE'S LONG RANGE ENROLLMENT
TARGET. CONTRARY TO RECENT
REPORTS, WHICH FOCUSED ON èC S¼
U ENROLLMENT OUTCOMES DURING THE
LATE PANDEMIC PERIOD, ENROLLMENT
OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS IN THE
CURRENT COLLEGE YEAR 20 THREE 24
INCREASED BY MORE THAN 7500 FTES
OVER LAST YEAR. THIS WAS
ACHIEVED THROUGH FOCUSED WORK TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN AND
SUPPORTING CONTINUING STUDENTS.
UH, STUDENTS RETURNING TO HIGHER
UNIT LOADS, RETAINING AND
ENGAGING STUDENTS DURING SUMMER
SESSIONS AND RECONNECTING WITH
STUDENTS WHO STOPPED OUT DURING
THE PANDEMIC. AND IS ALSO NOTED
BY THE CHANCELLOR THAT THE èC
S¼ U ENROLLED THE LARGEST
FRESHMAN CLASS OF CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS IN OUR HISTORY MORE
THAN 64,000 STUDENTS LAST FALL.
THAT NEW CLASS MIRRORS THE
DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WITH
MORE THAN 56% OF THOSE STUDENTS
IDENTIFYING AS LATINO AND HALF
OF THOSE STUDENTS WILL ALSO BE
THE FIRST IN THEIR FAMILY TO
EARN A COLLEGE DEGREE. I WOULD
ALSO SHARE THAT AFTER ENROLLING
MORE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS THAN
FUNDED BY THE STATE FOR 12 YEARS
TO 2022, THE èC S¼ U HAS SEEN
JUST TWO YEARS BELOW THE
OVERARCHING TARGET. THE IMPACTS
OF THE PANDEMIC DISRUPTED THAT
OVERALL ENROLLMENT TRAJECTORY.
BUT THE èC S¼ U SYSTEM AND
CAMPUSES HAVE RESPONDED
INTENTIONALLY FOR BOTH THE SHORT
TERM AND LONG TERM. AND FUTURE
TRENDS ARE ALSO MAINTAINING THAT
MOMENTUM. UNDERGRADUATE
APPLICATIONS FOR FALL 2024 THIS
FALL HAVE INCREASED BY OVER THE
PRIOR YEAR. FIRST TIME FRESHMAN
APPLICATIONS ARE UP BY MORE THAN
5% AND TRANSFER APPLICATIONS ARE
UP 1% DESPITE CONTINUED
ENROLLMENT DECLINES IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. WE'RE ALSO INTERNALLY
TAKING STEPS TO MATCH RESOURCES
WITH ENROLLMENT DEMAND. IN
CONSULTATION WITH OUR UNIVERSITY
PRESIDENTS. WE RECENTLY LAID OUT
THE GROUNDWORK FOR A MULTIYEAR
ENROLLMENT AND BUDGET
REALLOCATION PLAN THAT WILL
BETTER ALIGN RESOURCES WITH
STUDENT DEMAND BY CAMPUS. WE'VE
BEGUN THAT WORK BY MOVING, UH,
REDUCING ENROLLMENT AT EIGHT
CAMPUSES BY 3% THEIR ENROLLMENT,
TARGET AND ASSOCIATED RESOURCES
AND IS REDISTRIBUTING THAT TO
NINE CAMPUSES WITH SUSTAINED
DEMAND ACROSS THE SYSTEM. WE'VE
ALSO AUGMENTED STATEWIDE
RECRUITMENT THROUGH TARGETED
ENROLLMENT, MARKETING AND
ADVERTISING AND PARTNERSHIPS
WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS LIKE L, A
UNIFIED FINALLY LOOKING TO THE
FUTURE OF THIS SEA ISSUE IS ALSO
WORKING ON REDESIGNING OUR
ONLINE APPLICATION TO ALLOW
CAMPUSES USING THE STATE'S
CRADLE TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM AND
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO DIRECTLY ADMIT ALL
èC S¼ U ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS IN
A SCHOOL OR DISTRICT WITHOUT
STUDENTS, EVEN HAVING TO, UH
INITIATE AN APPLICATION. THE
STRATEGY IS PARTICULARLY OF
INTEREST TO CAMPUSES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA, WHICH HAVE SEEN
MULTI YEAR DECLINES TO
POPULATION CHANGES IN THE
REGION. OUR SYSTEM IN
UNIVERSITIES WILL CONTINUE TO
PLAY A STRONG PLACE. A STRONG
FOCUS ON STRATEGIC ENROLLMENT
PLANNING. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK, AND I
WOULD WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. UM, LET ME
START WITH WHAT THE ISSUE THAT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST RAISED
BECAUSE IT SEEMED THAT COUNTING
500 OR 5000 SUMMER SCHOOL
STUDENTS THAT AREN'T FULL TIME
YEAR ROUND AND IT IS MORE AN
ACCOUNTING MECHANISM THAN IT IS
A GENUINE INCREASE IN ENROLLMENT
. COULD YOU SPEAK TO THAT
CONCERN? ABSOLUTELY I DO
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION. SO
HISTORICALLY, CAMPUSES HAVE MADE
SUMMER ENROLLMENT AVAILABLE TO
BROADLY TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
THEY ARE FULLY SELF SUPPORT
COURSES THAT ARE BEING OFFERED
THAT THAT MEANS THEY'RE ONLY
COVERED BY THE FEES COLLECTED
FOR THOSE COURSES. UM BEFORE,
EVEN THE CURRENT YEAR THREE OF
OUR CAMPUSES SAN FRANCISCO, SAN
DIEGO AND SAN LUIS OBISPO. AS
PART OF THEIR SORT OF
OVERARCHING STUDENT SUCCESS
EFFORT HAD REALLY BEGUN TO BE
MORE STRATEGICALLY USE SUMMER AS
A RETENTION MECHANISM AND
RUNNING SUMMER THROUGH STATE
SUPPORT, SO STUDENTS PAID AND
COULD EXPECT THE SAME, UH,
INSTRUCTION AND FEE STRUCTURE
DURING SUMMER, UM, THAT THEY
WOULD IN THE REST OF THE YEAR SO
THAT WE CAN HOLD ON TO THOSE èC
S¼ U STUDENTS AND GET THEM
2 DEGREES MORE QUICKLY AND
SUPPORT THEM. THE OTHER
DIFFERENCE THAT THOSE CAMPUSES
RECOGNIZE THAT NOW OTHER
CAMPUSES HAVE IS ACCESS TO
FINANCIAL AID. WHEN COURSES TO
SELF SUPPORT. THE ONLY STUDENTS
THAT CAN REALLY AVAIL THEMSELVES
TO THOSE COURSES. OUR STUDENTS
THAT CAN PAY THAT FULL COST OUT
OF POCKET, WHEREAS WHEN THEY ARE
STATE SUPPORTED, THEN STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO INSTITUTIONAL AID
, AND IN MANY CASES, FEDERAL AID
TO PELL GRANTS IF THEY HAVE THAT
ELIGIBILITY REMAINING, SO WE
WENT FROM THREE CAMPUSES THAT
HAD USED THAT STRATEGY. WE HAD
10 MORE CAMPUSES REALLY EXAMINE
AND LOOK TO ADD TO ADD THAT AS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEIR
STUDENTS TO CONTINUE AND THE
REMAINING 10 CAMPUSES AT THIS
POINT, HAVEN'T DECIDED IF
THEY'LL GO MOVE THAT DIRECTION,
BUT THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE THINKING
ABOUT. SO THE STUDENT PROFILE OF
WHO ENROLLS IN SUMMER IS QUITE
DIFFERENT WHEN COURSES AND
OFFERINGS ARE UNDERTAKEN THROUGH
SELF SUPPORT VERSUS STATE
SUPPORT, YOU MENTIONED THAT IT'S
FOR RETENTION. DO YOU HAVE
STATISTICS ON IF THERE'S 5000
THAT WERE ENROLLED IN THE SUMMER
. HOW MANY ACTUALLY ARE RETAINED
HOW MANY CONTINUE TO THE FALL OR
THE REST OF THE ACADEMIC YEAR? I
DON'T HAVE IT AT HAND. BUT WE'D
BE HAPPY TO GET THAT FOR YOU
BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME THAT'S IN
PART THE PROOF OF THE PUDDING IF
IT IS 5000 SUMMER SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN 10 OF THEM STAY,
THEN IT IS AN ACCOUNTING
MECHANISM. I IF IT IS 5000
STUDENTS AND 4000 GO ON TO THE
REST OF THE YEAR. THEN YOUR
RETENTION AND RECRUITMENT ISSUE
IS TRULY BEING ADDRESSED. AND IT
MAKES MORE SENSE. WE'D BE HAPPY
TO SEE YOU. I KNOW I'M NOT
SUPPOSED TO RESPOND TO QUIZZICAL
EXPRESSIONS, BUT I SEE ONE ON
THE FACE OF SOMEBODY FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST, AND I
WONDER IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON
THIS. AND I KNOW YOU'RE GONNA
TRY TO BE MORE OPAQUE GOING
FORWARD, BUT, UH UH, I, I WOULD
WELCOME YOUR COMMENT. ALL. I
WOULD NOTICE THAT IN LOOKING AT
THE DATA ON SUMMER ENROLLMENT,
WHILE WE DID SEE AN INCREASE ON
THE STATE SUPPORT SIDE OF 5400
STUDENTS. WE DID ALSO SEE A
DECREASE ON THE SELF SUPPORT
SIDE OF ABOUT 4700 STUDENTS. SO
THAT SUGGESTS TO US THAT MUCH OF
THE INCREASE WE SAW IN THE STATE
SUPPORT. SUMMER ENROLLMENT WAS
OFFSET BY THIS DECREASE IN
SELF-SUPPORT AND THE NET
INCREASE IN STUDENTS. LOOKING
ACROSS THOSE TWO MODELS WAS
RELATIVELY SMALL. SO THAT
SUGGESTED TO US THAT IT HAD MORE
TO DO WITH CONVERTING THE
COURSES FROM ONE SIDE TO THE
OTHER. THEN INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS THAT WERE
ENROLLED IN THE SUMMER. OK, I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO WANT TO
HAVE FURTHER CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THAT, AS WE MOVE THROUGH THE
SPRING TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
LIKE A VALID THING FOR THE
PURPOSES OF COUNTING IT. THEN,
UH, I DIDN'T WANNA BE LABOR AND
ALREADY LONG OPENING PANEL. BUT
THE, UH THE ISSUE OF DIVERSITY
IN ENROLLMENT IS A BIG ONE. AND
THE èC S¼ U AND I KNOW THAT
THAT IN ONE OF MY HOME CAMPUSES
OF CAL POLY I CAN'T REMEMBER THE
NUMBER BUT THE NUMBER OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN FIRST YEAR STUDENTS WAS
MINUSCULE AND IT WAS POINTED
OUT. UH ALL OVER THE PLACE. AND
I DID HAVE COFFEE WITH THE
PRESIDENT WHO HE TOLD ME ALL HIS
PLANS TO MAKE SURE THAT DOESN'T
CONTINUE. BUT COULD YOU SPEAK TO
THAT SYSTEM WIDE? WHAT ARE YOU
DOING TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THERE'S DIVERSITY AND, UH, IN
COMING STUDENT BODY? ABSOLUTELY
UH, REALLY APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION, AND IT'S A COMMITMENT
YOU HEARD FROM OUR CHANCELLOR IN
TERMS OF THE ROLE THAT THE èC
S¼ U PLAYS, UH, IN SUPPORTING AS
SHE DESCRIBES, UH, AMERICA'S AND
CALIFORNIA'S NEW MAJORITY. UH SO
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF THINGS
THAT YOU DESCRIBED WORK AT A
PARTICULAR CAMPUS. UM, THERE ARE
MANY SIMILAR EFFORTS GOING ON
LOCALLY, WHAT I WOULD OFFER AT A
STATEWIDE LEVEL YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD IN OTHER DISCUSSIONS WITH
èC S¼ U COLLEAGUES OUR RECENT
WORK AROUND BLACK STUDENT
SUCCESS, UH, AND A TASK FORCE
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED. LAST YEAR
TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
SPAN THE CONTINUUM OF BOTH FROM
EARLY ENGAGEMENT OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS AND
COMMUNITIES AND SCHOOLS ALL THE
WAY THROUGH ALUMNI AND SO AS ONE
ASPECT OF THAT, UH, THERE HAVE
BEEN THERE'S TARGETED WORK, AND,
UH, IN OUTREACH AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT. UM WE HAVE
HISTORICALLY, FOR EXAMPLE, OUR
SUPER SUNDAY EVENTS THAT JUST
TOOK PLACE IN SEPTEMBER, WHICH
ARE JUST ONE OF A SORT OF ANNUAL
EFFORT YEAR ROUND WORKING WITH
IN THIS CASE, RELIGIOUS
COMMUNITIES, BLACK CHURCHES.
FIRST AND FOREMOST BEING IN
COMMUNICATING ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE èC S¼ U
AND THEN FOLLOWING THROUGH WITH
ON CAMPUS VISIT OPPORTUNITIES
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD FROM YOUR
ENGAGEMENT WITH, UH, PRESIDENT
ARMSTRONG FROM SAN LUIS OBISPO
ABOUT DIRECT SCHOOL PARTNERSHIPS
WHERE THEY'RE WORKING WITH, UH,
DIVERSE, UH, HIGH SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO REALLY
ATTRACT STUDENTS THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN THEIR
CASE IN POLYTECHNIC AND STEM
MAJORS, AND, UH, BEING IN
INTRUSIVE IN THOSE SCHOOLS AND
THEN INVITING THOSE SCHOOL
COMMUNITIES ONTO THEIR CAMPUSES,
SO THOSE ARE REPLICATED. IN A
VARIETY OF WAYS AT THE TRANSFER
LEVEL. UH, THE èC S¼ U LAUNCHED
LAST YEAR. OUR NEW DUAL
ADMISSION PROGRAM, WHICH HAD
BEEN SUPPORTED THROUGH
LEGISLATION WE WENT ABOVE AND
BEYOND. WITH THAT LEGISLATION
CALLED FOR TO ALLOW STUDENTS
WHILE THEY'RE STILL IN HIGH
SCHOOL TO GET A GUARANTEED DUAL
OFFER OF ADMISSION FROM BOTH A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SIMULTANEOUSLY
WITH A SPECIFIC èC S¼ U CAMPUS,
NOT JUST THE èC S¼ U WRIT LARGE
BUT A PARTICULAR CAMPUS AND
MAKING THAT COMMITMENT TO ENGAGE
WITH THEM WHILE THEY'RE AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENT THAT ARE AT SCHOOLS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA HAVE THAT
ACCESS AND I APPRECIATE THAT,
AND I APPRECIATE I MEAN, ONE OF
THE OTHER JUST ANECDOTAL THINGS
IS I ALSO HAVE CAL STATE
MONTEREY BAY. UH UH, IN THE
DISTRICT AT THE NEW PRESIDENT
HAS MADE THE STATEMENT THAT
THERE ARE MAJORITY OF LATINO
STUDENTS AND THAT IT IS NOT
BEING CONSIDERED UNLESS YOU
AFFIRMATIVELY TALK ABOUT IT A AS
A CAMPUS THAT IS MORE LATINO
BASED AND MORE DRESSING,
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS OR OR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THAT THAT WHERE THERE HAS BEEN
SOME SUCCESS ENROLLMENT, IT'S
NOT BEING CALLED OUT IN THE IN
THE WAY THAT MIGHT DO IT AND IS
LOOKING FOR SORT OF THAT
RECOGNITION AND ASSISTANCE OVER
TIME. THE LAST QUESTION. I HAVE
OFF THE TOP AND IT'S I DIDN'T
WANNA DRAG OUT THAT FIRST
HEARING IS THE ENROLLMENT SEEMS
TO BE CLEARLY TIED. ENROLLMENT
WAS A THING IN THE COMPACTS AND
CLEARLY TIED TO THE COMPACTS.
WHAT HAPPENS IF WW WITH JUST THE
FACT THAT IT'S DEFERRED THIS
YEAR, BUT IF IT'S NOT THE FULL
PERCENT NEXT 10% NEXT YEAR WHAT
HAPPENS TO ENROLLMENT? UH UH.
HOW DOES THAT COME OUT THE OTHER
END AND IN WHAT YOU WOULD SEE
FOR èC S¼ U ENROLLMENT. UH,
WELL, UH, AS BEEN ACKNOWLEDGED,
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
COMPLEXITY OF AND OF THE
CHALLENGES AND BALANCING A
BUDGET. IN THIS PARTICULAR
SITUATION, I WILL SHARE THAT THE
COMPACT FRAMEWORK HAS ALLOWED
OUR CAMPUSES TO REALLY PLAN ON A
MULTIYEAR HORIZON. I DESCRIBE
THE INTERNAL èC S¼ U ENROLLMENT
AND BUDGET REALLOCATION PROCESS
AND THAT WAS STAGED ALONG THE
SAME TIMELINE AS THE COMPACT SO
THAT IT ALLOWED FOR THOSE
CAMPUSES THAT HAVE SEEN
SUSTAINED ENROLLMENT DECLINES.
THAT COULD BE A AND GRADUAL
REDUCTION IN THEIR ENROLLMENT,
TARGET AND CORRESPONDING
RESOURCE WHILE AGAIN
TRANSFERRING THAT TO AREAS OF
THE STATE WHERE WE KNOW THERE IS
CONTINUED VERY STRONG DEMAND. IT
WOULD TRULY INTERRUPT THAT
ABILITY TO, UM TO SORT OF
MITIGATE THAT OVER TIME AS ONE
ARTIFACT, THE OTHER PIECE, I
WOULD SAY IN TERMS OF DIRECT
STUDENT IMPACT, UH, HERE IN
MARCH, MOST ADMISSIONS DECISIONS
FOR FALL 24 IN THIS CASE ARE
ALREADY OUT THE DOOR. MANY, IF
NOT MOST. SO THE TIMING AND SORT
OF CHOICES THEY IN CAMPUSES HAVE
, UH, IT REALLY JUST, UH RELATE
TO COURSE INSTRUCTION AND COURSE
AVAILABILITY. UH, AND SO IN
TERMS OF SORT OF LEVELING THAT
OUT OVER THE BALANCE OF THE
COLLEGE YEAR, SO MAKING A
DECISION IN THE YOU KNOW, BY MAY
, UH, AS I SAID, SORT OF ONE OF
THE REMAINING LEVERS IS IN
COURSE AVAILABILITY THROUGHOUT
THE REST OF THE YEAR AND HAVING
TO SORT OF TAMPER THAT DOWN. UM
BUT WE, YOU KNOW, CERTAINLY, AS
I SAID THE BENEFIT OF THE
COMPACT WAS A MULTIYEAR HORIZON
FOR THAT PLANNING. WE ARE SORT
OF RECONCILING WHAT'S HAPPENED
WITH DEMOGRAPHICS AND POPULATION
IN SOME AREAS OF THE STATE YOU
HEARD FROM THE CHANCELLOR. A
MAJORITY OF OUR STUDENTS COME
FROM THE IMMEDIATE AREA AROUND
THEIR CAMPUSES. AS YOU KNOW OF
THE TWO IN YOUR, UH, DISTRICT.
UM AND THEY TEND TO STAY AND
THAT MEANS THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO
TRY TO BALANCE THAT OVER TIME
AND NOT MAKE THOSE ABRUPT
CHANGES TO RECOGNIZE HOW SOME OF
THAT'S CHANGED, SO IT WOULD
DEFINITELY DISRUPT THAT, AND
THEN THE STUDENT LEVEL WOULD
IMPACT MOST LIKELY COURSE
AVAILABILITY. OK UH UH.
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH. AND
I, AS I SAID YESTERDAY, DURING
LOBBY DAY, I ACTUALLY SAID I
HAVE 2.5 BECAUSE SO MANY FACULTY
AND STUDENTS COMMUTE TO SAN JOSE
STATE, WHICH IS JUST OUTSIDE THE
DISTRICT, BUT, UH, I APPRECIATE
THIS, AND I THINK THAT WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IN THE DIFFERENT
ITEMS IS THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
COMPACTS AND THE DEFERRALS AND
HOW IT'S REFLECTING TO SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE OUR GOALS,
WHETHER IT'S ENROLLMENT OR
HOUSING. OR OR OTHER PROJECTS
AND THE FACT THAT THAT, OF
COURSE WE ELECTED OFFICIALS. WE
WANT THE BEST OF ALL WORLDS. YOU
KNOW, WHICH IS MAYBE SHORTING
YOU A LITTLE ON MONEY AND STILL
HAVING YOU PRODUCE, BUT I THINK
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO HAVE THAT NOT BE THE
CHOICE AND TRY TO CONTINUE. ON
ALL THESE GOALS, SO MY YES.
SORRY SENATOR TO PROLONG YOUR
HEARING. UH, CAN I GO BACK REAL
BRIEFLY TO THE SUMMER DISCUSSION
A LITTLE BIT. WE UNDERSTAND THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT THE L A Ó
HAS PROVIDED IS YOU KNOW A
CURRENT HOT BUTTON ISSUE RIGHT
NOW. BUT IF WE COULD STEP BACK
JUST ABOUT 1015 YEARS ON SUMMER,
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAD TO
DO IN THE GREAT RECESSION WAS TO
SIGNIFICANTLY CURTAIL THAT
WONDERFUL THING KNOWN AS SUMMER
TERM, WHICH ALLOWS STUDENTS TO
PERSIST AND COMPLETE THEIR
DEGREES. YOU KNOW, DURING THE
SUMMER TERM OR GET AHEAD OF THE
OF THEIR COMPLETION, YOU KNOW,
WHILE THEY'RE MID MIDSTREAM
CAREER OVER THE LAST 10 YEARS.
THERE'S BEEN MORE AND MORE, UM,
INTEREST BY THE LEGISLATURE. TO
DO MORE AND MORE SUMMER TO GET
BACK TO UTILIZING MORE STATE
SUPPORT. SUMMER AND MOST
RECENTLY, THERE HAS BEEN A GRANT
PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN ADOPTED BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
PROVIDE $6 MILLION EVERY SUMMER
FOR FINANCIAL AID FOR STATE
SUPPORT, YOU KNOW, OR FOR SUMMER
TERM. UH UH. UTILIZATION. WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF CAMPUSES THAT
WANT TO USE MORE. SOME ARE GOING
FORWARD AND WE'LL BE DOING THAT
IN THE FUTURE. I JUST WANTED TO
PUT THAT ON THE RADAR AS SUMMER
IS A VERY VALID THING FOR OUR
STUDENTS AND A GOAL OF OURS FOR
MANY OF OUR CAMPUSES TO UTILIZE
GOING FORWARD, SO IT'S NOT IT
WOULDN'T BE THE END OF THE STORY
ON SUMMER. WE REALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE UTILIZING.
WELL LET ME COMMENT ON THAT
BECAUSE THERE'S A BUNCH OF
DISCONNECTED THINGS THAT THAT
FIT TO THAT AND ONE IS THAT I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN PRESSURE
BECAUSE OF FACILITIES ISSUES
THAT RATHER THAN EXPANDING
FACILITIES. YOU EXPAND. THE TIME
COURSES IS OFF ARE OFFERED AND
IT DOESN'T REQUIRE THE SAME. UH
UH, ADDITION OF FACILITIES. I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND YOU KNOW
THE WHOLE NOTION? Ó. OUR FIRST
PANEL WAS SO PROLONGED THAT I
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT SCHOOL
BONDS AND MAKING SURE HIGHER
EDUCATION IS IN THEM, EVEN
THOUGH WITH THE BOND CAPACITY.
WE'RE NOT SURE WHAT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO DO ON EVERYTHING. UH UH.
BUT IT IT'S STILL RAISES. THE
ISSUE THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER IS KNOWING THAT WHO'S IN
THE SUMMER ARE REALLY YEAR ROUND
STUDENTS OR ENTICED IN A WAY
THAT IT'S NOT AN ACCOUNTING
MECHANISM THAT IT IS TRULY TIED
TO ONGOING STUDENTS THAT ARE
DOING THAT AND MAKING A
DIFFERENCE. AND SO WHILE I
APPRECIATE YOUR POINT, THAT WILL
STILL BE THE QUESTION AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. TO DO
ANYBODY ELSE. UH, HAVE ANY
COMMENTS. THEN. THANK YOU. I
REALLY UH UH APPRECIATE THIS.
DISCUSSION. AND WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ENROLLMENT. AND WE
HAVE GABRIEL CHÁVEZ FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IAN KLEIN
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND SAY VERTIN AND AGAIN
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE VERY LUCKY
THAT THAT HAPPENS TO BE THE
FIFTH PANEL AS WELL, SO JUST GET
COMFORTABLE IN YOUR SEATS, AND
WE'LL GO IN THAT ORDER. SO LET'S
START WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, GO TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST AND GO TO THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA. W. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
LEAR, GABRIELA CHÁVEZ WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF YOU PREPARED YOUR
STATEMENT THINKING YOU'D BE
SPEAKING IN THE MORNING. BUT IT
IS, YEAH. IT WAS A 930 GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR LAIRD GABRI
CHÁVEZ WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
REFLECTS THE THIRD YEAR OF THE
MULTIYEAR COMPACT WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. AND
DESPITE THE STATE CURRENT FISCAL
CONDITION, THE ADMINISTRATION
REMAINS COMMITTED TO THE SHARED
GOALS OF INCREASING ACCESS TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
IMPROVING THE STUDENT SUCCESS.
TO ADDRESS THE PROJECTED BUDGET
SHORTFALL. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES A ONE TIME DEFERRAL FOR
THE PLAN OF 227.8 MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL AN INCREASE IN
2024 25 AS PART OF THE MULTIYEAR
COMPACT INVESTMENT. AND THE PLAN
INVESTMENT OF 31 MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND. IN 2024 25. TO
HAVE SET THE REVENUE REDUCTIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE REPLACEMENT
OF 902 NON-RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS. ONGOING
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT FOR THE U
èC WOULD REMAIN AT
APPROXIMATELY THE 2023 24
BASELINE LEVELS. WILL AND ELY,
THE U èC TO USE INTERIM FINANCE
STRUCTURES, OTHER INTERNAL
BORROWING OR CASH RESERVES TO
SUPPORT PLAN OPERATING
EXPENDITURES IN 2024 25. THIS
APPROACH WILL ENABLE THE TO
CONTINUE ITS EFFORTS TO MEET THE
COMPACT GOALS TO EXPAND STUDENT
ACCESS, EQUITY AND AFFORDABILITY
AND TO CREATE PATHWAYS TO HIGH
THE MAIN CAREER OPPORTUNITIES.
THE ADMINISTRATION WILL CONTINUE
TO MONITOR THE USES ACTIONS
TORMENTING THE CAMPOS HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'LL
MOVE TO THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CHAIR
LAIRD, IAN KLEIN WITH THE L A
Ó. WE WOULD LIKE TO DISCUSS
THREE ISSUES WITH YOU WITH
RESPECT TO U èC S¼ ENROLLMENT.
FIRST THE 2220 THREE BUDGET ACT,
SET AN UNDERGRADUATE RESIDENT
ENROLLMENT TARGET FOR OF 203,661
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENTS BY
2324. YOU SEE, CURRENTLY
ESTIMATES THAT THEY WILL FALL
SHORT OF MEETING THIS GOAL.
WHILE THE ENROLLMENT NUMBERS
WON'T BE FINALIZED UNTIL LATER
THIS YEAR. YOU RECOMMEND
SCOOPING ANY UNEARNED FUNDS AS
PART OF THE 2526 BUDGET CYCLE
ONCE THOSE NUMBERS ARE
FINALIZED. SECOND WE RECOMMEND
HOLDING THE ENROLLMENT TARGET
FLAT AT THE 2223 BUDGET ACT
LEVEL FOR 2024, 25 AND 2526.
WELL, THE ADMINISTRATION AND AS
YOU'VE HEARD EARLIER TODAY,
EXPECT ENROLLMENT GROWTH FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR DESPITE NOTEBOOK
BASED AUGMENTATION BEING
PROVIDED AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. IT'S EXPECTED
THAT WILL COVER THE COST OF
ENROLLING THESE ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS FOR THAT YEAR. WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS STRONG
DEMAND TO ATTEND IN GENERAL AND
AT SEVERAL CAMPUSES IN
PARTICULAR. HOWEVER THERE ARE A
FEW FACTORS THAT HAVE IMPACTED
MEETING THEIR ENROLLMENT
TARGETS. SEVERAL CAMPUSES NEEDED
TO GO FURTHER INTO THEIR WAIT
LIST LATER IN THE APPLICATION
CYCLE, WHICH RESULTED IN SOME
CAMPUSES, MISSING THEIR
ENROLLMENT TARGETS. THERE. ALSO
DEMOGRAPHIC ISSUES TO CONSIDER
WITH BOTH THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES
AND CALIFORNIA'S COLLEGE AGE
POPULATIONS, CURRENTLY DECLINING
AND ARE EXPECTED TO CONTINUE TO
DECLINE IN THE OUT YEARS, WHICH
ALL THINGS BEING EQUAL, COULD
SHRINK THE POP. UH, THE POOL
THAT WOULD BE APPLYING TO U èC.
ADDITIONALLY FIRST YEAR
RETENTION RATES RECENTLY
DECLINED FOR THREE CONSECUTIVE
YEARS FROM 2019 TO 2021. WHICH
ALSO IMPACTS THE TOTAL
ENROLLMENT LEVELS. GIVEN THESE
FACTORS AND IN LIGHT OF THE
BUDGET OUTLOOK THAT THE STATE
FACES WE RECOMMEND HOLDING THE
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT LEVEL
FLAT. LASTLY YOU SEE, CONTINUES
TO IMPLEMENT THE NON-RESIDENT
REDUCTION PLAN AT THE BERKELEY,
LOS ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO
CAMPUSES. MAINTAINING THE
NON-RESIDENT REDUCTION PLAN
WOULD COME AT A COST OF $31
MILLION. THE ADMINISTRATION ONCE
AGAIN, AS YOU HEARD EARLIER, DID
NOT PROVIDE THE FUNDING FOR THIS
PURPOSE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. GIVEN THAT STUDENT
DEMAND IS SO STRONG AT THESE
THREE CAMPUSES, THE LEGISLATURE
MAY REQUEST THAT YOU USE A
PORTION OF THEIR UNCOMMITTED
RESERVES, WHICH YOU HEARD
EARLIER TODAY IS ROUGHLY 238
MILLION TO CONTINUE IMPLEMENTING
THIS PLAN. WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT,
WHILE USING RESERVES FOR ONGOING
ENROLLMENT COSTS IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE OVER MANY YEARS.
THIS ACTION COULD BE CONSIDERED
ON A TEMPORARY BASIS, GIVEN THE
NON-RESIDENT PRODUCTION PLAN HAS
BEEN SUCH A HIGH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY. THAT CONCLUDES MY
OPENING REMARKS, AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I WILL MOVE ON TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU, CHAIR, LAIRD SAY OF TENANT
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AS PRESIDENT DRAKE SHARED IN HIS
OPENING REMARKS IN FALL OF 2023,
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ENROLLED OUR LARGEST EVER
ENTERING CLASS OF CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES. IN FALL OF 2020
THREE UC CAMPUSES ENROLLED
59,810 NEW CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES. FOR THE 2020
THREE 24 YEAR, THE UNIVERSITY
ESTIMATES THAT WE WILL HAVE
RECORD ENROLLMENT OF OVER
202,000, CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES. THIS INCREASE IN
ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
HAS BEEN DUE TO THE DELIBERATE
INVESTMENTS MADE BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR AND
THE UNIVERSITY. IN THE LAST
DECADE, THE STATE PROVIDED
ANNUAL FUNDING FOR INCREASING
ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA'S
UNDERGRADUATES. AND DURING THIS
TIME UC CAMPUSES GREW CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT BY OVER
29,000 STUDENTS. THIS INCLUDES
GROWTH AT U èC MERCED, BUT IT
FAR SURPASSES GROWTH AT A SINGLE
CAMPUS AND REFLECTS REAL
EXPANSION OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
MANY STUDENTS. WITH THE
LEGISLATURE'S FUTURE
INVESTMENTS, THE UNIVERSITY CAN
CONTINUE TO GROW. THE UNIVERSITY
APPRECIATES A STRONG PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE GOVERNOR, AND WE
REQUEST THE LEGISLATURE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSED DEFERRAL. OF
COMPACT FUNDING TO CONTINUE TO
OFFER ACCESS TO A QUALITY
EDUCATION. THE PROPOSED DEFERRED
FUNDING WOULD SUPPORT AN
ADDITIONAL 1% GROWTH IN
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES AND
THE REPLACEMENT OF 902
NON-RESIDENT STUDENTS WITH
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. IN
ADDITION, THE DEFERRED FUNDING
WILL SUPPORT NECESSARY EXISTING
CORE OPERATING COST INCREASES
FOR OUR CAMPUSES, INCLUDING
INSTRUCTION AND STUDENT SERVICES
FOR THE 2024 25 YEAR. WE INTEND
TO CONTINUE TO GROW CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT AT ALL
OF OUR UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES TO
MEET THE COMPACT GROWTH AND TO
CONTINUE TO REDUCE NON-RESIDENT
ENROLLMENT AT BERKELEY, LOS
ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO. AND THE
UNIVERSITY CONTINUES TO DECREASE
THE NUMBER OF NON-RESIDENT
STUDENTS THIS FALL, WE ENROLLED
OUR SMALLEST NUMBER OF
NON-RESIDENT STUDENTS SINCE 2017
WITH A THREE YEAR DECLINE,
LEADING TO A SYSTEM WIDE
NON-RESIDENTIAL OF 16.6% ALL
THANKS TO STATE SUPPORT. THE
COMPACT ENROLLMENT GROWTH FOR
2024 25 WILL BE 2927 F Tð,
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES. AND
IN ADDITION TO THAT ENROLLMENT
GROWTH, THE UNIVERSITY INTENDS
TO GROW ENROLLMENT TO ENSURE
THAT ANY SHORTFALL IN THE 2020
THREE 24 FUNDED TARGET IS MADE
UP NEXT YEAR. UH, WE MIGHT STILL
MEET THE FUNDED TARGET THIS YEAR
. UH GIVEN THAT IT IS AN F, Tð E
AND OUR STUDENT CREDIT HOURS ARE
SHOWING GREAT PROMISE OF
INCREASING OVER THE PREVIOUS
YEAR, SO WE THINK WE MIGHT
ACTUALLY GET VERY CLOSE TO THAT
GOAL. UM I WANT TO MENTION THAT
THE UNIVERSITY HAS ASPIRATIONS
TO GROW OUR GRADUATE HEALTH
SCIENCES PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS THE
CURRENT INEQUITIES IN THE STATE.
THE UNIVERSITY'S REQUESTING $3.5
MILLION IN ONGOING FUNDS TO
ESTABLISH AND SUPPORT ENROLLMENT
GROWTH FOR TWO NEW HEALTH
SCIENCES PROGRAMS MODELED AFTER
THE PROGRAMS IN MEDICAL
EDUCATION OR PRIME THESE NEW
PROGRAMS WOULD EXPAND AND
INNOVATIVE TRAINING CURRICULUM,
FOCUSING ON ADDRESSING HEALTH
CARE, WORKFORCE SHORTAGES AND
MEETING THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS IN DENTISTRY AND
PHARMACEUTICAL CARE. WE'RE ALSO
REQUESTING $800,000 FOR THE Dð
VÆ M SERVE WHICH WILL PREPARE
HIGHLY MOTIVATED, SOCIALLY
CONSCIOUS LEADERS TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO VETERINARY CARE AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS. THE
UNIVERSITY'S GOAL CONTINUES TO
BE TO OFFER ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE COLLEGE STUDENTS AS PART
OF THE 2030 CAPACITY PLAN. WE
INTEND TO GROW ENROLLMENT BY AT
LEAST 23,000 STUDENTS BETWEEN
2020 2030 IN ORDER TO HELP
CALIFORNIA MEET THE NEEDS FOR A
HIGHLY SKILLED WORKFORCE AND TO
PROVIDE OUR STUDENTS WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REACH THEIR
ASPIRATIONS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. THANK YOU. AND UH, I
ALREADY IN AN EARLIER ITEM
TALKED ABOUT THE BACKFILL, WHICH
I WOULD HAVE TALKED ABOUT HERE
ABOUT ENROLLMENT, SO AT LEAST
THAT ISSUE IS ON THE RECORD.
THE, UH I DID ASK THE CSU
REPRESENTATIVE IN THAT ITEM
ABOUT FAILURE TO NÓ. I SHOULD
USE ANOTHER WORD LIKE INABILITY
TO MAKE GOOD ON THE DEFERRALS.
HOW WOULD THAT INFECT
ENROLLMENT? IF THAT TURNS OUT TO
BE CASE. SO THE UNIVERSITY
INTENDS TO GROW ENROLLMENT IN
THIS COMING YEAR, AND THAT WILL
COST US MONEY IF WE DO NOT
RECEIVE A FUNDING TO COVER THAT
ENROLLMENT ON OUR BASE COST, WE
WILL HAVE A DEFICIT. UM, AS THE
PRESIDENT STATED, WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
TRYING TO SCALE BACK ON CERTAIN
EXPENDITURES. WE'RE DELAYING
LAUNCHES OF NEW PROGRAMS. WE'RE
DELAYING SOME CONTRACTS IN ORDER
TO ALLEVIATE EXPENDITURE
PRESSURE FOR THIS COMING YEAR.
WE UM, WOULD HAVE TO TAKE STEPS
IN PRIOR RECESSIONS. WHAT WE
HAVE DONE IS WE HAVE PUT IN
PLACE HIRING FREEZES. WE HAVE
UTILIZED FURLOUGHS AS WELL. UH
WE MAY HAVE TO HAVE A
NEGOTIATION WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ABOUT RE ENROLLING SOME
ADDITIONAL NON-RESIDENT STUDENTS
BECAUSE WE WOULD NOT HAVE THE
MONEY FOR THAT REPLACEMENT, AND
THOSE STUDENTS DO PROVIDE US
WITH ADDITIONAL REVENUE THAT
ACTUALLY SUPPORTS OUR RESIDENT
STUDENTS BEYOND THE COST OF
THEIR THEIR OWN FEES. UM SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO US? I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT FOR THE 2024 25
YEAR, THE UNIVERSITIES ESTIMATED
COST INCREASES IN OUR CORE
CAMPUS OPERATIONS ACTUALLY TOTAL
OVER $580 MILLION. A LOT OF THE
STUDENT TUITION AT THE NON
RESIDENCE, SUMO TUITION, THE
INVESTMENT INCOME AND DONATIONS
FROM PRIVATE INDIVIDUALS ARE
INTENDED TO COVER THE REST IN
ABOUT HALF ARE BEING REQUESTED
FROM THE SO IF WE DON'T GET THE
STATE FUNDING THOSE OTHER
FUNDING SOURCES ACTUALLY CANNOT
FULLY STEP INTO THAT. UH VOID
AND COVER THEM COMPLETELY. SO WE
WILL HAVE TO TAKE SOME ACTION
STEPS TO REDUCE OUR BUDGET IF
THE LEGISLATURE CHOOSES NOT TO
GIVE US THE DEFERRAL. OK? I
THINK I DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY
ELSE WANTS TO COMMENT ON THAT.
IT'S JUST A SMALL POINT OF
CLARIFICATION. SO WHAT WE'RE
RECOMMENDING IS LEVEL FUNDING,
SO MAINTAINING THE EXISTING
LEVEL OF FUNDING. NOT NOT AT
THIS POINT, PULLING ANY FUNDING
BACK. UM SO ANY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THAT WAS MENTIONED IN
TERMS OF THE SCHOOLS FUNDING
PLAN WOULD EITHER BE, UH, FOR
NEW SERVICES TO, UH, TAKE CARE
OF THE ADDITIONAL STUDENTS AT
THE CAMPUSES PLANNING, UH, TO
ENROLL, WHICH AGAIN? WE'RE
RECOMMENDING, UH, NOT
UNDERTAKING AT THIS TIME. OK AND
I DON'T KNOW. MAYBE YOU HAVE
PARTIALLY ADDRESSED THIS. ALL OF
YOU, BUT, UH AND MAYBE TO TRY TO
PUT IT IN ONE FORM. THE ISSUE
ORIGINALLY WAS A PARTICULAR
GROWTH OVER. I THINK IT WAS 2122
AND THERE WAS. I DON'T KNOW HOW
TO CHARACTERIZE IT. A
DISAGREEMENT OVER WHAT THE
ACTUAL ENROLLMENT WAS FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME AFTER THAT, AND I
THINK THAT'S BEEN CLARIFIED. AND
IT IT IT IS LIKELY THAT THE
UNIVERSITY WILL MEET THE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH THAT WAS
PREDICATED ON THAT IN THE NEXT
YEAR. YOU WERE REFERRING TO THAT
II. I JUST WANT TO KNOW IN THE
OVERLAPPING ISSUES. IS THAT
THREATENED BY THE OTHER THINGS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT? ARE YOU ON
TARGET AND YOU JUST EXPECT TO
MEET THAT GOAL THAT WAS SET
FORTH IN THE PREVIOUS BUDGET.
HOW WOULD YOU CHARACTERIZE THAT
THAT PREVIOUS ENROLLMENT GROWTH
HAS ALREADY BEEN FUNDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. YOU GAVE US A
TWOYEAR TARGET FROM 2021 TO 2020
, THREE OF 7800 F Dð STUDENTS.
UM WHEN WE GOT TO 6400, THOUGH,
ON THE HEAD COUNT BASIS WHERE AT
7300 WERE DOWN SO MUCH BECAUSE
OUR SUMMER ENROLLMENT DECLINED A
LOT. UM THAT BECAUSE THEY ALL
WENT TO èC S¼ U. THAT'S RIGHT.
UM I GUESS THEY LIKE IT BETTER
THERE. UM, THE BECAUSE THAT
ENROLLMENT IS ALREADY FUNDED. IF
WE ENROLL THOSE STUDENTS NEXT
YEAR THAT WILL NOT BE A COST TO
US UNLESS THE LEGISLATURE WERE
TO EXERCISE AN OPTION TO PULL
BACK FUNDS NOW, AND WE HOPE YOU
DON'T DO THAT. WE DO THINK THAT
THE STUDENT CREDIT HOURS WILL
GET US CLOSER TO THAT 7800 MARK
IN THE CURRENT. WELL, I THINK
THE ISSUE WAS THAT HE AND IT'S
ALWAYS NICE TO SAY WE FUNDED
ENROLMENT. OUR GOAL IS TO ENROLL
AND ACTUALLY SHOWS UP AFTER WE
FUNDED IT. THAT'S WHERE THE
DISAGREEMENT WAS, OR IN NUMBERS
OR WHATEVER, AND WE JUST WANT UM
GOOD FEELING THAT IT'S ACTUALLY
GONNA READ REACH THAT BECAUSE
THERE'S AN EXTRA YEAR THAT'S
BEEN GIVEN BECAUSE OF WHAT
CONCERNS OR DIFFERENCES WERE
OVER IT BEFORE CAMPUSES ARE
MAKING OFFERS TO STUDENTS RIGHT
NOW, WITH THE INTENT TO ENROLL
THOSE AT THE STUDENTS FOR THE
FALL OF 2024. YES AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST HAVE ANY
COMMENT ON THAT? YEAH, I'LL
REITERATE MY POINT THAT WE
RECOMMEND, UH, HOLDING THEIR
ENROLLMENT TARGET FLAT FOR 2425
AND 2526. WITH RESPECT TO
MEETING THE BUDGET ACT, THE 7800
STUDENTS, UM I'LL JUST PROVIDE
SOME VERY BRIEF BACKGROUND FOR
THAT THAT THAT WAS CONSISTED OF
THREE SEPARATE COMPONENTS, ONE
OF WHICH WAS THE 902 STUDENTS
THAT WERE TO BE REPLACED WITH
RESIDENT STUDENTS. UH THAT WAS
SUCCESSFULLY ACHIEVED ADDITIONAL
, UH, FUNDING WAS PROVIDED TO
INCREASE RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT BY 4730 RESIDENT
STUDENTS. WE BELIEVE THAT TO
HAVE BEEN ACHIEVED AND THE
DIFFERENCE HERE IS THE REMAINING
1% GROWTH THAT WAS TO TAKE PLACE
BY THE 5% BASE AUGMENTATION
WHERE THEY'RE FALLING. JUST
SHORT RIGHT NOW. UH, WE DON'T WE
DON'T HAVE MAJOR CONCERNS WITH
THEM BEING BEHIND AT THIS POINT.
UM AS WE HAVE LOOKED AT GOING
BACK, 10 YEARS UH, U C'S BUDGET,
UH, ENROLLMENT ESTIMATES AT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO WHAT THE
ACTUALS ENDED UP BEING IN MOST
YEARS, THEY ENDED UP BEING
CLOSER OR GREATER THAN WHAT THE
ESTIMATES WERE AT THE, UH AT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. SO WE ARE
ANTICIPATING SOME FLUCTUATION,
AND THAT'S WHY WE MADE THE
RECOMMENDATION TO, UH, SCOOP
BACK ANY UNEARNED FUNDS ONCE
THOSE NUMBERS ARE FINALIZED IN
THE NEXT BUDGET CYCLE. OK? THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER COMMENTS. I
THINK YOU'VE BENEFITED BY BEING
FOURTH BECAUSE WE HAD ALL THESE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT PIECES OF THIS
BEFORE WE GOT TO YOU SO THEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
APPRECIATE IT, AND WE'LL LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING HOW WE COME
OUT WITH ALL THAT. AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS FOR WHICH
ARE REALLY THE ONE THAT MERCED
AND THE ONE AT U èC L A. IT'S
EXACTLY THE SAME PANEL. SO LET'S
GO, UH, IN THE SAME ORDER,
STARTING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND IN THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST AND IN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. UH, GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR. UH, LATER, UH, GABRIELA
CHÁVEZ WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. CONSISTENT WITH THE
2019 BUDGET ACT. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES AN INCREASE OF
14.5 MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
FUND. TO SUPPORT A MEDICAL
SCHOOL PROJECT USE IN MERCED
BEGINNING IN 2024 25. ALSO THE
GOVERNANCE BUDGET PROPOSES TO
FORGO PLAN INVESTMENT OF
300,000,001 TIME GENERAL FUND.
TO SUPPORT FOR THE CONSTRUCTION
OF AN INSTITUTE FOR IMMUNOLOGY
AND IMMUNOTHERAPY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA, LOS
ANGELES. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. YOU MAY THANK YOU.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. THANK YOU.
CHAIR LAITY INCLINE WITH THE L A
Ó. WE HAVE TWO COMMENTS RELATED
TO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSALS. FIRST WE RECOMMEND
ADOPTING THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO FOCUS UH FOREGO THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE U èC
L, A IMMUNOLOGY AND IMMUN
IMMUNOTHERAPY INSTITUTE, AS THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS NÓ LONGER
NEEDED DUE TO THE PROJECT SCOPE
CHANGE. SECOND REGARDING THE
MEDICAL SCHOOL PROJECT AT UC
MERCED. WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE PAUSE THE FUNDING OF
THIS PROJECT. THE 29 BUDGET ACT
AUTHORIZED TO PURSUE A MEDICAL
SCHOOL PROJECT AT OR NEAR THE U
èC MERCED CAMPUS AND INCLUDED
LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO SUPPORT
THE DEBT SERVICE FOR THAT
FACILITY. THIS COMES TO A COST
OF 14.5 MILLION, BEGINNING WITH
THE 2425 BUDGET. YOU SEE, HAS
INDICATED THAT IT HAS NOT YET
DRAWN COMMERCIAL PAPER NOR
ISSUED A REVENUE BOND FOR THE
PROJECT. GIVEN THAT THIS PROJECT
IS STILL IN ITS EARLY STAGES, WE
RECOMMEND THAT IT BE PAUSED AND
REVISITED ONCE THE STATE'S
BUDGET CONDITION APPROVES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. SAY OUR
CANNON FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. UM CALIFORNIA
CENTRAL VALLEY IS STRUGGLING TO
PROVIDE ADEQUATE HEALTH CARE TO
ITS RESIDENTS AND RECOGNIZING
THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL DOCTORS
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN THE
BUDGET ACT OF 2015, THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTED UC TO USE
OUR INTERNAL FUNDS TO, UH, COVER
THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PROCESS TO LOOK AT CREATING A
MEDICAL SCHOOL AT UC MERCED,
THEN IN 2019, THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECTED THE UC TO CONSTRUCT A
MEDICAL SCHOOL BUILDING AFTER
SAID AND SAID YOU WOULD COVER
THE BOND FUNDS COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT. UH, THE CAMPUS IS
ABOUT TO BREAK GROUND ON THE
IMPORTANT BUILDING THAT WILL
SERVICE THE FUTURE SIDE OF THE
MEDICAL SCHOOL AT UC MERCED. THE
BUILDING WILL HOUSE THE MEDICAL
EDUCATION AND ALLIED HEALTH CARE
PROGRAMS AND THEIR ASSOCIATED
INSTRUCTIONAL FACILITIES TO
ALLIED DEPARTMENTS,
PSYCHOLOGICAL SCIENCES AND
PUBLIC HEALTH AND HEALTH
SCIENTIST RESEARCH INSTITUTE AND
GENERAL ASSIGNMENT CLASSROOMS TO
SUPPORT INCREASED STUDENT
ENROLLMENT. THAT WILL ALLOW THE
CAMPUS TO EXPAND ENROLLMENT BY
HOUSING GROWING DEPARTMENTS. THE
L A Ó HAS RECOMMENDED THAT THIS
PROJECT BE HALTED. UM BUT THE
UNIVERSITY REQUESTS THAT YOU
ALLOW THE BUILDING TO CONTINUE
BECAUSE IT IS NECESSARY TO
DEVELOP THE MEDICAL EDUCATION AT
UC MERCED. THE COHORT OF
STUDENTS WHO WILL RECEIVE THEIR
MEDICAL EDUCATION MERCED HAVE
BEEN SELECTED BASED ON THE
STUDENT'S INTEREST IN WORKING
WITH UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. YOU SEE,
MERCED CANNOT RECEIVE
ACCREDITATION FOR THEIR MEDICAL
SCHOOL WITHOUT THE PROPER
INSTRUCTIONAL FACILITIES. AND
THE LEGISLATURE HAS REPEATEDLY
ENDORSED THE FUNDING FOR THE
MEDICAL EDUCATION AT U, èC
MERCED, AND STOPPING NOW WOULD
NOT BE COST EFFECTIVE IN THE
LONG RUN. THE STATE'S OWN
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES,
WHICH TRACKS THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION COSTS. INDEX STATED
THAT IN FEBRUARY OF 2024
CONSTRUCTION INFLATION IN
CALIFORNIA WAS AT 9.6. IF WE
STOP NOW, IT'LL JUST GET MORE
EXPENSIVE. UM SO, FOR THIS
REASON WE REQUEST THAT YOU ALLOW
THE UNIVERSITY TO CONTINUE ON
WITH THE MEDICAL EDUCATION
BUILDING AT U èC MERCED. NOW
I'LL MOVE ON TO THE UM WEST SIDE
PAVILION, WHICH IS IN THE, UM,
AGENDA. JUST WANTED TO NOTE A
FEW THINGS ABOUT THIS. U èC L A
PROJECT I WAS GONNA SAY, WEST
SIDE PAVILION. THAT'S U èC L A
RIGHT. AND THEN YOU WENT RIGHT
TO IT. IT WAS JUST GONNA CLARIFY
IF YOU WANT ME TO PAUSE FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS, I KNOW THAT WAS THE
QUESTION. YOU JUST SAID WEST
SIDE PAVILION AND HALF THE
PEOPLE WOULD NOT UNDERSTAND.
THAT WAS U èC L A. BUT AS I WAS
TRYING TO INTERRUPT YOU YOU SAID
U èC L A. WE'RE GOOD. THAT'S
RIGHT. GREAT. GREAT. GLAD IT WAS
CLARIFIED. UH, YOU SO U èC L, A
ACQUIRED THIS WEST SIDE PAVILION
IN DECEMBER OF 2020 THREE. THEY
USED STATE FUNDING AS A PORTION
OF THE PURCHASE PRICE. THE WEST
SIDE PAVILION IS A 700,000
SQUARE FOOT PROPERTY. LOCATED
TWO MILES FROM THE U èC L, A
MAIN CAMPUS AND THE SITE WILL BE
RENAMED TO U èC L, A RESEARCH
PARK, THE U èC L, A RESEARCH
PARK WILL HOUSE THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE FOR IMMUNOLOGY AND
IMMUNOTHERAPY, THE U èC L, A
CENTER FOR QUANTUM SCIENCE AND
ENGINEERING AND AS WELL AS
PROGRAMS IN MANY DISCIPLINES.
THE RESEARCH PARK WILL BRING
TOGETHER SCHOLARS AND INDUSTRY
EXPERTS FROM AROUND THE WORLD
AND IT WILL SERVE AS A CENTER
FOR INNOVATION AND SCIENTIFIC
DISCOVERY, AND IT WILL PROVIDE
AN ENGINE FOR ECONOMIC GROWTH
FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
BEYOND. UH IN AUGUST OF 2023,
THE REGIONS APPROVED A TERM
SHEET AGREEMENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR
IMMUNOLOGY AND IMMUNOTHERAPY,
AND THE IN THIS INSTITUTE IS A
PRIVATE, NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
THAT WILL RENT SPACE FROM U èC
L, A AT THE RESEARCH PARK. AND
PERTH THIS TERM SHEET, THE
INSTITUTE WILL BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR TENANT IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
SPACE THAT THEY OCCUPY. THE TERM
SHEET ALSO ADDRESSES
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY RIGHTS AND
REQUIRES THE INSTITUTE TO PAY U
èC L, A 7.5% FOR PROFITS FOR
THEIR INVENTIONS THAT THE
UNIVERSITY DID NOT CONTRIBUTE
FUNDING TOWARDS AND OTHER
DETAILS OF AN AFFILIATION
AGREEMENT ARE STILL BEING
DETERMINED. BUT AT THIS TIME,
THE UNIVERSITY ESTIMATES THAT
THE RESEARCH PARK RENOVATION
WILL COST $560 MILLION. THAT'S
AN EARLY COST ESTIMATE AND IT
WILL CHANGE. UH, WE DO EXPECT
THE CENTER FOR THE QUANTUM
SCIENCE AND ENGINEERING TO MOVE
INTO THE SPACE IN 24 MONTHS. UM
BUT WE ARE STILL IN THE PROCESS
OF DEVELOPING THOSE PRELIMINARY
PLANS AND STUDYING HOW MUCH IT
WILL COST AND GETTING ALL THE
ACTUAL TIMELINES FOR YOU. UH UH,
MOVING. THAT COMPLETES YOUR
COMMENTS THAT COMPLETES MY
COMMENTS AND MOVING TO THE
QUESTIONS. UM LET'S START WITH
THAT ONE BECAUSE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST SORT OF INDICATED THAT
MILLION. I COULD NOT TELL IN
YOUR COMMENTS. WHETHER YOU
AGREED, OR YOU WERE SAYING THAT
IT'S NEEDED FOR THE THINGS YOU
LINED OUT. HELP ME HERE. COMPARE
YOUR TUBE POSITIONS. STATE
FUNDING THAT WAS INITIALLY
REQUESTED WAS NOT A èC PROPOSAL
BUT WAS A GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
UM THE ORIGINAL COST OF THE
BUILDING WAS ESTIMATED $1
BILLION. AND WE ARE NOW, UM AND
A LITTLE BIT LESS BECAUSE THE
PURCHASE PRICE WAS JUST OVER 300
MILLION AND THE RENOVATION COSTS
WILL BE ABOUT 560 MILLION STILL
TO BE FULLY DETERMINED EXACTLY
WHERE WE LAND ON THAT. SO YOU'RE
TRYING TO OFFER A COMMENT ABOUT
A PROPOSAL? THAT WASN'T YOURS?
THIS IS A THIS IS A UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA OWNED BUILDING AND
WE WILL BE RENOVATING IT.
ALRIGHT. THE PROPOSAL WAS NOT
ORIGINALLY HOURS FOR THE STATE
FUNDING. WELL, LET'S TRY THIS
WAY. UH DO YOU OPPOSE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
RECOMMENDATION TO THAT YOU DON'T
NEED THE 300 MILLION THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
OKAY? YOU KNOW FOR ONCE IT'S NOT
THE FINANCE DEPARTMENT THAT'S
DOING THAT. SO, UH BEFORE WE
LEAVE THAT SUBJECT. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COMMENT ON THAT? SHORT
OF SAYING YOU STICK WITH YOUR
RECOMMENDATION. I THINK WE'RE
GONNA STICK WITH THAT FOR NOW.
YES, OKAY. ALTHOUGH SOMEBODY'S
COMING UP OUT OF THE CROWD JUST
TO BE CLEAR. EVERYBODY IS SAYING
THE EXACT SAME THING AND JUST
DIFFERENT WORDS. SO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TAKES THE
MONEY OUT. SO I THINK YOU SEE A
SAINT. OF COURSE 300 MILLION
WOULD BE BETTER THAN NOT, BUT
IT'S NOT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, AND WE'RE JUST
RECOMMENDING THAT OF ALL THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL SOLUTIONS BEFORE
YOU THIS ONE'S REASONABLE
ACTUALLY, ALSO, I LIKE THAT AND
ALL THE OTHER SOLUTIONS WEREN'T
REASONABLE. IS THAT GENERALLY
IT? I'M JUST KIDDING. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE TRANSLATION THAT
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL. IT SOUNDS
LIKE WE WILL. I LIKE THAT, TOO.
SO THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT. AND
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME TEASE
YOU. AND THEN ON THE OTHER ITEM
ON MERCED. THAT WAS THE ONE MY
INITIAL QUESTION WAS SORT OF
ADDRESSED, BUT BUT MAYBE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OR OR
FINANCE CAN TALK ABOUT IT. BUT
BECAUSE MY QUESTION WAS GOING TO
BE WHAT DO WE LOSE BY NOT DOING
THIS IN THE PROGRESSION OF A
PROJECT? HA! I MEAN, WHAT DOES
IT DO? DOES IT JUST MOVE CERTAIN
PIECES OF IT OFF A YEAR AND
ACCEPT EXPECT THAT THE ENTIRE
PROJECT MOVES OFF A YEAR?
OBVIOUSLY IN WHAT WAS SAID. THE
EXPECTATION IS IF YOU DO THAT
THE COST OF CONSTRUCTION WILL GO
UP. IT WILL COST MORE. AND IT
SEEMS LIKE IT'S A RELATIVELY
SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT IT'S
GONNA PUT US ON THE HOOK FOR A
BIGGER AMOUNT OF MONEY, BUT GETS
US THERE SOONER AND WOULDN'T SO
JENNIFER PATEL AGAIN. LARGE
ANALYSTS OFF OF THIS WAS ONE OF
THE MORE DIFFICULT
RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE BECAUSE
IT IS OF LEGISLATIVE INTEREST.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS APPROVED THE
PROJECT IT HAS ADVANCED. IT JUST
HASN'T GONE TO CONSTRUCTION AND
THEY HAVEN'T SOLD ANY COMMERCIAL
PAPER BONDS FOR IT. IN ADDITION,
THE ACCREDITATION PROCESS IS
GOING TO TAKE MANY YEARS. SO WE
AGAIN WE'RE TRYING TO FIND
BUDGET SOLUTIONS THAT WOULD HAVE
NO IMMEDIATE DIRECT IMPACT ON
STUDENTS, FACULTY AND STAFF. AND
THIS DOES DO THIS. IT ALSO IS
GOING TO BE THE MOST EXPENSIVE
STATE THE COSTLIEST STATE
FACILITY THIS STATE HAS EVER
FUNDED FOR. YOU SEE, IT'S
COSTING DOUBLE WHAT THE U. C
RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
BUILDING WHICH WE TOURED THIS
FALL, IT'S COSTING DOUBLE THAT.
AND ONCE YOU LOSE THESE
OPPORTUNITIES TO PAUSE CAPITAL
PROJECTS WERE THE DEFICITS TO
PERSIST. THE OPTIONS NEXT YEAR
ARE LAYOFFS AND THINGS THAT ARE
GOING TO SOUND RELATIVELY
SPEAKING EVEN MORE. UH, FIRST
OKAY? YOU LOOK LIKE YOU HAVE A
COMMENT. THANK YOU, SIR. I'D
LIKE TO RESPOND TO THE
COMPARISON TO THE RIVERSIDE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE BUILDING. SO
THE RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
BUILDING THAT THE REFERENCE WAS
ACTUALLY AT THE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE BUILDING NUMBER TWO.
THEY NOW HAVE TWO SEPARATE
BUILDINGS BECAUSE THEY'VE
DISCOVERED THE FIRST ONE WAS NOT
BIG ENOUGH FOR THEIR SCHOOL. IN
ORDER TO GROW. THEY NEED A
SECOND ONE. THAT SECOND WAS
PRIMARILY CLASSROOMS, UM, AND
DID NOT INCLUDE SOME OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT WERE IN THE
FIRST BUILDING, WHICH ARE THEIR
REFRIGERATORS AGAINST STORE, THE
CADAVERS AND THE SPECIALTY LABS
THAT ARE REQUIRED FOR MEDICAL
SCHOOL. SO IF YOU LOOK AT
ACTUALLY THE TWO BUILDINGS
TOGETHER, YOU GET TOO FAR MORE
COMPARABLE COST. UM WE'RE TRYING
TO BUILD A BUILDING OF MERCED
THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO GET
MEDICAL SCHOOL ACCREDITATION AND
GROW AT THE SAME TIME. UM THE
HALTING OF THE PROJECT THEY ARE
ABOUT TO BREAK GROUND WILL
GREATLY COMPLICATED MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE CONSTRUCTION.
SO WE WOULD WE WOULD ASK THAT
YOU NOT PULL BACK THE FUNDS AT
THIS TIME. HMM. OKAY. UM. I
WOULD JUST SAY I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMING ON HOW HARD IT IS. WOULD
OBVIOUSLY BE OUR PREFERENCE TO
KEEP GOING, BUT WELL. PUT THIS
ALL IN THE MIX. FOR WHAT? THE
CHALLENGES ARE, IT JUST MAKES
SENSE, AND PARTICULARLY WITH
WHAT COULD HAPPEN NEXT YEAR. AND
TRY TO KEEP THIS ON TRACK, BUT I
KNOW THAT WE HAVE A MONUMENTAL
DEFICIT. WE'RE LOOKING FOR WAYS
TO BRIDGET. UM, DO YOU HAVE ANY
LAST COMMENTS ON THIS? OKAY, UM
THEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
APPRECIATE THIS ON PREVIOUS
ITEMS. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT AND SOME OF YOU
HAVE BEEN PATIENTLY WAITING
THERE. LET ME JUST TAKE IT
INFORMAL POLL. HOW MANY OF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS. IN ADDITION TO THE
PERSON THAT'S ALREADY STANDING
AT THE PODIUM. I SEE SIX. SO IF
THAT'S THE CASE WILL GIVE
EVERYBODY UP TO TWO MINUTES TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE SO AND IF
THE REST OF YOU WOULD LINE UP
AND BE READY SO WE CAN JUST DO
THIS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALL SIX OF YOU AND THE PERSON AT
THE PODIUM BEING SO PATIENT AND
WAITING THROUGH OUR VARIOUS
DISCUSSIONS TO GET TO THIS
MOMENT. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR.
POLITICS REIT ON BEHALF OF THE
PECHANGA TO HONE AND COLUSA
INDIAN TRIBES. ON THE AREA OF
TRIBAL REPATRIATION. AND THIS IS
VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO ME, SO I
WROTE IT DOWN SO I WOULD GET MY
THOUGHTS ACROSS. UM, I'VE HEARD
PROMISES FOR THREE DECADES OF
REPRESENTING TRIBES. IT'S HARD
NOT TO LIKE PRESIDENT DRAKE AND
CHANCELLOR GARCIA. AH BUT THEIR
POSITIONS CANNOT GIVE AWAY
ACCOUNTABILITY. TALK AND BROKEN
PROMISES ARE WHAT TRIBES HAVE
RECEIVED FOR 30. PLUS YEARS THAT
I'VE REPRESENTED THEM. IT TOOK
YEARS TO GET REPATRIATION LAWS
ON THE BOOKS. THE SIMPLE TRUTH
IS THAT YOU SEE IN THE CSU HAVE
NOT FOLLOWED THE LAW FOR OVER
TWO DECADES. THOUSANDS OF ITEMS
AND REMAINS ARE KEPT IN THE BACK
ROOMS AND PLASTIC BAGS AND BOXES
. SOME PROFESSORS HAVE PRIVATE
COLLECTIONS. ITS STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW, AND IT HAS BEEN
THEIR LOWEST PRIORITY. THE UC
AND CSU BUDGET SHOULD BE TIED TO
THEIR REPATRIATING BACK TO
TRIBES PER INSTITUTION. FOR
EXAMPLE, U C L A HAS BEEN GREAT.
MY ALMA MATER, UC BERKELEY IS
DRAGGED THEIR FEET. THE VERY
MOST PHOEBE HEARST SHOULD BE
SHUT DOWN UNTIL AT LEAST 90% OF
THEIR HOARDED ITEMS AND REMAINS
ARE REPATRIATED BACK. AND THAT
INCLUDES THE HELD BACK ITEMS IN
THE BACK ROOMS THAT THEY KEEP
WHEN THEY TELL TRIBES THEY HAVE
NO MORE ITEMS. UH THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE IN FORCES BUDGET
COMMITTEE NEEDS TO SEND A STRONG
EDICT THAT TRIBE, TRIBAL REMAINS
AND ITEMS DO NOT BELONG TO THE U
C OR THE CSU. AND IF THESE WERE
YOUR FAMILY MEMBERS, YOU WOULD
WANT THEM BACK LONG AGO. TRIBES
ARE TIRED OF BEING OF BEGGING
FOR THEIR ANCESTORS TO BE
RETURNED. ON BEHALF OF MY
CLIENTS. I HOPE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WILL DO SOMETHING
AFTER ALL THESE DECADES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS. NEXT WEEK.
WELCOME TO THE COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR LAIRD
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS MOLLY MCGUIRE WITH THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET LARGELY CONTINUES THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT IN COLLEGE
ACCESS AND STUDENT SUCCESS, AND
WE ARE DEEPLY GRATEFUL THAT
AMIDST FISCAL UNCERTAINTY THE
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL PROTECTS
AND PRESERVES HIGHER EDUCATION
FUNDING. THAT SAID THERE ARE A
FEW AREAS OF THE BUDGET THAT
MERIT ADDITIONAL ATTENTION FROM
POLICYMAKERS. WHILE WE AGREE
THAT RELIABLE BASED FUNDING
INCREASES TO THE UC AND CSU
THROUGH THE COMPACTS ARE
CRITICAL TO THEIR ABILITY TO
PLAN FOR AND FUND VITAL STUDENT
SUCCESS AND RETENTION WORK.
THOSE BASED FUNDING INCREASES
WERE PART OF A 2022 AGREEMENT TO
PAIR FUNDING INCREASES WITH
MEANINGFUL IMPROVEMENTS ACROSS
SEVERAL AREAS, INCLUDING ACCESS,
COMPLETION AND AFFORDABILITY. WE
WOULD ARGUE THAT THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS HAVE BEEN UNEVEN,
AT BEST, IN PARTICULAR AROUND
TRANSFER STUDENT SUCCESS IN THE
REMOVAL OF EQUITY GAPS. WE WOULD
ALSO ARGUE THAT SOME OF THESE
IMPROVEMENTS IN PARTICULAR
AROUND TRANSFER STUDENT SUCCESS
ARE RELATIVELY LOW COST, AND
THEREFORE IT'S UNCLEAR WHY WE
HAVEN'T SEEN MORE CONSISTENT
PROGRESS. IT SUGGESTS NOT A
RESOURCE PROBLEM, BUT A
RESISTANCE TO TREATING TRANSFER
STUDENT SUCCESS ON PAR WITH
FIRST TIME FRESHMEN SUCCESS,
WHICH ULTIMATELY REINFORCES
EQUITY GAPS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH MEMBERS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OVER THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS TO PRIORITIZE THE
SEGMENTS COMMITMENT TO MAKING
GOOD ON ALL OF THE COMPACT
GOALS, EVEN THE DIFFICULT ONES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT SPEAKER. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. TIFFANY
MARK WITH C F T, A UNION OF
EDUCATORS AND CLASSIFIED
PROFESSIONALS. WE ARE HERE TO
TESTIFY THAT WE HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE DEFERRAL OF THE
CONTACT FUNDING FOR THE èC
SEGMENT, BUT WE WOULD OPPOSE
WHICH IS DIFFERENT THAN A
CONCERN. UM ANY CUTS TO THE
COMPACT? WE BELIEVE THAT IT IS
ESSENTIAL TO FUNDING OUR FACULTY
AND ENSURING OUR BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS SO THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE THE SAME SERVICES AND
THE SUPPORTS THAT STUDENTS NEED
TO SUCCEED. JUST BECAUSE WE HAVE
MORE DIVERSE STUDENTS. WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE BLESS ROBUST
SERVICES. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS RAYMOND GONZALES. I
AM A STUDENT AT CSU, STANISLAS
AND A STUDENT FOR QUALITY
EDUCATION INTERN FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
TODAY. I'M HERE TO ASK THAT YOU
MATCH THE GOVERNOR'S HIGHER
EDUCATION BUDGET PROPOSAL AND
ENSURE THE CSU REMAINS FUNDED. I
JOINED THE FIGHT FOR QUALITY
EDUCATION BECAUSE AS A LOW
INCOME, FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENT WITH THREE YOUNGER
SIBLINGS COMING INTO THE SYSTEM
AFTER ME. THIS FUNDING IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AS IT WOULD
ALLOW MYSELF AND OTHERS WITH
BACKGROUNDS LIKE MINE. YOU HAVE
ACCESS TO QUALITY EDUCATION.
WITH THE CURRENT TUITION
INCREASES THAT WE'RE FACING.
THAT WILL DIRECTLY AFFECT CSU
STUDENTS. WE ARE SEEING
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT OF A
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT OF
STUDENTS. THAT CAN'T AFFORD LESS
FUNDING. WE NEED TO KEEP OUR
CLASSES, CURRENT PROGRAMS AND
MAINTAIN CURRENT ETC. FOR
AWHILE, ROUNDED EDUCATION. ONE
SUCH CHOICE IS HOLDING THE CSU
TO ITS CORE MISSION OF PROVIDING
STUDENTS AND ATTAINABLE QUALITY
EDUCATION. WITH YOUR OVERSIGHT
AND CAREFUL SHEPHERDING OF
CALIFORNIA'S FINITE RESOURCES. I
TRUST THAT THE PEOPLE'S
UNIVERSITY WILL LIVE UP TO ITS
MISSION AGAIN. I URGE YOU TO
FULLY FUND THE CSU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUED ADVOCACY TO
HIGHER EDUCATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR LEERDAM
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS TAYLOR
HAWKINS. I'M ALSO A STUDENT DEBT
CSU, STANISLAUS AND AN INTERN
FOR STUDENTS FOR QUALITY
EDUCATION WITH THE F A. I'M HERE
TODAY TO ASK YOU TO MATCH THE
GOVERNOR'S HIGHER EDUCATION
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND ENSURE THE
CSU REMAINS FUNDED. UM I JOINED
THE FIGHT FOR QUALITY EDUCATION
BECAUSE I BELIEVE FULFILLING THE
MASTER PLAN FOR EDUCATION IS THE
KEY TO UPWARD SOCIAL MOBILITY.
I'M A FIRST GENERATION STUDENT.
UM MY DAD IS A NAVY VETERAN OF
26 YEARS, HIS SERVITUDE AND THE
NAVY'S UPHOLDING THEIR AGREEMENT
ALLOWED ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SCRAPE BY AND ATTEND HIGHER
EDUCATION. UM BUT I ALSO HAVE
HAD STEADY EMPLOYMENT HAVE HAD
TO TAKE OUT A STUDENT LOAN
RACKED UP $10,000 IN CREDIT CARD
DEBT TO PAY FOR TUITION. UM I
MOVED 100 MILES TO AN AFFORDABLE
CSU TOWN. WE'RE UM WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING THAT WE FEEL IS A
WE'VE WE'VE BEEN TOLD TO DO
PRETTY MUCH YOU KNOW, WE'VE
PULLED HERSELF UP BY BOOTSTRAPS,
SO TO SPEAK, BUT WE STILL FEEL
THE WEIGHT OF ENTRENCHMENT
NIPPING LIKE AT OUR HEELS. IT'S
RIGHT THERE. UM ALL THAT I
MENTIONED I'VE DONE BEFORE. THAT
WAS BEFORE THE TUITION RAISED
34% AND I KNOW YOU HAVE A
DIFFICULT DECISION TO MAKE. UM
AND THERE'S SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
ON THE ON THE LINE, BUT IT'S
TAKEN MY FAMILY THREE
GENERATIONS OF SACRIFICE. TO
BARELY GET HERE. UM AND LIKE,
JUST AS WE'RE GETTING HERE, THE
LINE IS BEING MOVED. UM SO I
WOULD SAY WE WOULD WE WOULD ASK
YOU TO FULLY FUND THE CSU. UM
AND LET US SEE AS YOU'D BE A
RESOURCE RATHER THAN ANOTHER
SYSTEM NOT BUILT FOR US THAT WE
HAVE TO CIRCUMVENT. BECAUSE
INITIALLY IT WAS IT WAS BUILT.
FOR US, UM, BUT I WOULD ALSO
ENCOURAGE, UM FOR YOU TO
ENCOURAGE, UH, REALLOCATION OF
FUNDS BECAUSE YOU GIVING THE
FUNDS FOR THE STUDENTS FOR THE
CSU. THAT'S HELPFUL FOR US. BUT
IF IT'S NOT IF IT'S NOT BEING
GIVEN FOR US IF IT'S BEING
HOARDED AT THE TOP. UM, IF WE'RE
SEEING ARE FACULTY AND STAFF
HAVE TO FIGHT NAILING TOOTH FOR
US TO GET, UM, PROPORTIONATE
AMOUNT OF COUNCILOR STUDENT
RATIOS AND, UM, FOR THEIR
WORKING CONDITIONS ARE LEARNING
CONDITIONS TO BE, UM IMPROVED
AND WE DON'T SEE THE SAME THING
FROM ADMIN. I KNOW YOU FEEL FOR
BOTH OF YOUR PARENTS WERE
TEACHERS, RIGHT? YES. EVEN
THOUGH I'M NOT SUPPOSED TO
RESPOND, BUT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS, THEIR
HEARTFELT AND THEIR PERSONAL,
BUT IF YOU COULD BEGIN TO WRAP
UP, UM THAT'S ALL. I JUST, UM WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO FULLY FUND THE
CSU, AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT THIS FAR. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND FOR WAITING TO
BE ABLE TO GIVE THEM WELCOME TO
THE COMMUNITY. SO GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARE. LARD STEPHEN FILLING. I'M
THE POLITICAL ACTION SHARE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION. I'M ALSO A
PROFESSOR OF ACCOUNTING AND
ETHICS IT CSU STANISLAUS AND
DEEPLY PROUD OF MY STUDENTS, IF
YOU COULD JUST SEEN I WANT TO
NOTE THAT MY COLLEAGUES
APPRECIATED HEARING THE
PRESENTATION IN THE
CONVERSATION. THEY HAD TO LEAVE
TO PROVIDE THE HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION THAT OUR STUDENTS
DESERVE. IN OTHER WORDS, THEY
HAD TO GO TEACH. WE'RE HERE TO
ASK THAT THE LEGISLATURE CONCUR
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
PROPOSAL FOR CSU FUNDING. AND
WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO SEE THAT
REFLECTED IN THE SENATE EARLY
BUDGET ACTION PLAN. WE AGREE
THAT THE PROPOSED DEFERRAL OF
THE BASE INCREASES A REASONABLE
ADJUSTMENT, GIVEN THE STATE'S
REVENUE FORECAST. AND WE'RE ALSO
COMFORTABLE THAT THE CSU HAS
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO BRIDGE
FUNDING DURING THAT PERIOD. CSU
PROVIDES UNPARALLELED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS WOULD BE A DISASTER FOR
THEM. THE CSU WAS FORCED TO CUT
CLASSES AND SEVERELY CONSTRAIN
OUR STUDENTS ABILITY TO COMPLETE
THE EDUCATION. THAT EMPOWERS
THAT SOCIAL MOBILITY CHANCELLOR
GARCIA TALKED ABOUT OUR SOCIETY
AND OUR STATE HAVE A CONTINUING
COMMITMENT TO CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. AND A MORAL OBLIGATION
TO PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES THEY
DESERVE. AGAIN WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR CONTINUING SUPPORT FOR
FUNDING IN THE CSU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS. AND NOW WE'RE
GOING TO GET TO THE THREE PEOPLE
THAT SAT IN THE FRONT ROW FOR
THREE HOURS WAITING TO SPEAK. SO
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. HMM MY NAME IS JOSHUA SMITH
. AND I'M A STUDENT AT U. C
DAVIS AND I ASKED THAT CALGARY
OUT TO BE, YOU KNOW, SUPPORTED
FOR NEXT YEAR'S, YOU KNOW THAT
YOU CAN MATCH THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND WHICH INCLUDES
CALDERON'S A SUPPORT AND
EXPANSION OF THE CONRADS IN THE
NEXT YEARS BUDGET AND, UM, FOR
CONTEXT. I AM A TRANSFER STUDENT
AT DAVIS, WHO ARE FORTUNATELY
OUT LOANS AND THAT IN THE PAST
AND WHICH IS NOT ATYPICAL FOR
OTHER STUDENTS. HAD IT NOT BEEN
FOR CAL GRANTS, HOWEVER, I WOULD
HAVE NOT HAVE ATTENDED AT UC
DAVIS IS OR EVEN ACCEPTED. U. C.
DAVIS IS ADMISSION LETTER IN
2021 NOR AH, NOR I WOULD KIND OF
BE HERE AS WELL. I'M PROUD TO
SAY THAT I'M ONE OF THE
COUNTLESS SUCCESS STORIES OF
CALIFORNIA'S EXTENSIVE FUNDING
AND SO KALDERANS WHERE I'M ON
TRACK TO RECEIVE ZUMA KAMLAGER,
WHICH THE HIGHEST HONOR FROM U
C. DAVIS UH, BY THE TIME I
GRADUATE WITH MY TWO DEGREES BUT
I COULD HAVE ONLY DONE THIS
WITHOUT THE STRESSES AND BURDENS
OF SELF FUNDING. MY EVER RISING
UNIVERSITY TUITION, WHICH FOR
èC FORTUNATELY LOCKED IN MY
TUITION, BUT HADN'T BEEN
ANYWHERE ELSE, IT WOULD HAVE
STILL CONTINUED TO HIRE YET IT'S
VERY MUCH AN UNDERSTATEMENT TO
SAY THAT KALDERANS CHANGED MY
LIFE BY FUNDING MY COLLEGE
EDUCATION, AND FURTHERMORE, AND
MY FAMILY. I HAVE SIBLINGS WHO
ATTENDED COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND
MOVED ON TO SEE SUS AND HAVE
ALSO RECEIVED EXTENSIVE
FINANCIAL AID PACKAGES FROM
CALIFORNIA. AS YOU KNOW, HIGHER
EDUCATION, YOU KNOW, BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS, SO I'M A FAMILY OF
YOU KNOW, CALIFORNIA EDUCATED
FAMILY, SO I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT
ONCE AGAIN I ASK THIS COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT CALGARY AUNTS AND
CONTINUE TO CHANGE. MANY MORE
STUDENTS LIVES AND EASE THE
BURDENS OF RISING COLLEGE COSTS.
BECAUSE SO FAR, CALDERON ANTS
HAS DONE SO MUCH MORE THAN
MAKING COLLEGE COSTS MUCH MORE
MANAGEABLE BUT ALSO ACCESSIBLE.
IT MAKES IT BOTH EQUITABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE TO MAKE EACH STUDENT
DECIDE HOW THEY GET TO EXCEL IN
LIFE AS CAL GRANTS GAVE ME SO
MANY OPPORTUNITIES BY LETTING ME
ATTEND HERE AT U C. DAVIS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. HELLO I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
THANK EVERYONE TO DECIDED TO
PARTICIPATE AND ENGAGE IN
TODAY'S MEETING. IT IS IMPORTANT
TO HAVE A DIALOGUE ABOUT THE CAL
GRAHAM. PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF
. SO WE KNOW WHO YOU ARE. MY
NAME IS LUIS MARIN. UM IT IS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE A DIALOGUE
ABOUT THE CAL GRANT BECAUSE IT
HAS OPENED THE DOOR TO MANY OF
US TO ACHIEVE A HIGHER EDUCATION
AS A FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENT AND AN UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENT. I CAN SAY WITH
CERTAINTY THAT THE CALDERON HAS
BEEN A FUNDAMENTAL PART OF MY
ACADEMIC JOURNEY. I CANNOT HAVE
HIM IMAGINE BEING HERE WHERE I
AM TODAY IF STATE FUNDING LIKE
THE CAL GRANT DIDN'T EXIST, THIS
GENEROUS GRANT HAS ALLOWED ME TO
FOUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE, THE
SUPPLIES NECESSARY FOR SCHOOL
AND MY BOOKS. I REMEMBER MY
MOTHER TELLING ME SON IF IT
WASN'T FOR THE HELP YOU'RE
GETTING FROM FINANCIAL AID. I
DON'T THINK WE COULD HAVE
AFFORDED YOUR SCHOOLING. HAS A
LOW INCOME STUDENT WITH NO
OPPORTUNITIES TO WORK LEGALLY TO
MY STATUS. THE CALDERON HAS
HELPED ME MAKE COLLEGE
ACCESSIBLE AND IMPOSSIBILITY. IT
HAS ALSO ALLOWED ME TO BE ABLE
TO GO TO MY DREAM SCHOOL UC
DAVIS WHERE UP UNTIL THIS
QUARTER, I FOUND THAT MY
ELIGIBILITY WILL RUN RUN OUT.
THIS HAS MADE ME WORRY BECAUSE
CAL GRAHAM WAS ONE OF MY ONLY
SOURCE OF FUNDING SINCE 8540
STUDENTS DO NOT GET ACCESS TO
FEDERAL AID. MY ELIGIBILITY RAN
OUT BECAUSE OF THE TIME IT TOOK
ME TO NAVIGATE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND THE TRANSFER. TO FAMILY AND
FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS. IT WAS
DIFFICULT TO GRADUATE WITH THE
STEM ASSOCIATES DEGREE IN TWO
YEARS, ESPECIALLY AFTER THE
COVID 19 PANDEMIC AND THE
OBSTACLES THAT PRESENTED I HAVE
THE OPTIMISM WHO MAY NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE HIGHER EDUCATION
WITHOUT CAL GRANT AND THE
UNDERSERVED. I HAVE BEEN
FORTUNATE TO HAVE RECEIVED THE
CAL GRANT BUT HOPE THAT ITS
EXPANSION AND REFORM HELPS THE
FUTURE GENERATIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. I HOPE THAT MY
TESTIMONY HAS HIGHLIGHTED THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE CAL GRAHAM FOR
THE UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY. AND
BUT HAS ALSO SHOWCASED THE
NECESSITY OF ITS REFORM. AS IT
NOT ONLY IMPACTS CURRENT
STUDENTS, BUT THE FUTURE
GENERATIONS THAT LOOK AT US AS
ROLE MODELS. I APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS. I KNOW THEY MIGHT
NOT HAVE BEEN EASY. SO WELCOME
TO THE LAST SPEAKER. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. THANK YOU. UM
I WROTE GOOD MORNING, BUT GOOD
AFTERNOON. UM MY NAME IS CHILLY
SIGNS. I'M CURRENTLY A THIRD
YEAR STUDENT AT UC DAVIS. AND I
AM ALSO HERE TO ASK FOR THE
FUNDING OF THE CALGARY AND
EQUITY FRAMEWORK. I'M FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENT AND
ALSO A FIRST GENERATION HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATE, UM, FROM RURAL
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. I'M FROM
HYSTERIA, CALIFORNIA IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE. UM YEAH, SO
GROWING UP IN A HOUSEHOLD WHERE
MY FATHER IS DISABLED, AND MY
MOTHER WORKS AS HIS CARETAKER.
MY FAMILY WAS CONSISTENTLY
FACING FINANCIAL UNCERTAINTY,
AND CALDERON, FOR ME HAS BEEN A
BEACON OF HOPE IN MY PURSUIT OF
HIGHER EDUCATION. UM BACK HOME.
I AM FACED WITH POVERTY AND
LIMITED RESOURCES. BUT HERE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA, AND DAVIS,
UM AND SACRAMENTO, I HAVE A FORM
. I HAVE CURATED LIKE A
COMMUNITY OF STABILITY AND MY
EDUCATION AND STABILITY ARE TIED
TOGETHER BECAUSE OF MY
COMPOUNDED FINANCIAL AIDS AND
GRANTS. UM ONE OF THEM BEING CAL
GRANT, WHICH CONSISTENTLY HELPS,
UM MAKE MY EDUCATION COMPLETELY
FREE. UM AND SO THE PROPOSED
CALDERON REFORM IS NOT JUST
ABOUT FUNDING. IT'S ABOUT
SAFEGUARDING THE STABILITY OF
STUDENTS LIKE ME WHO RELY ON
THIS PROGRAM TO NAVIGATE THE
CHALLENGES OF PURSUING HIGHER
EDUCATION AND BY SUPPORTING THE
CALDERON IMPLEMENTATION AND THE
REFORMS AND ALLOCATING THE
FUNDING IN THE 2024 AND 2025
STATE BUDGET. YOU'RE NOT JUST
INVESTING IN A PROGRAM YOU'RE
INVESTING IN THE STABILITY AND
FUTURE SUCCESS OF STUDENTS WHO
DEPEND ON THE CALDERON. LIKE ME
TO OVERCOME THEIR ADVERSITY AND
ACHIEVE THEIR DREAMS, AS WELL AS
FUTURE STABILITY AND EDUCATION.
SO I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. ALONG COMMITTEE
HEARING, UM, AND THE PROFOUND
IMPACT OF YOUR SUPPORT ON
STUDENTS LIKE ME WHO ARE LIKE ON
CALDERON AS A PILLAR OF THEIR
EDUCATION. UM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS, AND WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS OF EVERYONE AND LET
ME JUST ALSO SAY FOR THE LAST
FEW THAT THAT JUST TESTIFIED.
OUR LAST HEARING WAS A COMPLETE
HEARING ON STUDENT AID. AND IF
YOU DIDN'T SEE IT, I BELIEVE
IT'S AVAILABLE ONLINE AND WE
WENT THROUGH THE EQUITY
FRAMEWORK AND OTHER THINGS, TOO.
SO I DON'T WANT YOU TO THINK
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T COME UP VERY
MUCH TODAY THAT WE GAVE SHORT
SHRIFT TO THEM. WE REALLY
REACHED OUT. I APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY FOR STICKING. TO IT
THAT COMPLETES AH, WHAT WE HAD
ON THE AGENDA AND IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY YOU
CAN SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
TO DO IT. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS, AS YOU HAVE JUST
HEARD ARE IMPORTANT TO US, AND,
UH, INDIVIDUAL STORIES ARE
REALLY HELPFUL WHEN WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
RECORDS THAT CONCLUDES OUR
HEARING. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S PARTICIPATION AND
PATIENTS WITH ITS LENGTH. BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE, ONE ON EDUCATION
WILL STAND ADJOURNED.